[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
within the Tempest the best have come to
test their skills and brave the storm
oh we missed it oh
my goodness the wheels the wheels have
come out that could be the match for
some this is familiar ground oh my
goodness Knight d8 whoa
oh my God what a tactic
this is insane oh look at Fabby
exhausting every last resource the
battles will be electricity
the moves will be fast it's game over
it's winning oh my God he's gonna make a
queen the stakes will be high he just
grabs his head he can't believe it he
just gave away the pawn the 2022 speed
Chess Championship is now
fasten your speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
another day another speed chess
championship match this time the
semi-finals I'm Grandmaster Robert Hess
alongside me my good friend Grandmaster
Daniel nerdinski Dania we had an
excellent display of Chess yesterday
between Maxine Buster legravas he
claimed the final spot in the semis
today is Sakara Nakamura versus
nielsarin
well Guten Morgen everybody it's bright
and early it's actually not bright it is
early it's incredibly rainy here and no
better way
than to just tuck yourself in with a cup
of coffee and watch Newhall play
Nakamura we'll be bringing you the
coverage we'll be doing the hard work
you just settle in and enjoy the ride
and the players will be doing the
hardest work because this is a touch of
commentators who do the hard work yeah
that's true as well but these players
they're vying for a spot in the finals
of the speed chess championships though
there is a lot at stake today as the
players well there's quite a bit of
money they're gonna be duking out for
some good hard cash but look at that in
addition to winning six thousand dollars
and a split of the additional six
thousand basil win percentage the winner
advances to the championship match and
Donya if we know anything about these
two that's all they care about right now
is that championship match uh slot that
they want to see themselves in yeah this
is one of the most prestigious trophies
tournaments in online chess to win the
SEC you have to cross countless hurdles
and then you have to cross the biggest
two hurdles of all Hikaru Nakamura and
very likely Magnus Carl Wilson as well
and just the chance to face the world
champion is what both of these players
are vying for and I thought I was
hallucinating because I thought I saw
two and then a four and now it's a six
and I'm not hallucinating the prize
keeps Rising based on where you are in
the tournament it does indeed the purse
increases it grows and of course the
championship match will have the biggest
person of all but you said obstacles and
it wasn't easy opportunity for the
players in order to overcome their
opponents to get here as we look at the
bracket Donya we see four names
remaining they are Nakamura you know
sarin Magnus Carlson and Maxime vashir
lagrav four very deserving
semi-finalists and Daniel what do you
make of the past that Hikaru and Neil
took to get here well the past could not
be more different if you look at Hikaru
just cumulatively he has some of the
most lopsided scores in the entire SCC
neither of his first two matches were
close at all I mean he beats per avian
by 12 points and then against aronian he
wins with a single digit lead but it was
a eventually a wire to wire Victory now
you look at Newhall bottom left he beats
anishikiri by one point withstanding a
furious bullet comeback and then even
his match against England yes he won by
eight in the end Robert but that's a
very deceptive final score because he
racked up the points in the final
segment it was closed throughout it
could have gone either way nehal will
have to bring his A-Plus game once again
today I could tell that's what you were
getting at that he needs to play his
best chest of all against a card
Nakamura and as we look at this matchup
between these two Hikaru has a monster
lifetime lead but look at their Blitz
ratings as of yesterday Dania nihal
slightly higher yeah that's crazy and
just look at those ratings both players
knocking on the door of 3200 but Hikaru
is also knocking on the door of a
ridiculous head-to-head lead I mean you
look at Hikaru scores against anybody
and you just see the wildest percentages
125 wins and only 31 losses so nihal
Robert has to defy the forces of nature
in both Blitz and bullet if he really
wants a shot at the finals well you're
mentioning Blitz and bullet we should
remind everybody of the format of these
events nothing has changed in the last
couple days as far as I'm aware so we
are still are in a 16 player knockout
tournament it's three different time
controls the tie breaks are four games
of bullet chess one minute plus one
second increment and of course we get
Armageddon with bidding if all is tied
but the format itself 90 minutes of five
minute plus one second a grid followed
by an hour of three plus one and last
but certainly not least people love to
see these players go head to head in
bullet chess because Neil sarin has been
3 400 a car would knock more very much
the same I think all will be settled in
that one minute plus one second
increment time control so Dania it's
exciting stuff here as we are getting
set for this match uh but as always you
know predictions smarter chess
predictions sometimes they're correct
like yesterday other times we feel like
they're wrong but I do know this Dania
he's one of five people with a perfect
bracket thus far you know smarter chess
I have to say through clenched teeth has
been nothing short of unbelievable I
mean predicting yesterday's match
knowing somehow that mvl is going to put
through just a ridiculous performance to
defeat a stalwart who's been displaying
monster form the last year even his
enemies have to tip their hat and in
this case that means the commentators
have to tip their head but really the
time control it's elegant it's easy to
follow and most importantly the match
can realistically be decided in any of
these three segments and if nihal sarin
wants a shot at this match he has to get
off to a very good start he cannot let
this match get out of hand in these
first 90 minutes Robert yeah nicar
Nakamura has said time and time again
that as long as he's within two points
heading into bullet he feels like he's
got a good chance of not being the
favorite against anybody but let's look
at those smarter chess predictions those
the breakdown that he has provided us he
believes that his car is a favorite in
all three time controls and a two-point
favorite in the longest and shortest
time controls a one point favorite in
the three plus one and he says that Neo
still has about a 30 chance what do you
make of the smart just stats well the
real question is where can nehal reverse
the narrative where could niho rack up
those points I think the prediction is
reasonable I think even the most uh
stalart knee-haw fans have to admit that
Hikaru is the heavy favorite in this
match there's no question about that but
nihal can also lean into that and it's
not easy to play when you've got an x on
your back I think the Hulk can really
step up in the bullet I think that's the
segment he needs to improve in the most
let's not forget that Anish Gary
actually defeated Anish nihal in the
bullet segment so Robert that cannot
happen today because Hikaru can easily
wipe out even a three or four point lead
uh with the way that he plays Bullet but
to play not Devil's Advocate but at
least to assess that performance in the
bullet that was very surprising and
Anish Geary is a great bullet player but
nihal sarin is like the best of the best
I know he hasn't been the bullet chess
champion bullet Chess Championship
Champion the BCC champ but is calling
except for a year where he lost allereza
farrugia so nihal starts always at the
top of the leaderboard so I feel like
you know maybe we sometimes have a
little bit of recency bias but you would
know better than anybody how many games
have you played against nihal sarin you
know what he's capable of I think I've
played well over a thousand as we admire
Newhall they're getting focused for his
match definitely well over a thousand
I'll look it up as the match gets
underway but we've played across all
sorts of time controls we played mostly
three plus zero one plus zero we've also
played 30 second chess he is
ridiculously fast with the mouse I mean
he's got all of the technical aspects
fully worked out and I haven't kept it a
secret that I'm a big knee-haw fan I
think he's awesome I think he's got a
super bright future uh not to mention
you know he's very classy and very very
humble so he's got the whole package
Robert but so does he Kara Nakamura and
Hikaru is just so consistent and so
stable and even though he doesn't play
as much bullet anymore he doesn't seem
to have lost all that much strength and
I think Hikaru is very thankful that
they have that one second increment
which is going to counteract whatever
rust he might be otherwise feeling in
the bullet segment it's a very good
point and the community stands behind
Hikaru Nakamura as they always do the
number one twitch streamer in the chess
category look at that of the brackets 89
say Nakamura is going to take down nihal
sarin 11 for the Indian superstar in the
making and 28 overall predicting this
matchup that's actually surprising to me
I guess a lot of people believe in
dingly Ren because I imagine almost
everybody had a car Nakamura through the
semifinals that means people were
picking against nihal and almost
everybody who watched last year's SCC
remember that dinglieren came within
just a centimeter of defeating Hikaru
Nakamura I mean that match was as close
as it gets that was the CaRu nakamura's
closest Victory I mean other matches
that he's won have just been basically
wired to wire so perhaps nihal actually
looked over that match maybe he analyzed
some film uh like athletes do he looked
at what dingley Wren played he looked at
how he made Hikaru Nakamura
uncomfortable because he is definitely
facing a vote of no confidence from the
community Robert well I think that could
if anything Inspire him to even greater
Heights nihal sarin he surprised the
World by making the finals of the
chess.com Global Championship where he
did lose to Wesley so but in the running
there he beat kramnik he'd beat dingley
Wren he beat Anish giri and he beat Sam
seven all in a row just to get to the
final so he's clearly somebody not to be
trifled with and as the players are
getting set for today's matchup Hikaru
Nakamura is in Florida and that's
something important to point out because
in California where he often is playing
from streaming from it would be 6 a.m
call time it's 9 A.M on the East Coast
so at least he's a little bit more awake
and Lively I'm pretty sure my mom is up
to watch this match in California so
there are some dedicated fans on the
west coast watching from bed but yeah
those additional three hours they really
help you Caro as the match kicks off and
a surprise on move one I see Cairo
repeats the shenanigans deep played
against David perovian Robert look at
this you hear professionals sometimes
say they just need to find the joy in
the game they don't want to go through
the motions A3 one of these obscure
moves that are not something that we
would advise however it often what do
you mean right back into normal
territory right that's the thing about
having the first move Advantage it's
essentially like you threw an A3 as if
you know nothing else happened so it's a
perfectly normal position nothing really
too uh out of the norm just yet and
actually look at this we're getting into
like a Queen's Gambit decline now you
need to speak for yourself Robert
because this is the recommendation my
upcoming opening course
um just kidding of course nowadays I
think people would believe absolutely
anything and we have indeed transposed
into a weird kind of souped up Queen's
Camp declined and normally in these
structures you actually don't want to
bring your light squared Bishop out
early precisely for this reason Queen B3
Robert is a very annoying move to face
because both typical ways of Defending
B7 Queen C8 it's awkward because because
you lose contact with the D5 pawn and
later on white can put a rook on C1 the
second way is V6 and it's pretty
self-evident why this move is weak near
creating a lot of holes on the queen
side that's I think why nihal sarin is
investing some time here what's
fascinating about this opening choice in
particular is that nihal is the one who
plays dodgy openings you don't really
need attempt him into it we saw that all
throughout the global Championship where
game after game with the black pieces he
was playing some kind of iffy stuff now
here a card was A3 on move one not the
biggest deal in the world even if it's
not something you see every day and now
we've reached a position where as you're
saying the queen is awkwardly placed on
C8 for black all of White's pieces thus
far on normal squares and what can't put
some pressure on D5 The Good News for
Neil you can also move Pawn C7 to C6 to
get the Triangle Pawn structure and keep
everything defended which is I think
precisely what he's gonna do no he takes
on C4 and maybe he wants to follow up
with C5 which is an ambitious way to
play contesting the center but of course
it's quite risky especially if white as
a bishop on F4 you could run into a very
nasty night escapod to B5 and then
Bishop D6 so as long as your dark scored
Bishop isn't developed you've got to be
very careful here if your knee Hall
Saran but I should point out Robert that
people are often under the misconception
that a move like A3 is terrible and the
black is somehow winning that's the case
with the grab one G4 which I believe is
the worst first move on the board
according to the engine but A3 is
actually not that bad and black I don't
think can get anything even resembling
an advantage it's just equal
right exactly I agree with you
completely and speaking of equal this is
what nihal SARS aiming for it plays
Bishop D6 let's trade off some pieces if
Bishop takes Pawn takes we can trade
queens and the one thing to keep an eye
on if we see a lot of Trades is this
Knight B5 jump you were mentioning that
earlier I think a lot of players would
see an opportunity to win a pawn and
they would just grab it right away so if
we can bring up an analysis board and
just show this variation right where we
just get this swap everywhere with
Knight to B5 well this looks very
interesting but black can even bring the
king up to E7 in many of these positions
defend that pawn connect the Rooks and
white is woefully underdeveloped and
even 94 deserves consideration because
hey you're getting forked no I'm not
King d8 and your queen is hanging you
mentioned undeveloped that's where white
pays the price it gets super messy here
but that's kind of what niho starn wants
he wants these messy positions early in
the match to give himself a chance and
guess what Robert let's give ourselves a
pat on the back it might be early but we
already have made a money prediction
this is on the 40 Caro has played Knight
B5 wow so back to the live board you
know quite and there's King E7 I called
by you would be okay but oh my gosh
creeping up is the are you saying 936
there's like a check manic attack or
winning the queen if the king's winning
the queen that's precisely what I'm
saying remember Robert not so long ago I
mentioned that the queen on C8 could
succumb to a rook C1 tactic well that's
become the reality Hikaru is calculating
that Knight takes D6 wins the pawn and
forces black to acquiesce to the queen
trade I don't know if it's worth
bringing up another analysis board
because I have no doubt in my mind that
he carves going for this yeah because
the whole point is that the king is
drawn out to D6 then Queen B4 check the
King has to step on the C file in which
case Rook C1 is going to be devastating
but I think after Knight takes D6 if a
car does indeed play it um we could see
a queen trade Rook H to C8 and actually
that's in the nature of this very
position how many openings are
variations within the Queen's Gambit
declined in similar positions the nimzo
in particular do we see black give up a
pawn for the quick activity and look at
it garbage does not take the pawn and
listen that actually might have been the
reason he refrained from it I think
you're absolutely right black is a big
lead in development and initiative on
the queen side and Hikaru has shown a
propensity early in SEC matches to be
relatively solid even though he's played
1a3 he doesn't want to take too many
risks early he kind of wants to settle
into the match and he often really makes
his big push at the start of the three
plus one segment that's kind of what
I've anecdotally noticed and so maybe
he's influenced by that in the early
going I really like newhall's position
now he can drive the white king out to
D2 but Robert that's not necessarily a
good thing because then you're helping
white play Rook C1 so a lot of nuances
in this position it's quite amusing and
counterintuitive you think bringing that
King out in the center that has to be
bad but look at the black king on E7
it's surrounded by its own pieces nice
and safe and sound and allows that Rook
on h8 to connect with the Rook on A8 so
just like Black's King is safe on E7
White's King will be perfectly at home
on D2 and as you're mentioning Rook C1
would then be in after option because
the square is protected so I think if
you are knee-haul here you make a move
like say queen to C6 bring your queen up
so you can bring a rook to C8 love the
move Queen to C6 white could respond by
pushing the Knight off of E4 with F3 but
the situation definitely very dicey for
white
unless until he manages to get his light
squirt Bishop out and coordinate his
heavy pieces
and look at the clock situation by the
way hikar Nakamura down on time I
thought without looking the Niha would
be because he it seems like he's had
several long things yeah has been deep
in the think tank the last few moves uh
with the trade on D6 and then moves like
Queen to B4 so right now Neil doing well
in the clock he needs to avoid getting
into terrible time pressure and he plays
a four here line the queen to go back to
B4 with a queen C2 check at the very
least that looks scary for the white
king and I think this move is a mixture
of tactical thinking concreteness
noticing Queen before Queen C2 check and
then you can bring the Rook up to defend
the D6 Pawn but it's also very
positional you're locking in the light
squares on the queen side you're setting
yourself up for success in an eventual
end game you can think about the Knight
coming into C4 in all of these lines the
fact that White's Queen side pawns have
been immobilized is a great thing and
Hikaru says Queen C2 check I'm laughing
in the face of danger and there it is
Rook A6 on the board and F3 a move that
you indicated as an option earlier now
E4 is next but look at black terrifying
all of the pieces into the position uh
the bishop is under attack you could
even sack on e4 let's open it some more
and you absolutely should take twice and
bring the Rook to C2 and I'm shocked
that White's not getting mated here
according to the Eva barkikaru might
have to play Bishop E2 after Queen takes
E4 check and give up the house on the
king side right G2 Falls and likely H2
after that uh but the evil are saying
0.4 in Black's favor that's just a
little bit that means one mistake from
from nihal means that white might have a
winning Advantage because that's the
nature of the position when you give up
a piece for several pawns but I think
Hikaru is you know he's probably a
little bit
on edge right now he didn't expect you
to bring it to him like this and he goes
King D1 he said I'm not giving you G2 at
the very least we have a draw
and niho might actually take this job
because neither player wants to take
undue risk at the start of the match
both players want to get on the board
you're also playing Hikaru Nakamura if
you don't want to draw Rook a to C6 is
an option to consider to bring the Rook
into the game maybe pave the way for
Rook C2 but amazingly Robert I'm not
really seeing any concrete mating
construction so if I had to make a guess
I think nihal is likely to go for the
straw and if he doesn't that would be a
super gutsy decision that we could all
stand behind but I don't know if it's
worth it against icaro but if you're Neo
you spend the rest of your time you know
you have a draw with Queen Z2 Queen E4
that will be a three-time repetition so
you spend in the next minute calculating
going deep maybe Rook a to C6 as you
mentioned maybe Queen G4 check just to
ask that King is it gonna go up to D2 in
which case Rook a to C6 and we'll try to
go to C2 but no he does the I think the
very pragmatic thing here down to mix
draw we're tired what a game one game
what a first game so much fireworks a
lot of subtlety and really really good
play from from both players they're
tactically sharp in the early going and
I think that bodes really well for the
likelihood of a close entertaining match
nehal with the white pieces in game two
and this time we get an actual Queen's
Gambit and Hikaru accepts it with d
takes C4
and plays A6 Hikaru has played this in
many events including classical chess
over the board so he is accustomed to
these types of positions but niho had
some great games against Anish giri in
these types of positions in the global
Championship do you remember those games
Dania where it felt like it was pretty
acoustic quality and then he'll just
outplayed his uh Dutch opponent so I
feel like nihal feels very at home in
this type of structure he loves this
structure that's a great observation and
I've had a ton of Blitz Games Against
nehal where he goes for this structure
which appears so deceptively symmetrical
now you might ask well what about it is
asymmetrical well it's one thing in
particular the placement of the dark
scored Bishop this bishop is so Superior
to its counterpart which sits on a much
less glamorous diagonal now black
doesn't really have any Targets I think
Hikaru is going to manage to equalize
from this position but it often takes a
lot of time to contain the activity of
White's pieces as Nakamura brings his
Bishop out to a rather ambitious D6
Square but now you have to watch out for
tactics down the D file right like
Knight D2 to F3 uh it goes like Oh D
Bishop F6 all right Bishop says 94 good
uh I by nihal sarin here it looks so
weird right where you could bring yeah
less active Knight to F3 why not but
he's keeping more pieces on the board
and not only is Bishop takes F6 a threat
there could be an argument in the future
for Pawn E4 which threatens Pawn to E5
and whoa the car just castles allowing
Bishop takes F6 and I was actually gonna
point this out this is an instructive
decision I'm not sure it's the best
decision but a lot of players rule this
out just on principle I can't ruin my
king side structure but you see this in
the ex in the French D take C4 you see
this in some openings Bishop F6 GF is
not the end of the world and Robert
black can actually repurpose the king
side off into his favor by dropping the
King on the relatively safe h8 square
and then bringing the Rook to the
semi-openg file so we actually see nihal
refraining from what I thought was the
main idea of Knight to uh for F3 yeah
and instead he goes let's go for
expansion on the queen side A3 B4 he can
sit as Queen on B3 if he'd like bring a
rook to C1 or Rook to D1 and it's clear
where many of White's pieces belong the
difficult part is after that okay Queen
E2 looks perfectly natural but then what
that's the key question and one thing
that you have to keep in mind is that
when you extend your Pawn so much black
and strike with an A6 to A5 move so be
careful
yeah that before Pawn can be used as a
queen side hook and if you mindlessly
push it to B5 not only does it become
weak but you leave a lot of weak squares
in its wake and E5 by Hikaru I like that
move he's trying to drop his Pawn on e4
get this Knight out of the picture and
then Bishop G4 is going to be a problem
don't sleep on a potential Greek gift
sacrifice his pieces look deceptively
passive but they could all combine in a
king side attack real fast here so an
important moment here for Newhall uh to
not Sleepwalk through
and maybe he can play Pawn E4 himself
but that does give up control of the D4
squared now the Knight on F3 and Bishop
and B2 excuse me cover the square the
Knight on D2 will likely go to B3 and
maybe into C5 so he does play this Pawn
push and the D5 scores under White's
control the D4 screw would like to be
under a car's control he's just not
there quite yet
okay so he can play Bishop B6 here to
improve his dark Spirit Bishop I feel
like that's kind of a Hikaru move you
could also continue with Rook C8 and
Rook d8 you know those moves are pretty
good Bishop D7 to G4 comes to mind as
well to pave the way for Knight T4 so a
lot of positionally critical moments
early as the players kind of decide
where they want their pieces to be and
there's Knight on D2 that's the one bad
piece in White's position you'd rather
be on the E3 square right now hopping
into F or D5 that takes a long time
Knight F1 Knight E3 Knights takes many
moves and the E4 Pawn is loose you're
pointing at Knight G4 to attack F2 as
well so you're you don't have time for
that you can put H3 but then Knight H5
is very tempting trying to go into F4 as
you uh you know mention this E3 push to
E4 gives control of other squares yeah
it's really weird when you look at this
position uh in in a perfunctory manner
but White's actually quite uncomfortable
on the king side Robert it's it's
strange to even say it but there's all
sorts of ideas Knight G4 you mentioned
Knight H5 Bishop B3 I really like as
nihal drops the bishop back and saying
the Knight wants the parking spot and
Knight C4 can later drop back to E3 so I
think this idea is on his mind and
importantly Knight G4 can be met with
the simple Rook D1 and F1 not the
coolest looking move but it does the job
doesn't it it does indeed and that night
jump into C4 as you mentioned hits the
bishop it's the E5 Pawn you can also
bring that Knight to E3 and into D5 so
it's a moment that you see what White's
plan is and you as you're pointing out
Knight G4 Rook F1 does that really
accomplish all that much and we tend to
think well if I ever take on F2 that's
giving up two minor pieces for rook and
a pawn that can never be good sometimes
you have to look for things like that
but here it does not work so uh for
Hikaru who's once again down on time
that's in I think an underrated
storyline Nihao Saran I feel like is
always the one who has less time but in
the first two games he's actually built
up a sizeable lead on the clock and is
that a conscious adjustment entirely
possible I'm positive that the player's
preparation extended past the opening
especially in the case of nehal because
you need something special you need a
healthy dose of nasty if you want to
beat Hikaru Nakamura in a three hour
match and I'm sure that nihal maybe got
some coaching maybe thought long and
hard about what his overall meta
strategy would be and that in includes
time management love hikaru's move
Bishop E6 so alert recognizing that the
bishop on B3 is undefended and this
trade Robert don't know who it favors
but that Knight on B6 is kind of going
to get stranded and it's going to be
nowhere near E3
it will not be near E3 and it's just a
trade opposite colored Bishops you're
protecting the bishop on B6 by pinning
this Knight on C4 and nihal now he's
trying to work through this position he
can start trading Rooks right now but
you have to look out for Knight G4 at
some point Bishop takes C4 followed by
Knight G4 if all those Rooks are off
you're not going to be able to protect
the F2 Pawn so you have to be very
careful right now
great Point let's bring up an analysis
board real fast here and I'll show this
line now it should be pointed out that
if you just blindly trade all the Rooks
after Rook D1 Queen D1 you don't want to
rush with Knight takes C4 if you're
black that blunders the bishop on B6
because now B3 is under control what you
want to do is take first and now Knight
G4 works but even better is to grab this
Pawn on the way and to add insults to
injury white cannot defend F2 in his
position collapses so the simplification
approach doesn't work for an e-hole and
for the first time he has now dropped
significantly behind on the clock back
to the lifeboard we go and the hall
continues to ponder this situation
Nation it chooses a very calm move just
H3 to stop Knight G4 yay stops Knight G4
but he makes Knight H5 more attractive
because the way you usually stop Knight
H5 to F4 is by playing Pawn to G3 but
you can't do that here for two reasons
one as you're pointing out you have two
opponent is pinned and two the H3 Pawn
is loose because The Bishop's on E6 but
I would consider Bishop A7 for a car
just to keep that Bishop safe inside
maybe even threaten the move B7 to B5 at
some point to try to execute this piling
up pressure on a pin piece but Knight H5
also is in your back pocket and he puts
Bishop D4 instead and the engine doesn't
mind it but wow what a complicated move
to make with all trades on the table
Yeah that would not be in my top three
Canada moves that was really out of left
field but this is what Hikaru Nakamura
does he senses when you get low on time
when you start feeling uncomfortable
with your position and then he throws
this weird wrinkle at you and forces you
to invest even more time adjusting to
the new set of circumstances so what's
happening here I would anticipate that
Niha will take the bishop what is he
going to take it with well Knight takes
D4 comes to mind and Robert my guess is
that ikar wants to recapture with the
Knight and eliminate White's dark scored
bishop and that pawn on D4 is probably
going to be more of a nuisance than a
weakness if your knee-haul that's right
and the open E file puts pressure on the
E4 Pawn so I think that nihal trying to
figure this all out right now but if he
takes on D4 it's a flurry of Trades all
those minor pieces are coming off
because black is pre-moving Knight takes
D4 and it's played and he did and there
we go and the pieces are off the board
but the position has gotten no less
complex and nihal has to try to simplify
with 30 seconds left I love the move
Knight A5 in the event that Hikaru takes
on B3 and takes on e4 Niha will
recapture on T4 and that position I
think you'll be comfortable drawing even
with 20 seconds left absolutely it's
just liquidation all pawns will come off
in the center all these minor pieces but
frankaru who's ahead in the clock he may
say let's keep this game going I have a
past Depot maybe you can play Rook D7
for example which allows you to double
Brooks protect the B7 Pawn one more time
so that you can take on E6 with the
queen so things like this are in the
cards for Hikaru but I don't know
there's also some risk there I
understand he's ahead in the clock but
he has his isolated Pawn which is an
asset if it's a pass Pawn but it's a
liability if you can't protect it well
that's a great Point Rook D7 you also
have to reckon with E5 because Knight
can't easily step into D5 the D4 Pawn
drops there are some tactics there with
Knight C3 that have to be calculated but
Newhall has erased his time deficit as
Hikaru makes this important early match
decision Bishop takes B3 basically a
draw Rook D7 keeps pieces on the board
and SC cargo drops behind on the clock
he actually goes for Bishop back to C8
opening up more pressure on the E4 Pawn
an E5 plate I'm a little bit worried
about some kind of queen E4 Bishop C2
not yet because the knight's jumping
right into C3 and the tactic that you
were mentioning earlier Rook D4 is a
blunder because of Knight C3 and after
the trade on D4 there'll be a fork on
the E2 square and we don't have time to
really show that right now nihal
dropping to 15 seconds down you do he's
got to make a move he's got to find
stuff they may Rook Knight C3 Knight C3
so scary and don't sleep on Knight F4 he
tries to prevent both at the same time
but Hikaru can just pick up this pawn
and simultaneously defend what will now
be an extra Center Pawn wow I think he
was counting rookie one here but the
queen can slide over to keep the Knight
on D5 defended C4 things are slipping
away from neosarin right now seven
seconds remaining great move Queen F4
you mentioned that Daniel doubling
Brooks is not going to help that
position and will be defended and look
at this he pushes the pawn up to D3 now
you can see what neho is trying to do
he's trying to go G3 but that doesn't
solve any problems the Knight has a
million strongholds and there comes
taking on a location and it's mate yeah
if the king went to the H file this is
over Knight F4 it's one zero one
hits the rook and threads Rook H1 mate
that is resign time and actually it's a
win on time for hikar Nakamura he takes
the first lead of the match and if
you're nihal sarin you're probably very
upset about that one because it looked
like you had things under control and
look at this H3 move won this game the
move I think that won the previous game
is actually Bishop E6 to C8 that was a
devilish decision in nihal's time
pressure because it created the right
amount of threats it threatened the E4
pawn it made me all panic and that is
what Hikaru Nakamura does best and
that's what he's done add infinitum in
the first two SEC matches but look at
this we talked about one A3 this Robert
is far more outlandish
objectively this is not as good because
uh black and often strike at this G4
Pawn with H5 but you don't want to do
that too early you may think oh let me
crack the pawn chain over there G5 as
you mentioning that your knight has to
move again that's not ideal and white
would control the D5 Square uh with all
of his pieces so uh not that terrible of
a line even if you know you see the
engine say black is better I actually
really like the move H6 I know the
engine is saying it gives away Black's
Advantage but it doesn't allow the
complications that Hikaru undoubtedly
wants and this one could think of as a
normal English right you get this
position with the pawns on G3 and H2 One
Step removed
there's no question in my mind that the
pawn sitting on G4 favors black it
creates long-term weaknesses on the king
side and with the pawn on C4 it's not
really fair to forecast that White's
gonna castle queenside and try to use
these pawns for attacking purposes white
has too many weaknesses already on the
queen side so what I'm curious about in
the early going is how Hikaru is going
to manage his King safety is he actually
gonna castle kingside and say I don't
care that my Pawn's on G4 or is he gonna
keep his King in the center and try to
play creatively
and the fact that hikara is spending all
this time feels like this isn't some
kind of deep preparation right he
doesn't play H3 and G4 it's not a system
that you know sometimes people are
system players hey Carlos B3 and even if
the engine says black is doing well in
some of those positions he knows them
inside and out so he is more well-versed
he goes Knight F3 here he is trying to
just develop his pieces
um The Pawn on E5 can indeed push up to
E4 but that also may become a Target as
the game continues the Knight of six
defends there the queen can try to come
out to E7 but the E4 Pawn sticks out
like a sore thumb so I do feel like if
you're knee-haul you may refrain from
that move just for the time being and
nihal from a meta-strategy perspective
as E4 is played has to avoid getting
tilted right because when you're down in
the match and your opponent continues to
play these off-beat openings you start
getting annoyed because you start
telling why can't I punish him for one
H3 I mean I'll punish anybody except
Hikaru for this and your decisions start
becoming less objective let's see if
Newhall can avoid that here as he pushes
D5 eval bar dislikes it what do you make
of it Robert Bishop before he had a good
position until he played the move D5 and
the reason why his position was pretty
good is the E4 Pawn was actually
Untouchable for the time being because
if white ever traded on e4 the night on
F6 would get out the way and then H4
would be loose so maybe a bit of a
calmer move would have been uh better
but Bishop takes E4 here 193 you take
back with a Pawn on C3 and then while
the Knight on H4 is hanging so is the
bishop on B4 it's kind of a crazy
sequence now that we've come to it Dania
and Neal flat out blunder this I think
he might have overlooked that after
Bishop takes C3 Hikaru takes back with
the d-pawn and the Knight on D5 is in
the crosshairs of two of White's pieces
this is flat out an extra pawn and the
worst thing is that if you drop back to
F6 and say give me your Bishop because
the Knight is hanging guess what the
Knight is no longer hanging because
you're intercepting the queen and after
Knight F6 the bishop could safely return
to G2 or even jump into F5 nehal has
blundered his Center pawn and somehow
some way Hikaru is has a plus over minus
position nine moves into a game that
started H3 G4
unbelievable right Knight takes C3 just
Pawn takes the bishop on B4 is hanging
there so Knight on H4 can be captured
but it's in fact a trade so wow a car
Nakamura not just gets away with it but
he's in charge right now and nihal he
needs to stay calm because the position
isn't that bad even if he's down upon
for the time being a car's King won't
find true safety and that will always
give him compensation and knee-haul is
so good at generating chances out of
sometimes completely lost positions we
saw it in the cgc on full display
against M7 and we saw it in his previous
match against Anish giri there were a
couple of games when he was getting
checkmated Seven Ways to Sunday and he
gets out of it he often wins those games
but Hikaru Nakamura is neither of those
players and he just doesn't let you go
when he gets anything that even smells
like a winning position I like to move
Bishop E6 though this shows composure
and You Haul doesn't tilt he gets his
pieces out and I think he should just
Castle here I agree that's what we keep
talking about the white king will not
find true shelter so that will always
give black compensation especially in a
short time Patrol game now if we look at
the clock it's pretty close on time it
cars still is about three minutes uh
nailed down to two and a half but where
is that King on E1 going I think that
nihal needs to make some of his
decisions a little bit more quickly I
know that's easier said than done when
you're playing Hikaru Nakamura uh but
another tactic to avoid I believe
there's some some possible ways to
blunder if you like a B4 B5 but it
doesn't quite work in this position
especially with the white King still
anyone but you do have to monitor the E7
Square because the fork could come
precisely when you least expect it I'm
totally on the same page and you all has
to move fast here and I would have
played the move Bishop A5 quickly he
goes Bishop C5 allowing D2 D4 so he's
trying to provoke this move and try to
overextend Hikaru but I'm a little bit
skeptical about this strategy I'm as
well uh D4 does tactically work out for
white but he's just trying to say
hiccard push pieces forward that will
leave squares vulnerable let me attack
things uh but if he can establish
heaping Hikaru upon a D4 and E3 then
everything seems pretty stable though
the bishop on C1 is the piece that
suffers yeah it's gonna be looking into
the eyes of the E3 Pawn but that's not a
mission critical piece to develop and
everything else about hikara's position
is is healthier than it was just a
couple of moves ago but D4 not a move to
be made lightly that is a very very
committal Pawn advance and there are
alternatives you could also play B4
which is I think what Hikaru was
planning in the event of Bishop A5 B4 I
think nihal is just gonna drop back to
B6 and it's the same general strategy
the Knight on C3 is a little bit looser
actually before you could take C3 and
take D1 and take F2 and so Hikaru does
end up opting for D4 the best thing that
nihal has done here is he's posing
questions to Karu we see the advantages
going up it's at 1.4 approximately right
now and you know as the engine gets its
depth it will continue changing but the
point is that individual moves are more
complicated for a car and if you look at
the clock down here right now a car is
actually behind by quite a bit he had a
30 second lead now it's Niha with the 30
second lead and from a blitz perspective
Bishop C5 actually might end up being a
really smart decision I like the way
egal is playing this very cagey moves
Rook f8 to E8 maybe I'm not threatening
anything in particular but I'm creating
the preconditions for a tactic and I'm
setting myself up for a potential time
scramble that's what nihal's thinking
right now and the move G6 is playable
here it might not work out but if Knight
takes H6 King G7 the Knight gets caught
on H6 the queen covers the G5 Square so
you can't just push your Pawn so maybe
it doesn't work just yet but that's
something to consider and not to mention
the light squares on the queen side
after I move like Knight C3 if we trade
there and then play Knight A5 we can
just play this strategically white skin
Still Remains unsafe and black is
dominating those light squares on C4 and
B3 that's a super instructive idea and
it's important to remember that even
though you're a pawn down that doesn't
mean positional chess goes out the
window that doesn't mean all you can do
is play for tricks and play for tactics
you can play for square control you're
just down a pawn I love Knight takes C3
and Knight A5 you could follow up with
C6 the blunt White's light squared
bishop and later on the queen has a nice
parking spot on F6 to exert a little bit
of pressure on White's King side and
don't forget about the possibility of
pushing H5 and trying to undermine the
Knight later on
he didn't forget he plays it immediately
it happens to be a move the engine
doesn't appreciate but I think in Blitz
it's still a perfectly fine move if a
car takes on H5 pandemonium Breaks Loose
if he doesn't well there's always the
opportunity to take on G4 open another
file on the king side and the King on G1
does feel like a less safe piece not to
mention Diamond G6 becomes even more
tempting because you don't hang up on an
H6 that's exactly right and a lot of
players hesitate to make a move like H5
isn't my king also on the king side well
he's not really disrupting the
fundamental Pawn shell he still has
pawns on F7 and G7 so black skin is
completely safe for the time being
although if Hikaru recaptures with a
queen which is not out of the question
that will threaten Checkmate in one yeah
because the queen can't slide to F6
without dropping the Knight on D5 that
Queen on d8 is overloaded I love the
move Queen takes G4 hey Carl is thinking
about it but he's down to 30 seconds
while Neil is 57 so this is gonna remain
complicated and Hikaru he needs to speed
up a bit and a major sunk cost there
something about Queen takes G4 he didn't
like maybe it was G6 which lets a
tactical complications Hikaru trying to
keep things tight and keep things simple
as he drops to 30 seconds a big chance I
think here for a knee-haul if he can
continue complicating the game I still
like Knight C3 and Knight A5 he starts
with G6 so 93 95 will still be there and
Knight G3 seems very logical but he was
Knight H6 that's a huge move from Caro
and E4 so his Center is in danger but
the Knight on H6 is protected if Knight
C3 bc3 suddenly the D4 Pawn has a friend
attached to it what a decision by akaru
and what a friend it is blunting two of
whites Black's minor pieces at once and
look at that 99 H6 it seems to be
totally idle but it's actually blocking
the a trial and that is crucial because
if it didn't well I could have quickly
played Queen H4 in Rook h8 as it stands
white could even shove the pawn down to
G5 and cement the Knight on H6 nihal
doesn't find a move and he continues
trying to create threats here but he's
now down on the clock and he's burning
so much time in the process Queen H4
there's almost like a rook E3 Rook H3
lift at some oh yeah that could be bad
for the black king rugby G5 Pawn loose
that could be troubled eight seconds
Rook date looks really good threading 90
Saturn Knight takes D4 Queen just jumps
out seven is defended but F6 is not
Queen F6 check a pretty big threat and
they all just desperately trying to
complicate the game this is obviously
unsound I think he car can just take and
go Rook B1 and I don't see a follow-up
here for black I think he's just down a
piece there is no fob Bishop effort
giving up the Rook on A1 I like that
decision as well get those minor pieces
off the board the white king is safe and
sound right now a queen trade don't mind
goodbye
wow goodbye a car could have traded
queens and won that game very simply and
said he wins on the spot that's a
hanging piece Hikaru Nakamura a man on a
mission playing H3 and H3 leading to
Victory I mean the guy plays like an
engine and time scrambles this is what
makes him so debilitating to the face he
spent the entire game trying to
complicate things you find creative
ideas on both sides of the board you get
him low on time and it's like nothing
ever happened he makes three or four
precise moves and your initiative just
evaporates faster than a puddle on a hot
day
well here we see the Queen's Gambit
accepted I didn't know if that was a
good analogy but I I'm gonna accept it
anyway I vented it on the spot so give
me a little slack no I'm I'm here for it
and we see the same opening once again
nehal liked his position and here if you
remember correctly he went Knight D4 to
F3 this time he plays Bishop back to E2
so Neil making good retreating moves
because he wants his C4 Square for his
Knight so I love the way Neo is
reshuffling his pieces but a card
Nakamura seems unfazed generally
speaking when nihal is trying to figure
out the right path forward and in
general I don't want to talk too much
about meta strategy that strategy but I
think it's very important when you're
playing Hikaru nihal knew this was a
possibility right losing 2-0 to Hikaru
losing my two points at the start of the
match that's just Woody Carr does he
gets off to really fast starts and you
just got to remind yourself hey it's a
super long match these first two games
were very close I just think the hall
has to be a little bit more precise in
the opening he needs to turn up the dial
just a bit and not give Hikaru those
tactical opportunities in the opening
and early middle game that he's had thus
far but again so much easier said than
done
that's true Rook C1 very natural move
Knight C4 is another one Bishop F3 I see
a three moves for white and every turn
for black you see a card he's deep in
the think tank he's already down a
minute on the clock because every single
move has a consequence here you may kind
of mindlessly play Queen to E7 but then
Knight C4 and if your Bishop goes to C7
Bishop A3 and you have to watch out for
the skewer in the diagonal so he takes
on D4 plants his Bishop on A3 but I
think Rook C2 can be played now Knight
C4 will hit that bishop and it feels
like White's pieces are coming out in
full force and it does and that old idea
Bishop D4 takes F6 that conversation has
been reopened because after Queen F6
Knight C4 actually hits both Bishops
it's a moot point now Hikaru the prize
one oh Knight B1 exactly Bishop analysis
board please analysis board please this
is sick even if nehal doesn't play this
Queen takes F6 now you can't go Knight
C4 Knight B1 undeveloping the Knight and
hitting the bishop I love those types of
moves Robert this one's a piece yes so G
takes F6 would be four so he put gf6 on
the board it looks like that black king
is vulnerable but as you were saying in
some of the other positions that if a
kid can slide safely slide to h8 you'd
be doing okay but you can't in this
position the bishop 1 D7 is loose you're
talking about the fork on F6 Rook C2 to
D2 would be a huge threat as well so I
think okay can't take he didn't so we're
getting into a different line I mean but
same friends are still there exactly we
were getting the same structure he
played Rook C8 I'll just show really
quickly there was a trade and then he
did take ups and he's making all the
same moves it's just a pair of Brooks's
gun okay Queen D4 going right for the
f61 king G7 is one way to defend it
another way is E5 and a car plays that
but the reason why you don't like
playing those moves you don't do it
without really considering uh the
positions the D5 Square the F5 Square
these light squares are more likely to
be under White's control you have a
knight and a bishop the bishop on E7
cannot defend light squares but the
Knight can help with the bishop on F3 as
you're showing with arrows here that the
light squares are quickly under white
control the Queen's on B6 and I think
Knight G3 right now looks very good
because there's sneaky threat a bishop
to B7 trying to pick up the A6 Pawn
great call and good vision of both sides
of the board these pawns are vulnerable
they're sitting ducks and Hikaru needs
to smoke that Queen out of B6 Pronto I
think he should play Bishop E7 to C5 but
the Queen's not gonna go very far it's
just gonna sit on A5 and annoy the heck
out of you Rook C1 is going to be a
problem after that nihal has to try to
squeeze this game into a full point yeah
and the problem with Bishop C5 as well
is that Bishop is needed to find F6
we're talking about Knight G3 to F5 in
some dream world but then it's going to
H5 it's going to sit there and pester
the pawn on F6 so the bishop on E7 is
going to sit defensively look at the
clock by the way it carved down to two
minutes 20 seconds of change and Neil
had four minutes and 18 seconds you
could tell he is very comfortable
despite the two game deficit Dania he's
feeling the rhythm of this position
because he knows that he's getting good
positions out of the opening he likes
that Hikaru keeps repeating this line he
feels comfortable in these structures
and he's going to keep repeating this
for as long as it takes but can he
capitalize on this opportunity F5 by
Hikaru he allows Bishop B7 and if I'm
reading him right he wants to play Queen
C5 in response he wants to induce a
queen trade and then trap the bishop on
A6 with Rook f8 qb8 it's a complex idea
it's an interesting idea and he wants to
turn the game around by giving up a pawn
okay well Neil plays Bishop B7 no reply
yet by a car I'm trying to read his face
too he's going active
so Queen takes A6 but what's the
follow-up the queen looks imposing but
where is he going from here because if
you play F4 Robert
you give up also the E4 square and you
continue to weaken your king side so
you're paying the price here if you're
hikara with more active moves and
amazingly enough after F4 maybe bishop
E4 so that way you can play Knight F5 uh
that could be really annoying for a car
to deal with you give up all these light
squares he was Rook to B8 but the bishop
B7 protected by the queen over there no
threats at the moment for Hikaru and
nihal he has grabbed a pawn and looks
like he's going to escape with it and
Rook V8 those are the types of moves we
take for granted we pass over them but
they are what make Hikaru Hikaru right
he's down two minutes so many people
would Panic with F4 allowing that very
pretty positional idea you pointed out
but Hikaru he's fine keeping the tension
he says hey I'm a pawn down but White's
minor pieces are still scattered I'm
gonna use my pieces and try to create
threats and try to equalize the clock
Bishop F3 getting out of there running
away fast threading Queen A7 as well
hitting the Rook on B8 and the bishop 27
nikaru making good defensive move after
good defensive move bringing the queen
back so all the blacks pieces are
coordinated and if you can imagine the
Queens are off the board then it's a one
Pawn Advantage but with the bishop pair
it's gonna be very hard for white to
make use of that extra Pawn on the queen
side and Hikaru making the most of his
damage to kingside structure this is
about as good as it's going to get and
you probably want to avoid pushing any
more pawns I pointed out F4 E4 has a
similar problem it greatly weakens the
F4 Square allowing the Knight to jump
around so you're only going to play a
move like that if you have a concrete
follow-up Rook D1 by knee hall both
players kind of moving their pieces into
position and keeping the tension King G7
by Nakamura allowing a tempting check on
H5 but it's a bit of a dead end as it
currently sits right then the king just
go back and it doesn't seem at the end
of the world forward
you could go for it I was a little
worried about going on the sixth rank
with the pin there but Rook be 6 would
be a follow-up so you're absolutely
right I think for nihal he just needs to
find Luft he plays H3 right away
E4 would be a very bad move as you
mentioned Knight could go to H5 to F4
eventually so hecar's Pawn stuck in
place you can play Rook B6 but then that
walks into Queen a five pinning The Rook
things get a little bit awkward there no
this is good play by nihal I mentioned
keeping the tension that's one of the
narratives of this game as both players
jockey for position nehal kind of
waiting like a tiger in a cage for the
opportunity to strike but he's already
up upon he doesn't need to do anything
concrete and it's an incredibly
uncomfortable position for Hikaru who
finds nothing better than sort of a
semi-waiting move Donna check your watch
look what look at the time here hicaro
down under a minute Neo with two and a
half this is a problem for cars not just
the pawn I think objectively the
position is still okay for black but
simple move like Bishop E2 here right or
nehal just attack the B5 Pawn create one
move threats if you play B4 maybe white
plays Bishop C4 you would love to trade
the light Square Bishops Bishop D5 would
serve that purpose but it walks into a
pin with Rook to d8 that's why you can't
trade the Bishops just yet but you would
love to get the bishop 186 off the board
it should be two is a great move keep
needling him keep poking him like that
annoying Facebook feature which was
really popular a while back it should be
two you can force B4 you get your light
squares in order and Bishop C4 will
force the light squared Bishops off the
board and weaken the F5 Pawn
and Neil now thinking he has time to
spare uh what other moves come to mind
says Bishop E2 I I actually I'm not
really seeing too many attractive
options I have another idea what's that
Bishop E2 okay
wow that's a really novel concept
it reminds me I was watching the
Olympics in in uh 2012 in London I think
it was 2012 and the Nigerian basketball
coach uh famously said there are three
teams that uh our national team has to
face the United States the USA and the
US Bishop E2 Bishop E2 and Bishop to E2
uh that's actually King's Bishop to King
two and he plays Ethan similar idea
carving out the light squares yeah and
if F4 is gonna play Knight F5 check code
obstacle Bishops or is he gonna play
Knight H5 and maybe bishop G4 trading
off the light score bishops from a
different diagonal
yeah that's actually a great alternative
it didn't occur to me for whatever
reason I kind of assumed that niho was
going to keep the status quo on the king
side but look at those juicy light
squares but listen light squares don't
win games Checkmate wins games so after
Knight F5 check icard just gonna take
and say hey I've got opposite colored
Bishops I'm maybe going to put my Bishop
on F6 and I'm just gonna try to hold the
fort
yeah because you would love to get your
Bishop to D5 for white with the pawn
still in E4 but upon going to F5 you're
not going to get that if you play Knight
H5 your knight might get trapped over
there not that you're gonna lose the
piece but it's going to be out of play
and then black can just say oh I'm
essentially playing up a piece so huge
moment he plays Knight H5 but nehal
suddenly down on the clock Bishop G4 the
likely follow-up but I am worried about
his time management but a car now we
have to think thus far Hikaru has been
money in these time pressure situations
as he brings the king up to G6 inviting
Bishop G4 but that Rook B6 move Robert
which we've pointed out that could come
in very clutch at the right moment and
nihal starting to hesitate big time he
follows up with Bishop G4 and his Rook
B6 going to be the response or is he
want to play Queen B6 and force the
queen trade he plays Queen B6 he trades
those Queens off and white has got the
money choice
the knight's stranded you can play G3 to
try to extricate the knight from there
but the problem is your extra Pawn isn't
that great Subway black with B5 to B4
cement the queen side Pawns in place
with Rook A6 to follow so he does play
G3 his extra Pawn is on A2 he can play
Rook D2 to defend that pawn that's the
good news but look at the clock
situation I think that's really neho's
best chance that a car is in time
trouble strap yourselves in the hall is
a fantastic end game player this is his
wheelhouse these better end games he's
so good at squeezing them out but Rook
D3 Rook A6 rookies or Rook D3 King g54
and then you have to play Knight G7 and
extricate your knight from the the
forward position he goes Rook A6 and
this is dangerous this is a three result
game Robert it is because F2 is a target
if that Bishop can get to the A7 F2 and
G1 diagonal that's a problem because I
don't like King G2 slow move and I
thought he car had B4 and Bishop C5 but
he makes a solid move to bring his King
back Knight G7 and that's such a Hikaru
idea it's just being able to say I love
Rick Sim just bring my king back and
then B3 is under attack go Rook C3 here
you gotta bail out E4 you've got to bail
out and he does and this is gonna be a
draw is it it car's gonna play on
F4 though don't get made it if you're
Hikaru
taken E5 take any five yeah this is
definitely a draw of course don't play
around with your knee-haul he's trying
and now tikaru is gonna go King F3 and
threaten mate
but he's not gonna win no we'll just see
it drawn this way and wow what defense
by Hikaru I mean it's really
unbelievable if you look at this game
quickly you'll say ah nothing really
happened the eval bar was always
hovering around one at the maximum but
the Precision needed by hikar to bring
his King up to G6 and queen B6 people
don't trade Queens when they're down
pawns but a card Nakamura recognized
that that is his path towards equality
he makes the draw he keeps his two point
lead I totally Coast on your point and I
would even go so far as to say that this
game is in a way more frustrating than
your loss because when you lose you get
out played okay you know that's gonna
happen a couple times against dicaro
when you spend so much energy and you're
better the entire game and you find so
many good ideas and you still can't win
those are the games that really
debilitate you psychologically
for sure and we see this there's a queen
D3 Hikaru is just playing random chess
yeah total random chess well with the
white pieces with black he's actually
getting worse positions so uh this is
the last game before the Midway break
but if I'm mikaru I would really start
studying the qga position to keep
getting because nihal is obtaining
advantages but this one here looks
pretty level the one thing to note is
the double pawns for black which means
the H file is open which means black may
not Castle kingside
and this almost resembles a win our
French after Bishop B4 especially if
Hikaru plays E5 which I don't think he's
gonna play 594 does not look appetizing
with that H file uh half open as you
pointed out so maybe just e takes D5 and
Bishop D2 and perhaps you can go Queen
side
yes but ed5 ed5 is very likely uh just
play it like a French and if you played
Bishop D2 this queen E7 check always uh
just to make White's piece a little bit
less comfortable and black and also
Castle Queen side
yeah so Bishop D2 Queen E7 looks
annoying he can't quit castle kingside
that's not out of the question
especially because you could put the
pawn on H3 and it's going to be very
hard for black to squeeze his Jeep on
past G5 and black has a castle King says
well because rookie want to check would
have kept the king in the center
otherwise although bringing the king to
f8 didn't look like the end of the world
though we saw Yonder Palm she put a king
on a fate in the world championship
against Matthew Carlson that did not pay
off very much I remember that very well
but by the way Dania I'm looking at the
clock once again Neil up about a minute
hasn't turned into anything fruitful or
he hasn't been winning games but that
may come in handy as we uh you know get
into the shorter time patrols that's
exactly what I was gonna say this might
not be all that effective in the five
minute portion but niho shouldn't get
this phenomenal time management alive
when they get into the three minute
portion the Hikaru won't be able to get
away with these one minute thinks in the
opening so I'm gonna make a bold
prediction I'm going to predict that the
car is going to continue playing this
this offbeat chest with white in the
five minute portion but I have a feeling
he's going to switch to more
conventional openings uh as they get
down to the two shorter time controls
all right with you there but isn't Queen
E7 just a good move here like you can't
play rookie one so taking over the
e-file seems uh very smart for neurology
but he can't play Rook E6 so there's
Knight F4 but he plays Knight E4 instead
and all right this seems like a position
Donya very solid very stable nothing
under attack just yet but that D5 pawn
it feels a little bit tender yeah black
is a good position not as good as
commentating with Robert Hess what it's
solid it's solid but solid positions
again they don't win games and you're
absolutely right this Pawn on D5 it may
seem very well defended but the Knight
on E2 is raring to go it's gonna jump
into F4 and if you defend with Knight D7
to F6 you're also yielding the E5 Square
for the other night and we know how
quickly Hikaru can just muster up play
out of absolutely nowhere Queen A6 by
nehal I think is a direct response to
that as he opened up the B6 Square for
his Knight in exerting pressure on C4
he plays Bishop D6 just trying to
retreat that way C5 doesn't sort of trap
that Bishop in there and Bishop F4 by
hikaran I was actually looking at
positions like this and can you take on
C4 at some point for Nyala trade on F4
take on C4 he doesn't he just brings his
Knight over
yeah and we could get a trade of Bishops
in a four Knight position Bishop takes
D6 and 95 comes to mind you could also
play something like Bishop E5 so a very
kind of kg
you know clever type of maneuvering
battle in the center not entirely sure
who's got the upper hand here I think
nihal does simply because of time he's
just ahead in the clock hikar has plenty
of time remaining but I feel like a
broken record I keep saying oh I had on
the clock and it never pans out for him
so maybe this is part of a car's
strategy just spend some time in the
opening make sure nothing goes really
wrong and then when it comes down to it
he is so fast in time trouble his speed
is through the roof it really is and
this is going to be the last game before
the halftime break it's a big game a win
for anyhow would go a long way it would
shrink the lead down to only one and it
would be a major confidence boost right
because you start going 45 minutes an
hour without a win that starts affecting
you psychologically you start doubting
yourself even if you're normally a very
confident player agreed I think Bishop
A3 here is just a little bit annoying
but the Rook may just slide over to D1
and say no big deal uh but as you're
pointing out you know you wanna
just create some sort of issue in
White's position so Bishop takes F4
instead of going to A3 allows G5 G4
undoubling your pawns getting some
activity for your pieces
I like Bishop takes F4 it's a Concrete
decision
um nihal has to not miss the opportunity
when he can convert is better piece
placement into something a little bit
more specific more concrete but he goes
for your initial recommendation
what is the follow-up though if your car
just Dodges that with Rook do you want
to Rook B1
Rook B1 he's just trying to avoid D
takes C4 right Rook D1 he must have
thought DC4 was an option so he goes
Rook B1 hoping to open the B file but
now c4 is really under attack you can't
protect it if you 95 good idea uh maybe
there's some Knight I was trying to say
Knight H5 Pawn F6 but you're never going
to get away with that
okay 95 on the board let's see what
nihal has in mind I was thinking maybe
Knight D6 to F5 start with DC and put
pressure on the D4 Pawn but that's a
major concession you don't want to give
away the center unless you know for a
fact that you can go after this one and
the D4 Pawn can be easily defended with
a rook from D1 okay nehal plays the
immediate Knight F5 it's a little less
committal than starting with DC he
really needs to watch out for some
timely like C5 B4 and the bishop
construct an A3 like that's the
absolutely one thing I'm very concerned
about if I'm looking at this from
nihal's perspective and
um C5 not really the most tempting move
just because it takes away the tension
but
yeah the bishop 183 seems a little bit
out there it really does what happens if
you start with C5 is there anything
specific that black has in response
maybe just it looks real flimsy yeah I
mean the Knight E2 is also a little bit
loose in some positions so you do very
very careful uh before you make it with
like C5 it's so committal
you could start with a move like G4 but
that's pretty inhuman I mean that
creates these massive weaknesses on the
king side but Hikaru he's shown in the
previous white game that he doesn't mind
upon on G4 as early as like move four
wow I mean G4 there's even ideas with
like a knight takes D4 at some point
with DC4 but if there's Rook F1 to D1
can't blame him but the engine says no
no no black is significantly better
right now
what awareness what awareness by nihal
he senses that the time has come because
C5 actually became a serious threat he
brings his Bishop back applies more
pressure on the Knight you pointed out
Knight takes D4 and that was prophetic
because it's now a major threat and you
can't move the night back because of
Rook takes C2 and so he protects the 95
with the queen on B2 another piece
coming to the rescue but C4 is now loose
in many different positions uh Knight
jumping from F6 to E4 at any moment just
seems like a nice improving move with G5
to follow I feel like White's pieces are
scattered and look at black species is
very well connected there in the center
yeah but again we've been through this
before black is better maybe even
clearly better but where's the follow-up
your clock starts sticking down and you
don't want to give up this clock
Advantage if you're new I think if this
gets down into another time scramble
Hikaru is gonna wiggle his way out of
this once again so let's see what niho
can do in the next 40 seconds yeah he
really doesn't want to play D takes C4
because after B takes C4 the B7 Pawn is
a target so knee-hole ahead on the clock
using his time wisely here but Daniel
you know this position looks so good for
black but what's the concrete issue C5
maybe just blast the center open and say
hey I've got the better pieces he does
take on C4 wow very concrete approach
but D takes E5 he trades the Rooks and
he takes C4 oh the Knight on E2 is loose
so ef6 takes E2 but that's not the end
of the story because you could go Rook
d8 check and FG with Queen F6 coming in
and that gets really spicy wow that's
actually something easy over with this
rookie one checking Queen takes F4 check
positions you got to be great
calculation and I think Hikaru is doing
just that he's trying to figure out he
takes F6 he's down to 38 seconds and
he's played it and I hope he doesn't
blunder that rookie one check because
it's so easy to miss but maybe he still
can play that because like G3 tactics as
well I mean this is an unbelievable
position rookie too oh there is an fg7
oh my gosh and the reason I I pull up an
analysis board but I I'm pretty sure
that this is gonna happen you all can
also play Queen takes E2 which is a more
conservative approach but the end game
Robert I'm not sure it offers a lot of
winning chances white could throw in a
check on d8 and then drop back to D7 and
start picking up the pawns on the
seventh rank like a vacuum cleaner yeah
that looks like it just would make a
draw here so rookie two is the more
courageous choice but it could backfire
completely with f takes G7 Queen F6
ideas as you mentioned so I think nihal
is going to spend a lot of time here uh
he's probably a little bit nervous he
does not want to drop a third game
against Hikaru so if that's the case he
will just like Queen takes E2 and we'll
see this fizzle out gotta go Gotta Go
Gotta Go and we see according to the
eval bar he's lost his Advantage F takes
G7 and queen F6 is absolutely terrifying
and this is the narrative repeating
itself Robert he's down to 26 seconds
here we go Rook dnfg played instantly
and queen coming to F6 okay so the
threat is Queen H4 check there is Knight
H5 to pair that off as a queen E6
offering the queen trade makes a lot of
sense it does yeah he makes a mistake
Queen
H4 Knight H5 rookie
Queen H4 and rook h8 and Bishop E5
picked up the black queen you are a
Madman that was an insane tag we'll show
that after the game for sure when Knight
comes out to F5 and that Queen on G5 is
actually dominated by the Knight and F5
and black could play F6 but it doesn't
trap the queen it has the G4 Square it's
anybody's game I'm getting so concerned
for anyhow's clock though he's got so
many squares to keep track of yeah F6
Rook t7 check looks like a problem oh
that's a mate oh four seconds three
seconds
Queen E4 okay that's a good move yes
he's lining up F6 actually because after
rookie seven there's rookie E7 the block
and the queen protects it
and now the ball is in Hikaru scored he
could play Rook D7
he does Rookie E7 oh this trade would
not favor a car so we see a little
repetition and we will might get a six
position here F6 oh that's such a Godsey
move he plays Queen E6 oh my gosh
Queenie six Tower
can you play F6 he does
and A6 up a Pawn Yeah that's what it's
easy to forget about nihal is up upon
here he just blundered it back though he
just gave away the pun that was not
intentional that was a blunder and
what's the queen doing on D5 wow oh
Knight drops back to prevent H5 it's
anybody's game we're in a Time scramble
hey Cara's just trying to make sure he
doesn't lose this game and the pawn
structure is Valley my knight F5 coming
in Knight E3 rookie three
he wants to make a draw down upon and
that's what she did against Fabi
but chances for nehal Robert past seep
on this is so hard to defend with two
seconds wow he just dragged the pawn to
an undefended Rook takes F4 is Rook
takes C5 he's done it again and it's not
even close like nihal it's not like he
had a win and then it was a draw again I
think Hikaru is just defending this
comfortably although at some point
yeah I was gonna say he can release the
pawn okay four okay four
very classy very very classy by icaro
and still in the hall is strong he gets
his King to B5 but the Rook can keep in
contact with the pawn as long as the sky
Rises the sun rises in the morning
wow Hikaru Nakamura you know even when
it seems like he might be in a little
bit of trouble finds the precise way to
make a drone I think we should go back
to that woman uh where you found a way
for white to win the queen that was a
stellar tactic hard to see with no time
on the clock especially because the
black queen is on the other side of the
board it seems to have nothing to do
with the action but Quinn H4 check lines
up a discovery what you need to do is
get the King on a dark Square so that
the bishop can move away you can play
Bishop B5 immediately but it doesn't
work because of Queen C1 check but what
you do is you throw in Rook h8 a
deflection Bishop E5 check a discovery
and you pick up the queen on C4 with
excellent winning chances for Whitey
Caro would have won this game if he had
seen this combination but he is more
than happy to come away with half a
point Robert no question about it Loose
pieces drop off but of course form does
not drop off he maintains a two-point
lead over nihal sarn as they get a
little bit of break to stretch their
legs look up their openings and for Neil
try to combat A3 and H3 but for now
we're going to join them we're back in
just a few minutes for more from the
speeches championship match between a
car Nakamura and nihal sarin
[Music]
International Master Danny wrench back
again Chief chess officer bringing you
chess terminology let's Dive Right into
one of one of everybody's favorite
tactics if I might be so bold because
it's surprising it's something that
never never fails to deliver shock value
and excitement whether you're watching a
broadcast or just reviewing some famous
chess games and that is the process of
an under promotion when you move upon to
the other side of the board almost
always you're looking to get a queen but
the rare times where it's better to get
something else or perhaps even required
in order to maybe not stalemate your
opponent or keep your winning chances
alive are some of the most fascinating
exciting moments in chess so with that
let's dive into what under promotion is
and show you some of my favorite
examples under promotion as we said is
the process of promoting a pawn but not
to the most obvious or most powerful
type of piece which is usually the queen
in this famous example between Nakamura
and Vladimir kramnik the fact that
Hikaru was winning is only because he
under promotes on C8 to a knight that
move comes with check on the black king
so that on the next turn white can
capture the E2 pawn it should be noted
that if Hikaru had queened
black would actually go on to win
because now black queens with check and
ultimately kromnik would have been able
to not just save but actually win this
game another promotion tactic provided
to me by our own Sam Copeland vice
president of content one of his favorite
examples is the move D7 and after Bishop
to E8 the only way to win the game is to
underpromote to a bishop under voting to
a bishop doesn't happen that often in
this particular study it was designed to
be so the point is that if the bishop
moves over to H5 we check and mate along
the A4 EA diagonal and if the bishop
moves anywhere else white actually plays
a subtle move Bishop of seven first and
there is no way to prevent Checkmate on
the next move shout out to everybody
watching this video thank you for tuning
in and enjoying our breakdown of under
promotion and we'll see you on chess.com
[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
and we return here in the matchup
between Hikaru Nakamura the one seed and
nihal sarin the five seed in the speed
Chess Championship nihal sarin made the
semi-finals last year he's made the
semifinals this year as well Dania he is
seeming to be an Unstoppable Force until
he has Medicare Nakamura well everyone
seems to be an Unstoppable Force until
they meet the ultimate immovable object
ikaro is so solid
he's so resilient and as we look at
nihal sarin's play player card that's
what great players do they make it look
easy and as Fabi can tell you they make
Legends look like amateurs they do
indeed and or a nihal sarum he has this
pragmatic style in fact I use that word
a couple times earlier without even
seeing this graphic his lifetime score
in the SEC is four wins and two losses
uh last name is the semis this year as
well so that's a very impressive
performance for somebody so young he
took down dingley Ren and Anish giri in
this year and he would like to add
Hikaru Nakamura to that list and nihal
has just such a mature style he's got so
many different aspects to his game he's
an incredible tactician and yet he has a
very positional style particularly with
the white pieces so nihals got the
ingredients that he needs to beat
someone amazing it's just that he's
gotten the positions he's wanted Robert
let's take out the silver lining for
knee-hole he's been better with white
consistently he just has failed to
deliver on his opportunities okay here's
the critical moment Knight Ford F3 is
played in one game bishopy two in
another uh but for Hikaru The Bishop's
on E7 rather than on D6 so that's
another difference Knight C4 doesn't
come with the tempo he plays it anyway
uh that does allow blacks to play
through B5 or what Niha will do is swap
on C6 bring a knight to E5 instead and
just claim that he is the superior minor
pieces in this position
by the way just to clarify I didn't mean
to call Fabiano caruana an amateur he's
an absolute Legend I have the utmost
respect for him but uh you know it's
just it's just what people like Hikaru
and Magnus are are able to achieve it's
that crazy effect when someone who
normally victimizes other players just
ends up being the one who's victimized
and Hikaru do you think he looked this
up or do you think he's just kind of
being stubborn well he I thought he
might have looked it up because he went
Bishop E7 but now he's sitting here and
thinking and what can happen at times is
we see the evaluation went from a slight
Plus for white to zeros this could be
like the third or the fourth best move
and when you don't have that much time
to look at an opening when someone plays
the third move you probably haven't
looked at it it's too far down in the
computer's ranking perfectly good move
but the cars seems stuck
he does and the Knights are definitely
unstuck they're all over the center
Knight F6 to D5 which is a very natural
move Hikaru preparing to play Bishop F6
and ultimately neutralize the bishop on
B2 which is the real path to equality
here but nihal preparing to annihilate
this Knight take it off the board and
get a dream iqp structure look at the
bishop on D7 compared to the bishop on
F3 earlier uh in this match you
mentioned the dark squared Bishops it's
also the Light Square Bishops that's
what makes this opening have much more
teeth than one would initially think
Bishop C6 trying to counter the bishop
on F3 is met with Knight to E5 which is
attacking that Bishop in its play so I
feel like uh Niels everything he could
possibly dream of out of the opening now
that the advantage is that significant
it just is much more pleasant to play I
think it's been 0.4 specifically 0.4 out
of every opening it's like such a
frustrating eval like it's not 0.6 it's
not plus one it's 0.4 the little bit
better position but how do you actually
improve and I think that Hikaru is
perfectly okay being in this situation
game after game because his defense is
among the best there was recent this
video that he did with chess.com where
they asked him to rank himself out of a
hundred and he said his defense is 99.
and I think he's even selling himself a
little short there his modest is as
great as great gets he is like probably
the best defender in the entire world
and he just does not go down without
swinging maybe he should start chest
boxing yeah I mean stop underselling
yourself ikaro come on
he's like that yeah he's like that kid
who says I did terribly on on my test I
got a question around what'd you get 98
99 yeah right everybody hated that kid
and everybody hates playing Hikaru
because he just is that good
and what's funny is I actually failed a
test in fifth grade where we had we had
a blank map of the United States and we
had to label all the states because I
was at a chess tournament and I wasn't
studying and once I took the test I
immediately knew that I failed and of
course that's precisely when I was
talking to my friend who was complaining
and he says I feel you Daniel I forgot
where North Dakota was but I knew where
all the other states were that did not
make me any happier
oh good old North Dakota well right here
the Rook on C8 coming towards the center
just like North Dakota in the country
come to the center of the chess board
here oh you managed to connect
everything to the chest that is like the
ultimate Talent well you know you and I
have a commentary connection so
sometimes we gotta talk about other
things other times we got to focus in
the chest but here Queen to D2
connecting the Rooks from F1 to C1 and
this position is just gonna remain in
this like slightly better for what
slightly better for black a totally
equal territory and it's coming up with
a plan because right now we have only
two pawns and one pair of knights traded
what is the actual plan for each side
your point at Queen B2 that looks good
for white what is black have in store
yeah well at first you might think you
want you want to banish the night to
North Dakota after B5 the problem is
Knight's gonna go to Manhattan with
Knight C4 to E5 chasing away the bishop
you might have went earlier B5 is on the
board wow and the email bar is skeptical
there's also the move Knight to B6 here
trying to secure the bishop pair but
there after Knight takes B6 Bishop C6
you have to be very careful about E5
that Queen is going to be undefended
once the Knight moves away from C4 so
I'm sticking by 95 ikara will drop his
Bishop back to B7 and he'll politely ask
white again the topical question how are
you going to improve
I don't have to answer that question but
I am working on myself and my
understanding of the game of chess but
Knight E5 it just looks great eventually
can be kicked out with F6 so I won't
stay there forever even if it has Prime
real estate in the center of the board
so maybe 95 Bishop B7 and Rook takes C8
and Rook C1 quickly take over the C file
and you're exactly what you're pointing
out you try to take control of the C6
Square climb that Empire State Building
Knight on E5 Rook takes C8 I think is a
must if you don't play it that ship will
sail very quickly and you pointed out
the move F6 the moment White's Knight is
driven out of E5 whites grasp on the
position really loosens alternatively
though you could play Knight T3 on your
own volition and kind of Catalan style
try to take over that square on C5 so
possibilities here for knee-haul I think
Rook takes CNN Rook C1 is too juicy to
refuse though Knight D3 feels like the
ultimate Peter lekko move oh I like get
the smallest Advantage but take control
of important squares if we bring up an
analysis board here really fast I think
what might be giving nihal the
heebie-jeebies here is that after Rook
C1 Queen d8 Knight C6 looks like
everything's going according to plan but
if I have this calculated correctly
night before it's actually a super nasty
move our old friend E5 pays us a visit
the bishop can drop back to C3 but at
the end you actually lose that A2 pawn
and I think you lose your advantage in
the end game and so nihal after a period
of long thought goes Peter leko mode and
plays Knight T3 back to the lifeboard
yeah great move Knight to D3 it's saying
you know I could try to get the bishop
pair but maybe I'll do it in Better Way
Knight to C5 that's a juicy square and
that's what happens when you extend
pawns too much A6 and B5 what squares
that came up C6 we've been mentioning
also C5 there's a bishop on D4 Rook on
C1 give me that square I'm taking
control of B4 as well I love that move
from nihal and I feel like that's going
to create some issues for Hikaru and
it's important to beat Black to the
punch because if you had waited for F6
vanicar would have been able to follow
up with E5 and again your grasp on the
C5 Square would have been loosened if
the bishop would have been forced to
drop back to A1 let alone all of the
tactics you would have opened yourself
up to on the D file if Hikaru plays F6
here you drop your knight into C5
simultaneously hitting the bishop on the
pawn and then you Force black to give
away the dark scored Bishop that's the
nightmare scenario for black yeah F6
would be a terrible blunder at this
moment so Hikari needs to find another
move Bishop F6 or something like that
still gives up the C5 Square Bishop A3
can often be met by Bishop to B2 let's
trade those dark Square Bishops because
C5 is mine uh so it's a moment for a car
to recognize that C5 square is firmly
under his opponent's control and it's
not going to be easy to deal with not at
all I don't think you can deal with
Knight C5 itself maybe you can try to
take the sting out of it then drop the
bishop back to A8 but that is not an
easy move to play
we're back to point four on the EVO bar
and it's crept up and wait doesn't neoho
want to go Knight C5 is H3 really that
mission critical Robert I don't think it
was critical but he's saying Hikaru show
me your next move right H6 took him
forever to play rookie right there's
gonna be some kind of quiet follow-up
that's gonna take a car with 20 seconds
to play he plays Bishop right now Bishop
B2 let's trade the dark Square Bishops
the whole point is the C5 Square wants
to be under White's control you can play
B4 at some point in the future give me
the C5 Square I want it and I want it
now but I'm gonna backseat drive a
little bit here I really think H3 was a
lazy move by knee-haw I think he went
into that mode of trying to milk
hikaru's clock down and that doesn't
usually work against him I feel like
right about now he's regretting not
playing Knight T5 but he might make me
eat my words because that Bishop on A3
has seen better days oh my gosh actually
you can put a bishop on C5 and say your
Bishop's not getting out of there and
even if you don't win the piece you're
just gonna play around it and so what
can black do I think E8 makes sense just
trying to put a piece on the D5 but as
you're pointing out Rook B1 to B3 looks
very tempting uh oh and Rook B1 now is
even more tempting because it
simultaneously defends before you have
to I think resist the temptation to play
Bishop C5 because that invites the move
Rook D although 95 in that position
comes within a millimeter of trapping
the queen I think it's only because
black has the H War square that he stays
alive and something very important to
note is a knight on D5 is pinned so if
this Knight remains stuck in place you
can't actually take on B4 so the pawn B4
is not really threatened in many of
these positions and Rook B1 takes care
of it all at once the move Rook B1 Rook
B3 looks very natural and very strong he
has to see Rook B1 and he had to see it
yesterday because he's down to 40
seconds and again this is entering the
realm of a Time scramble Rook B1 is
natural it's strong and it puts Hikaru
in Dire Straits and you might play A5 to
free the bishop but then you hand white
and pass Pawn all right he plays Rook B1
he took quite a long think they're
almost minute Rook state by akaru Rook
B3 give me that Bishop is Bishop C1
available right now not only available I
think it's forced and is Newhall gonna
take and go into the end game no he's
gonna keep that Bishop stranded on C1
and I feel like Hikaru he has to use
some sort of weird tactics to extricate
that Bishop he tries to use the queen
trade to diminish the pressure on the
bishop I think you don't want that Rook
entering on C2 at least that's how it
looks to me so Bishop C5 remember the
bishop F3 defends the queen on D1 so at
least here he goes Knight C5 going for
the bishop on B7 makes perfect sense the
bishop on C1 still kind of Trapped in
there so King F1 King E2 is a bit of a
long story but Maeve the king can enter
the position it could trap the bishop on
C1 God Hikaru is balancing on the
trapeze here somehow the bishop is not
only alive but could even inflict some
damage on White's pawns with a
well-timed positions
spot and black will have to go Bishop D5
he missed it he missed it oh my gosh he
plays Bishop 3 still looking pretty
decent he's missing tactics you cannot
miss a one move tactic against Hikaru
and hope to win this match I think
Hikaru is back in the game and he's got
an initiative now and this is a once
again three years old game everything
possibly nice loose ba5 the Knight C5 is
loose A4
that's a bailout move that's a total
bailout move he car can trade both of
these pawns and make a draw but the E5
Pawn also is a bit loose so black needs
to keep an eye on that Bishop let's see
what's still awkward it does finally get
out and don't play Bishop my face [ __ ]
before oh oh oh and now watch for Knight
D6 White's minor pieces Robert are very
awkward on the queen side you could lose
a piece here in the blink of an eye
thankfully the A5 score is covered by A3
a car trying to win this game yep and
the Hall holding on for dear life at
this point bringing all of his pieces
back yeah Rook a one oh and then King
has to drop back to E2 barely hanging on
but I think he's gonna hold it E4 check
was possible there
and look at me I'll go he's out of it
the worst is behind him yeah and there
we go it's a draw
and Hikaru down a few seconds himself
maybe he doesn't he doesn't E5 Almost
kg4 Here Comes The King and King G6
blunders the pawn 95. oh my gosh he
barely got the move off hit point eight
seconds when he made the move Bishop G3
keep more peace there's a pass Pawn for
white E4 and you push it E4 try to get
it to
e53 he wants Rook D5 D5 D5
and the bishop end game was winning now
the pawn moves forward to E5 really
scared for Rook B7 Rook Beast oh he
blunder The Rock oh my gosh he blunders
The Rook on E1 it resigns and nihal
sarin is right back in this match Hikaru
Network cannot believe it
what a ridiculous win in that 4v4 end
game that was As Dead As It Gets and
neho just said eight four G4 G5 I'm
breaking up the pawn structure I'm
promoting my e-pawn and I'm winning this
game and I feel like Hikaru could have
did it to himself right he was playing
for a win in a mutual time scramble and
if he had just accepted a draw it would
have been a split point but instead he
plays on and nihal's active King and
that timely G5 push earned him his first
victory of the match and now we can say
it is on it's a one point match right
now ikaru gets the white pieces and
plays a central pawn move on the first
turn yeah Hikaru says no more games I'm
getting serious and we ball knee-hole
that win came at precisely the right
moment insane he misses Knight D3 that
would have picked up a minor piece right
off the bat he keeps his composure
navigates talk about the trapeze artist
I mean he could have lost a minor piece
there was just seconds left on the clock
and somehow outplays Hikaru from a dead
drawn and game but the key question
Robert can he capitalize on this
momentum this game might be even more
important than the last yeah he cannot
afford to lose this one because then you
give a car that renewed sense of
confidence you know you saw him at the
end of the game he couldn't believe it
he's like what just happened how could I
possibly lose that position in a
classical game that would never happen
and here with the black pieces all seems
okay for Neil he could take on e4 he can
get his King safely castled at some
point in the near future but there are
some tactics to work out you always to
look at the H7 Pawn things of that
nature but you know thinking and doing
the right thing and hikara might also be
saying hey I'm the one who's supposed to
do that I'm the one who wins these dead
equal end games on the regular so for
someone to do it against him is
particularly impressive as gleefully
orange says aptly in the chat nihal
proving that he can out magic Hikaru and
he will need a lot more where that came
from if he wants to stay competitive in
this match now what do we make of this
position it's an iqp structure wax play
is very natural here but white has a bit
of an initiative slightly more active
minor pieces and for neon you can play
Knight F6 but you're walking to a pin
and there's some sort of Knight E5 in
the future he puts Queen C7 sidestepping
everything and then he can play H6
himself we can bring a rook a to E8 but
the C6 Pawn that's the tender point in
the position Donya and black can try to
play C5 at some moment but as you point
out D5 is available there's also some
problems potentially on the D file
itself and so well for now you know
refraining from pushing the pawn and
there is even Bishop takes C6 and then
D5 kind of a weird looking tactic and if
we pull up an analysis board here after
Bishop C6 Bishop c65 the weird problem
for black is that if he puts a piece in
between the rook and the queen that
piece is then going to stand between the
rook and the Queen and it's going to be
picked up by another Pawn so I'm
actually struggling to figure out a
defensive move in this position for
black I think 95. D takes C6 and then
what A5 to prevent B4 yes
wow that's actually that's a tough move
to find very very deep and not easy at
all especially because it looks at the
pawn C6 will stay there but as you point
out H2 a bit loose for the time being
that is yeah this this WOW tempo for
Tempo by the way look what's happening
on the board right now
could it be Bishop takes C6 and D5 it is
indeed that sequence and I feel like
nihal kind of overlooked it you see him
grabbing his head he's calculating
um but this is not something that you
want to have because now there's like
only one way out you have to find Knight
C5 followed by A5 I think he's capable
of doing that uh are there any other
moves is there like a knight E5 here
potentially just trying to trade the
Knight on F3 and take on H2 uh that
might not well without the way you want
it there is the crazy Knight D7 2b8 but
the intention is simple just DC Knight
takes C6 but what's scary about that
move is that in the resulting position
your knight on C6 looks so tender and it
can be attacked in a variety of ways
Queen A4 Queen D5 Knight D4 I feel like
that is a lot scarier than Knight C5 so
the hard part about Knight C5 is the
move A5 I think if we bring up an
analysis board really quickly there's a
funny line with Knight to B8 so Knight
B8 takes takes uh Knight D4 there's like
Rook E4 stuff about to happen like
Bishop H2 check and rookie four oh and
so oh
take on C6 with your Rook I take on H4
and we just make a draw unbelievable and
you don't even have to recapture The
Rook you can just play in your face move
like Bishop G3 go back and you can go
wherever you want on the diagonal It All
Leads to Rome yes it does and so that
would be a draw and he plays Knight to
B8 whoa
back to the live board Knight B8 on the
board and Hikaru doesn't have to rush
with d takes C6 that's an important
thing to point out I feel like a Hikaru
move here would be like H3
that would be such a hit card move but
you have to watch out because you might
fall victim to a G5 Rook d8 if you're
not careful
great minds complete each other's
sandwiches
that would actually be really really
nasty I mean that's something that's so
easy to overlook because it seems like
the pin is kind of Eternal until the
queen moves but that Rook can slide in
d8 you're creating a counter sort of pin
Discovery attack against the queen on D1
I agree eating the same sandwich would
be nasty
yeah I mean I would share with you we
could cut it in half we get like a
grilled cheese slice it and then share
it how's that sound I don't like grilled
cheese but generally sounds good I don't
like grilled cheese I'm not a cheese
person you knew that I just like
parmesan everybody likes grilled cheese
not neriditsky I mean do you like pizzas
I do like pizza I like cheese on pizza
so I like it in principle I just don't
like it on a sandwich your opinion is
this
that was smooth I'll give you that
touche
thank you drink appreciate that thank
you I did enjoy that but right now it
card Nakamura trying to enjoy this pin
he seems to be struggling trying to find
a next move I can't move the knight in
F3 the H2 Pawn is loose Rook E4 is
always an idea for black and what a fine
by Neil
19. come on you know what he's really
good at that is a struggle for all chess
players from beginner to Super
Grandmaster is retreating moves he finds
these backward moves like no other and
Knight V8 undeveloping just to protect
the bishop is a really classy move by
Neil sarin yeah and thank you bjh at
least someone's on my team but Hikaru
he's trying to squeeze the juice out of
the position he's saying listen I don't
have to take the bishop immediately but
I can't really intensify the pressure on
the bishop either so he bites the bullet
he takes on C6 Queen A4 hits the Knight
and it can be defended with a rook a to
C8 you could also Play Bishop C5 but
that would have fallen victim to B4
exactly so he's avoiding that B4 tactic
Knight D4 still does not work H2 is
hanging rookie 4 is even more
devastating with that Queen on A4 over
there so
yeah card might not have anything the
worst might be behind you all and not
only that it's just there isn't even a
clear way to create threats if you're
Hikaru he does create a threat but it's
a pretty prosaic thread and the Queen's
gonna move out of the way what about
rookie four as well oh
that is a Fearless move right there and
we might start talking about a
revolution here with a black being the
one up on top yeah because that actually
threatens both the B4 pawn and Bishop
takes H2 check distracting the knight
from F3
but my worry would be after rookie four
let's say I play A3 you win that pawn
and then I guess you could just stay on
the fourth right to prevent B5 it's a
little bit flimsy though I'm with you
that Dashi does not look like an ideal
uh configuration of pieces so Queen B7
then that might just be the easiest move
let's get out of Dodge let's just make
sure that we maintain the quality
because what is white really playing for
in this position
yeah that's a good point I like Queen B7
I think given the match situation if
knee-hole can even draw this game
that'll be a major confidence boost just
sort of cement the fact that you're back
in the match don't give Hikaru the
immediate comeback win if we were
talking about the bullet segment and he
always down three points he would have
played a rookie four in the blink of an
eye but he's definitely not playing in
the blink of an eye he's taking a while
here deciding between what I'm sure are
these two candidate moves
that's right so nihal uh right now
trying to figure this out I mean I just
looked at their ratings for the first
time a car with 31.93 you know 31.66
these two behemoths of bullet and Blitz
chess I mean I'm just so stoked for the
rest of this match but I think nihal
right now he is struggling to find the
accurate continuation he's like do I
play rookie for and get adventurous do I
play the calm Queen B7 I know I'm doing
fine there but he's spending too much
time and that's my main concern for him
a car has been good in many of the time
scrambles not counting the previous game
and Hikaru probably the best player in
the world in the opponent's time
pressure knee-hal we know is capable of
magic with literally no time left on his
clock but you just don't want to get
into these situations against icaro in
principle because you might save one
game but if you keep doing it he car is
going to keep creating chances and keep
harassing you in rookie four and Bishop
H2 is on the board this is what we were
talking about and I guess nihal has
decided that Hikaru has no way to push
through the b-pawn which is also Knight
D4 at 7.3 92 mate when The Rook was oh
my God can we bring up an analysis board
for that we should absolutely bring up
an analysis board so are you saying Rook
H5 here maybe Knight D4 right away is
that no oh my lands yeah
What A Catch by you and Rook takes C7 92
is Anastasia's mate but the main thing
that's impressive about this line is
that here you have a fork you pick up
the rook and white has no compensation
for the pawn and lastly Robert Knight
takes D4 there's another combination one
Queen H2 was made in one just oh oh yeah
bust my bubble there Robert Queen takes
you one is the best move I don't care
well it looks like that didn't happen
Rook season
huge I'm stuck in trouble what is he
doing he's gonna find make a move video
because this is so complicated Rook fc1
is on Deck you might want he might want
some kind of Rook G2 tactics there's a
pin on that pawn so at some point there
could be something there so actually
Rook fc1 maybe he goes 97 he allows a
fork on E8 and goes Queen takes F3 but
that was way too complicated in time
pressure he knocks the queen out of A4
but in it comes to C2 I wonder if black
will play Rook C7 at some point so it's
not captured with check and then a
knight D4 sort of tactic and if Queen D1
here there's Rook d8 sliding out of the
pin but there's Queen C2 attacking the
Knight immediately you have to address
that and if you play Rook G6 you have to
reckon with Knight
e52 could come in wow oh my goodness
this is so complicated and right now
Hikaru he has plenty of time nihal does
not this is about to be a Scramble for
him he's up a pawn but that's not as
important as the pin along the C file
and hikar trying to figure out a way to
create maximum complications the queen
does drop back to C2 and nehal bails out
with great okay
great practical decision yes let's trade
off pieces that way you don't be as
concerned but even the night end game is
not easy yeah oh he might have okay he
allowed Hikaru to get better positioning
with his minor pieces and he's got six
seconds left queen d7's a great move
keeping everything together no Queenie a
checks
okay but still Hikaru has some chances
he's got the pawn majority and the
easier way to create a passer wait you
can't protect A7 oh my God you're gonna
he's gonna lose Queen F5 you got Queen
H5 check to D1 but the kinky brought the
G3 F3 and so on it can and it will and
there's never Perpetual check in these
kinds of cases but Hikaru doesn't Rush
with Queen takes A7 because you still
can't defend the pawn
oh my gosh Queenie Queen E4 Queenie
Queen E4 oh it's crazy
now's wrong chances again oh my God
yes look at him he is absolutely I was
gonna say a bad word he is displeased
with himself right now
because now if Queen eight there's King
G7 and you cannot force the Queens off
the board and Neo Hall has the ideal
defensive setup white cannot reposition
his Queen easily but Hikaru is going to
keep trying these end games are so hard
to hold in the long run
oh okay can get continue slithering up
if it wants oh but you could get mated
there easily he goes back he's like okay
I know it I'm not gonna take any risk
knee-haul just kind of treading water
here King up to G7 don't forget about
the possibility of a queen trade with
check if your knee-haul
yes if that oh why is it Eve about going
up a little bit Queen E5 to F5 something
like that well Queen G1 Queen H1 is a is
a Perpetual construction yeah you don't
have
can't just move your queen up can you
eat three dangerous King to a better
spot I think he's gonna win this game
somehow oh but after he just fell which
means way more checks available to the
black queen
true but the king is going to make a Mad
Dash for black side of the board and try
to hide around the pawn it's not Pawn
quantity it's Pawn quality the B6 plug
yeah is a passer
you can't drink Queen I've seen so many
of these end games and they're just
virtually impossible to hold with no
time on your clock eventually you're
gonna let the king slip out of your
grasp Queen do oh and there it is
winning on the spot
trying to get a sun dial but you don't
have it Queen c64 beneath the pawn
Queen E3 or queen C5 oh
this is so difficult for both players
how is Neil holding this together he's
using the PIN to prevent promotion right
and you can't offer
queen d8 queen C8 it's losing it's
losing Queen C7 he goes back here King
G6
it's still a draw Queen C4 Hikaru
getting more and more frustrated
Sundial Queen F7 is King running to f8
oh my God oh my God
th8
he whips the game F5 b a queen there's
no checks there's not a single check
the least likely Square on the
chessboard and that's where he went oh
my gosh and now he doesn't even need to
trade Queens he could have but he's
gonna win these pawns and oh wait but
there's still a bunch of checks here oh
my gosh it's still not over
no this is yeah he's got everything he
wants he's connected G5 hangs oh what
defense of Brazilians by nehal but it's
not quite enough and Hikaru steals it in
exactly a hundred moves that was
unbelievable the king ran to the enemy
territory all the way from A8 to h8 it
scurries across the board wins a car the
game and as I said he was displeased and
because he missed an earlier Queen trade
that would have won him the game without
so much complication
and it's crazy that all of that could be
avoided but what's going to get lost in
all of that brouhaha Robert is the fact
that Hikaru even created these chances
in the first place because once they got
into the queen of night versus queen of
night end game I was convinced that it
was a dead draw I mean it looked as
lifeless as I don't know name something
that's lifeless but um Charlotte past 9
pm
but in any case Hikaru creating chance
is just a vintage Nakamura Victory even
if it's sloppier than he would like how
are we still in the longest time Patrol
right we still have so much chess to go
both these players giving their entire
sense of self their entire effort and
right now is a two-point match a car
Nakamura leads but he needs to remain
composed and you know right now it's
even there's no problem in his position
but you can just see that something
about that last game bothered him a lot
and look at this now it's an advantage
for white it just looks like a pleasant
position for Neal it most certainly does
this is the final game of the five
minute portion and if he can win and
renew that momentum that he builds up
with such hard work with his only
victory of the match it would go a very
long way niho listen he's gotten exactly
what he wants he's gotten all he can eat
with the white pieces
was there in force was there Bishop C7
instead of Knight takes B6 there oh
probably no but I'm just it looks cool
that was a sick move with Queen takes B7
trying to Fork back the minor pieces
yeah I don't know if it worked but I was
just trying to come up with it whoa what
is this a middle chest by Nakamura look
at his center it's under Fire
he is leaving that Bishop on G3 in the
dust that Bishop is blunted by the pawn
on E5 but some point white might play D4
and spring that Bishop back to life and
at some point might be now it might be a
little bit later the Hall likes to play
H3 in these types of positions
let's see what he comes up with maybe
Rook C5 now yeah very good move let's
get that Bishop in open space and E4
doesn't look right e takes D4 Knight
takes D4 the problem is the C file will
open up that is very bad news for Hikaru
it most certainly is and maybe you can
try to stick a knight on C4 but that is
not a stable Knight because the pawn
from B2 can move up to B3 once the queen
leaves the B3 Square white undoubtedly
better here and nihal this is crucial
for him to capitalize on and once again
he is up nearly a minute on the clock it
hasn't really been
put into anything right he hasn't put it
to good use it feels like but it is
something to note especially in a
position like this and now Knight D4 the
trade has happened it may look like not
too much has changed but the open C file
is now white for the taking and that C
file has a lot of juice to be squeezed
from it The Rook if it lands on C7
introduces just complete Discord in
Black's position A4 by knee-hole what a
mature move what he wants is to move the
queen of away and play B3 so that the a
pawn isn't hanging this is a common
technique Robert when you're trying to
get a knight off of F5 you play H5 and
then G6 he's doing it on the other side
of the board he did that earlier in the
match in fact and right now he can bring
the queen up to B5 to attack the tender
Pawn on D5 and try to go B3 but watch
out for Knight Force if your Queen's on
B5 then there's Knight A3 Fork so you
need to put your queen on the right
Square it could be A2 I know we don't
like gun passive but the key is to kick
that Knight out of C4 that's gonna
happen sooner rather than later but you
made a great point on the last game knee
Hall doesn't mind making retreating
moves he played Knight B8 I I think he
won't hesitate to play a move like Queen
A2 if the position demands it and the
position might be demanding it I think
we're demanding it but Queen to C3 is
also available but then there's Knight
D6 to E4 things of that nature so I like
Queen A2 because it doesn't allow Knight
D6 so the queen takes D5 would happen
with check give me that Free Pawn so
gift me the pawn as somebody might say
Knight D6 you could play Queen
you could drop the queen to A3 and this
reminds me of the time that Robert
Huebner was playing a tournament in uh
in uh the last Boys open in 1984. E3
Knight A5 Bishop C7 this is a big
problem now you can even trade on D6 at
some point Rook C7 first if Rook D4 take
on D6 take on B7 double your Rooks on
the seventh rank threaten Checkmate on
the last rank as well this is really bad
for a car I'm surprised it's only 0.7
right now it's been a pretty one-sided
game I'm as shocked as you are that end
game looks totally lost because Rook C8
is a main threat Hikaru trying to
MacGyver something here with his Knight
but you can play multiply Bishop C7 for
example and then just take on A7 oh you
can play rugby C1 to C7 doesn't look so
bad either
yeah but Bishop C7 Rook C8 pins the
bishop and then Rook takes A7 I'm gonna
try to go Rook B4 and quickly Knight D4
he takes immediately well nope
and plays Rook B4 and he's gotta pass
deep on let's not forget about that but
Rook C3 D4 Rook D3 can you just sit and
blockade the pawn
you can and I think he will because Rook
C7 the effectiveness of that is greatly
diminished this Knight Robert is a
massive defensive piece it is for sure
so Rook C3 Knight D4 is a potential
follow but then Rook C3 to C7 and G7 is
loose and that's a big problem there's
another weird idea which is just to push
the a pawn and then put the other Rook
behind it and basically guide it from
two different directions got one guy
below you got one guy above and that
pawn cannot really be stopped of course
black will push his d-pawn but the
bishop can stop it from F4 complicated
idea nihal goes simple with Rook C3 and
I think it's a good pragmatic Choice
remember when he pulled up the Neil
sound card his biggest strength is that
he is pragmatic he just says I'm gonna
blockade the d-pawn while protecting the
b-pawn and what's the problem with A5 is
H4 really that threatening the bishop
can always slide up to C7 and the King
will still have left on H2 I don't see
an alternative I think you gotta push
him baby here if you're knee-hole A5
there is this weird move Knight D4
threatening two forks at once so I'm
maybe that's what's giving him pause but
rook cc7 in that position would have
escaped both of them at the same time
instead he starts with Rook D3 Paving
the way Robert for Bishop C7 like right
now
57 and Bishop to A5 potentially oh
forcing The Rook trainer Rook takes B3
with his rookie check so like you have
oh look at shoes yeah you know that was
my tactical Wheaties this morning with
Bishops this is what I love about nihal
he plays Rook D3 instead of a more
forcing move like pushing her past Pawn
or Bishop C7 he's as you're high link
Bishop D2 B4 even G4 to kick the Knight
away from both the defensive D4 and the
G7 Pawn I love the way he's playing this
game and I think that he's completely
winning right now he's totally winning
Bishop D2 before and what's so
debilitating if you're Hikaru is how
easy it is to play with white in the
next couple of moves the path is so
clear so will Nakamura find some way to
complicate the game use this d-pawn I
don't see it Bishop D2 coming to a
theater near you weird question but with
20 seconds left a car is losing this
game do you want another five plus one
game if you're Hikaru
I don't think so I don't think this is
lost enough to Warrant resignation
and I feel like a car is so confident in
his quicker time patrols like he's won
how many title twosies at this point
that it's not worth you know giving up
chances in this game but I was just
thinking about that as the match clock
there it is it hits zero that's the last
game of five minute plus one second
increment chess and right now nehal
better win this game if he wants to
maintain chances in this match question
baby Rock'em Cowboy B4 is coming but
nehal hesitating here I think he's also
weighing the option of trying to go
after the D4 Pawn I don't think he
should get waylaid by this pun because
the Rook on D3 is doing a perfect job of
restraining it of keeping the third rank
in order and here comes Johnny what's
wrong with B5 now I mean what is Black's
threat I don't see a single threat no
he's just playing passive and Rook takes
five
we've created one threat we see it maybe
Rook a six and then snake up the Pawns
of B6 and A5 there's also Rook A5
because the bishop on D2 defends it and
you're threading B6 with the 9 out of
five being loose
that's some very sharp tactical Vision
x-raying the Knight
because one thing you're walking is
after Rook A5 you want black to play G6
because then you can put your Rook back
on A7 and threaten back rank checkmates
when you cut the king off so I feel like
inducing that g Pawn forward would be a
good thing so Rook A5 Bishop protects it
threatens B6 he rushes with G4 but won't
that Knight plant itself on H4
threatening Rook takes D2 and don't
forget about the simultaneous threat of
Rook takes B5 I think nihas are just
giving Hikaru his first inkling of
counter play wait takes B5 these
blundered Rook takes B5 a b Rook takes
eight seven and then you can't even take
D4 you want G3 in that position exactly
that he wants Bishop G3 kicking the
Knight back then he'll take on D4 and I
guess he thought this position would be
winning but we see the evaluation bar
say no no no this is actually a position
that black can hold with proper play and
I think what he's missed and perhaps
what's giving him cold feet right now is
that in that resulting position Black's
remaining Rook can get behind the pawn
with a check on the first rank niho
cannot afford to let this game slip
Robert and I think it is slipping
through his fingers Hikaru Nakamura the
Wily veteran he does not go down without
a fight and right now he's ahead by
almost a minute on the clock he now has
made his disadvantage only one Pawn but
it's not gonna be that easy even if the
Rook takes D4 and just parking The Rook
on D5 white will keep that extra pawn
and you don't want to rush her okay one
check because then white would have
refrained from Rook takes D4 and put his
own Rook behind the pawn Hikaru doing
things in the right order Rook D5 keeps
the pawn alive but how are you going to
make progress blackstruck is on an
optimal Square okay he's gonna Rook to
ba and said just defending the Rook from
the pawn excuse me from the front oh I
don't know if I like King H7 why do you
go to F7 yeah weird move and now the
Rook drops back to D5 Bishop C7 and B6
Robert is a massive threat and the big
thing is Knight E7 Rook D7 the Knight
has to move again because the king isn't
defending it
Knight H4 check is a paper Tiger King
drops back to F1 there are no Forks the
king just don't go sinner where once oh
is actually a threat because there's an
Intermezzo check on H5 in the event of
Rook takes B6 wow okay so this is a big
moment for ikaru a king to G8 then
you're just getting bring your king to
where it belongs anyway but B6 happens
fast now the Pod can't get to B7 easily
that's the good news for akaru but the
king is getting to the center what's
wrong with King E2
well what's wrong with B6 ah there's
Rook takes B5 King E2 oh
[Music]
caution walking on hot coals but he's
avoiding the landmines thus far and he
car's clock is dropping maybe 95 here
should be considered 95 maybe G5 he goes
Knight to G5 instead what about King E2
94 trying to Fork on C3 I get it Rook D7
what's your idea
okay yeah Rook D7 that's such a nice
stabilizing move and getting away from
all night checks that's important
Knights are such tricky pieces and the
King can join the action with King C2
that Rook is not stable on the B file
where it has to remain to keep the beep
on restrained uh F4 please F5 check
great move
God nehal just piling it on here where's
the night going
nowhere it doesn't have any good squares
got to go back to the feet or banish to
G5
instead of play King C2 wins Knight 67
losing the spot because BC so here's
King C2 and this should be over King C3
but how do you actually make that final
business before and Rook B5 exactly
repeating he wants to gain some time
five seconds for Neal 6.8 for a car oh
still winning
but ikar was making it to D7 oh my gosh
what do you do
he traded Rooks at exactly the wrong
moment hikara might have a fortress oh
the king's going to H5 the king is
trying to go King F4 no no no no no no
no thinks he blundered again
oh my goodness mihal
that was inexcusable
I cannot believe it he's such a good
bullet player he just had a com and he's
actually the one who has to make the
draw by Cake getting rid of the last
Pawn
oh my gosh if we bring up in that
earlier position oh my gosh he put his
King in the wrong direction
and in this position I it still looks
and don't quote me on this I think it is
winning if you go King F4 then you go
King G3 King H4 King H5 now black can
try to hold on with Knight h8 but then
you give up your Pawn in timely fashion
you go around and you vacuum up the rest
of the pawns which are on dark squares
permanently if 95 the fun ending is also
winning because you create an
Unstoppable passer Robert this is basic
Betty for someone like nihal and instead
where is he going the freeway is closed
and he blunders G4 no that is shocking
from Nelson he didn't even need to trade
the Rooks in that manner either but
somehow Hikaru stays alive long enough
to create problems for nehal Neo Falls
victim to some of these issues and that
means it's still a two-point match I
cannot believe what I'm seeing here but
that is Hikaru Nakamura leading five to
three and this is the Hikaru effect in
action people stumble over their own
moves they miss basic ideas and that's
because Hikaru has rightfully earned
himself a reputation as The Hairy
Houdini of Chess but the good news for
Newhall it's only a two-point match when
you're talking about players of this
caliber Robert that is not a big lead no
it is not and we have seen some
incredible chess some incredible
defensive chess in particular in this
match and we've seen incredible chess
all year so you should get online and go
vote for the 2022 chess.com Awards
because chess.com is celebrating the
games moves and players that brought the
most to the game this year in the
chess.com Awards have your Say by voting
categories like Game of the Year Player
of the Year creator of the year and more
type the command Awards in the chat to
lock in your votes now and I'm gonna
give a shout out to nihal Saron because
I did not see his name in the player of
the year discussion or the rising star
category so go down where you can type
in your own nominees and I would advise
you to think about voting for Neil sarin
but for now I vote we go to break when
returned we'll get the three minute plus
one second increment portion of the
semi-final here between hikar Nakamura
and the al-sara
[Music]
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away
game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
be your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
within the Tempest the best have come to
test their skills and brave the storm
oh my goodness the wheels the wheels
have come out that could be the magic
for some this is familiar ground
oh my goodness 98 whoa
oh my God what a tactic
this is insane oh look at Fabby
exhausting every last resource the
battles will be electric
the moves will be fast it's game over
it's winning oh my God he's gonna make a
queen the stakes will be high he just
grabs his head he can't believe it he
just gave away the pawn the 2022 speed
Chess Championship is now
fasten your speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
welcome back to the speed Chess
Championship semifinal between Hikaru
Nakamura and nihal sarin so far Hikaru
Nakamura has a two-point lead but Dania
it has been a messy Affair chances for
both sides seemingly in every single
position
pleasure to cover this match for its
first a 90-minute half knee-hal is going
to be kicking himself he had
opportunities that went unexploited but
Hikaru he also has room to improve and
that's really scary because if he
already holds a two-point lead and he's
disappointed with himself you know
what's coming in his best segment
well let's check a look take a look at
the chess.com Blitz insights between
these two players because while they've
played many many games you see the
accuracy right both players 30 000 for
Hikaru nearly 20 000 for nihal I would
say the average accuracy is a bit if
it's leading because nehal is actually
one of the most precise players on the
planet but many of his games have
happened when he was younger he's been
playing a chest.com for so long but he
wasn't as established a player but as
you look from top to bottom done what
else catches your eye well it's
interesting the wins and losses by flag
in the case of Neal we know that number
is very low in hikaru's case now it's a
little bit misleading you might say oh
14 is knee-hal a slow player no it's
just the amount of his games that get
into time scrambles is immense so
obviously he's going to lose more games
by flag but he's also going to win more
games by flag and normally against
anybody but Hikaru I would say if your
knee-haul get the game into a Time
scramble but this is the one exception
Hikaru has been Ironclad with both
clocks under 10 seconds he is an
absolute monster you see that when he
wins 77 of his games his winning
percentage is even higher if you include
draws but just to win get a w and 77
percent of your games that is nuts when
you play 30 000 games but a car he's is
locked in right now you see him he is
taking this match seriously as we get
into 60 Minutes a full hour of three
minute plus one second increment time
ritual so Dania are we gonna see title
Tuesday Hikaru winning every game or
what are we going to see from niho was
there a different kind of hikara than
title Tuesday Hikaru title Tuesdays has
he won how many times has he gotten ten
and a half 11 out of 11. this is a very
scary time control if you are knee-hal
you have to be very precise in the
opening and they are repeating a quiet
Queen's Gambit declined with this very
modest 4e3 move by Hikaru and you know
plays Bishop E7 he took a bit of a think
there Knight C3 so this is kind of
standard fare leaving the tension until
the right moment and Bishop D3 only
after capturing on D5 not to waste the
tempo uh but from what we're seeing here
I feel like Hikaru is not ambitious out
of the opening with the white pieces and
he's just saying let me take advantage
later in the game at night E2 he was
rewriting the king side and Hikaru he he
has shown a predilection for these types
of modest lines in SCC matches he wants
to take this match into the middle game
he doesn't necessarily want to enter a
theoretical dispute which makes perfect
sense considering his middle game
success rate but position has changed
quite a bit Bishop takes F3 has happened
pieces are getting traded help me make
sense of this I like Black's position I
think that while the Knight blockades D4
is an iqp on D5 there's a knight and F6
that cannot be dislodged from its
defense so for black you play around the
isolated Pawn what's inherent to having
an iqp you have open files on the
adjacent line C8 and a rook to E8 and I
would play Rook E8 here and maybe go
towards the king side at some point if
White's not paying enough attention a
rookie 5 Maneuvers are indicating or a
night trade on D4 and Rook E6 to get
over to the king side and nihal thinking
exactly in those terms he wants I think
Knight G6 and Knight H4 we saw a similar
idea a couple of games ago and he was
playing with the white pieces remember
that night on G3 that was aiming at F5
and H5 kind of reminds me of this Knight
it's not aiming at F4 it very much is
aiming at H4 but it should be pointed
out Robert that Knight H4 as uh it
currently stands I think can be met with
King G3 you're not gonna be happy you
might have to change your pants but I I
think white survives yeah and you can
just play King H2 and slide away because
F3 is defended you have your own Side
open but Rook G1 is coming so I feel
like it looks a bit Troublesome for Caro
but he's like nah no big deal I
literally don't care
um
and Bishop F5 is not a threat due to a
knight H4 check but once the king slides
over it will become a threat white could
also consider the move F4 just because
White's damaged on the king side doesn't
mean that he can't grab some more space
and control some more squares it's true
yeah this is actually getting very spicy
right now and Troublesome for not Hikaru
but for nihal who is deep in the think
tank down almost a minute on the clock
how are you gonna deal with Bishop F5
not a threat right now you point out
Knight H4 check uh but Bishop F5 is
coming soon kikaru
just Trading
just trading and saying I've got my
Superior Knight on D4 I've got a free
hand on all sides of the board once the
Rooks are traded you no longer have
anything to fear on the king side either
yeah F4 looks like a very nice move he
trades first place he's going to the end
game and claiming the isolated Pawn on
D5 is a long term problem that's how you
play these positions the Knight on D4 is
superb and after Queen C2 Bishops DJ
white has many ideas F4 bring the king
up
um the knights on F6 and G6 are
restricted somewhere in Havana the
spirit of Jose robot Kappa Blanca is
applauding this decision and so am I
this is good practical chess
it looks great I mean you dream of
getting an end game like this typically
and the adventure is not huge you see
he's saying 24.5 now it's at the 0.6
sure uh but how do you actually make
progress B4 expand on the queen side
there it goes you can eventually Play
Bishop B3 to Target the D5 Pawn or keep
pushing your pawns and go after the
queen side so I think that Hikaru is
better but nihal defending well
yeah you're exactly right I just wanted
to say that Knight C6 would be an
instructive mistake because after the
trade it would have a long-term weakness
on A6 which white could easily attack by
re-maneuvering the bishop to the f1a6
diagonal but please continue I interrupt
you the king is going to continue his
journey King seven King E6 smooth man
man smooth that's exactly where it wants
to be I think Newhall has played this
perfectly and that's what happens in end
games of this nature if you are not
perfectly precise with the white side
your advantage dissipates and now in
fact you see the Evo bar is better and
what did Hikaru do moving his Knight
away from D4 I did not understand that
decision at all and a move like a6a5 can
be very unpleasant you have been
pointing this out for a while cutting
through White's Pawn chain and creating
entry points for your Knights and for
your King on the queen side and he plays
Knight E7
throughout the match he's a little bit
too hesitant he's kind of I don't say
scared of Hikaru but I do think the
Hikaru effect is in full swing he's a
little bit nervous he doesn't want to
make big decisions but Neil down to 30
seconds and I don't think he wants to
sit on this position forever I would
surmise that nihal would play A5 against
literally anybody else maybe even
against Magnus Carlson but the Hikaru
effect it's pretty unique it is indeed
and every night we'll go back to C6 the
good news for nihal is that hikar has no
threats right you can just go now Knight
B6 just attacks the bishop he plays B5
but the point is the Knight can come to
C6 back and forth where's the threat I
don't see it A5 I would just go A5
liquidate at least one Pawn off of the
queen side and of course be very careful
if you're a new Hall not to allow a
well-timed knight C5 keep your knight
for D7 as long as you can and he gets
the other night maybe around to E6 looks
like a pretty watertight construction
for black but we know that Hikaru always
finds ways to complicate it he does he
wants Knight F3 and maybe the knight's
hop into G5 or D4 or the E5 depending on
where Black's Knights go and 18 seconds
for Neo uh plenty of time and Knight E5
is about 94 so you can't allow that you
should play it anyway you should play it
anyway trade the knights and trade the
bishop for the night and I think that's
basically a fortress yeah it looks like
it the king can always go up to D5 the
Knight for black can swing around as
well
the car is still trying King D5 if
Knight to D7 watch out for Knight F6
check with the fork the car decline's a
draw here which makes sense but it's
easy to overpress with white as well
Knight B8 has to be considered but
that's a super double-edged move but it
might be I think he'll play it but G5
right like can I just open up a king
side you're absolutely right and with a
two-point lead maybe it's time for
Hikaru uh to carry out a bit of
knee-haul strength and be pragmatic here
no need to do anything crazy he could
make it move like H4 because it's very
difficult for that Knight on E6 to ever
attack the pawn and you're stopping G5
in its tracks uh but actually after
after H4 there could still be G5 right
the Knight on E5 is loose there so you
need to calculate that very concretely
in a car he looked up he did a little
bit of Beth Harmon looking at the
ceiling now he's back at the board
trying to figure out if he can indeed
press in this end game can he achieve
Harmony between his King and his Knight
can he infiltrate Black's watertight
construction I don't think so that
Knight on E6 speaking of Harmony
perfectly placed blocking the king's
access to D4 and Robert wait wait a
minute frustration by the black king
that black king is gonna score again
hesitant by knee-hole not enough time
for Neil he didn't want the king up to
A5 I get it but that was an opportunity
but now Hikaru fixes the pawn on A6 and
he's gonna try to get this Knight around
in due course to maybe B8 it's not
really possible though is it yeah King
D5 if you're Knight D7 Kings now the
King goes back to B7
just in time Knight B8 King B7 forces or
repetition of moves and I think they are
hurtling toward a draw at this point
yeah this is a fortress good play by
both sides here I mean some moments for
each right hikar did have an advantage
against the isolated Queen pawn and neon
never pushed his a pawn right he didn't
take on A4 he didn't play A5 earlier so
nihal he just wanted to manage he wanted
to say I am going to make this draw I'll
take the white pieces then I'll press
and in a weird way this match is
reminding me somewhat of yesterday's
match between mvl and Wesley so there's
this nagging two-point lead three-point
lead and at some point as the clock
starts to take down we're not there yet
there's 50 minutes left for goodness
sake but take another 30 minutes off the
match clock and you're gonna start
having to take more conscious risks if
you're knee-haw because this lead is not
going to erase itself wow that was a big
decision by the car Queen A4 followed by
Rook C1 I think white just takes over
the queen side real quick this is also
good because if you ever pushed C5 still
Rook C1 ideas like that going after the
C5 Pawn
and Knight F3 by Neil and again I feel
like he's playing this in two kind of
straightforward of fashion yes he's
trying to get the Knights of C6 but
Robert that idea of using the Knight to
pester the pawn from B3 maybe put a
queen on A4 it's still very much valid
without the Knight but now I feel like
the worst is behind Hikaru Queen B7
and Knight D7 and I think he's fine yeah
why would Rook C2 Rook F1 to C1 just
continue to pile up a little bit of
pressure but as you're indicating if
that Knight gets to D7 for black then I
think there's no issue whatsoever so uh
Queen A3 I like I love that move yeah
Queen A3 to try to go D4 is Rook C2
first see these are these little moments
where you need to maximize the pressure
on Hikaru because if you don't he's
going to find the way out
and he's trying to actively find the way
out the Knight Finds Its way back to D7
the bishop Finds Its way forward to C6
but isn't there Rook C6 here an
incredibly superficial move there
unfortunately for Newhall if he takes on
C5 he drops B2 in the end and only black
can be better
yeah there's a series of Trades that
white doesn't really want because
they're back rank problems and the D3
Pawn will be loose so this looks like a
mistake from nihal if he plays Bishop G3
back there's Rook A6 as an option and
you're almost safe squares are either on
the fourth rank which drops A2 or queen
back to B3 which gives you a hideous
Pawn structure so I think that nehal
just completely overlooked this Rook
lift and he's given away another sizable
Advantage not only that now Hikaru is
firmly in the driver's seat this is a
big game because Hikaru can open up his
first three-point match lead with a
victory especially if he can win with
the black pieces that would be huge can
nihal keep his composure and pull out
half a point what do you think
not looking good right now he is down a
minute on the clock he just seems just
frazzled right like this What's
Happening Here is he knew that he was
winning in the last game of the five
plus one couldn't make that happen and
then Hikaru was just showing great
defense in critical moments
um and then the last game he did
stabilize but I just feel like nihal is
not on tilt but he just hasn't found his
footing
he hasn't and the reason we're critical
is precisely because we're so used to
Excellence right it's not because we
have it out for him it's because we're
so used to precise play no matter how
much time he has on his clock and some
of these oversights some of these sloppy
moves they've been uncharacteristic and
they've come at precisely the wrong
moment and most importantly against the
wrong kind of opponent as niho gives
away his pawn and tries to achieve
maximum activity with his heavy piece
tandem I think this is a good defensive
approach it is A7 is loose if you play
A6 to keep it defended uh it looks like
black will be passive extra material but
worse pieces and if black wants to say
I'm appalled let me trade Queens with
Queen E4 check Oh I thought he's gonna
Queen F4 for sure me too he goes Queen
C6 I was gonna say queen trade would not
lead to an advantage or
funny blunder would be queenie Fortress
such a tempting move right but F3 wins
the game for white because you cannot
move the queen away with check and
defend the Rook so you do have to move
the Rook Rook B8 seems like the most
natural move Robert what is he car
thinking about here
um whether to play Rook f8 I guess or
Rook to B8 he plays Rook B8 your move
and I'm wondering
oh you are a nasty I'm I'm gonna play
some Blitz today I feel like I feel
sharp yeah no Rook takes F7 Queen C7
check to follow and that's something
that niho he should not miss that uh no
it is it it's a tactic that is hey if an
old retired commentator sees it and so
should knee-haul and he misses another
opportunity now he sets up rook takes F7
without realizing that it was available
on the previous move
yeah I wonder what he was worried about
maybe there was some kind of Queeny
forech he didn't like to see but either
way the Queensland F5 uh Queen F4 now is
a queen chain you don't want because
black gets active too quickly you swap
and I play Rook to B2 and that's bad
news for white you probably lose this a
Pawn on the spot so in some positions
you could trade Queens like Rook A7 Rook
B6 then Queen F4 that might be available
listen I'm honestly in disbelief at the
amount of tactical opportunities that
nihal is leaving on the table he is
gonna have to flip a switch right now
ASAP or this match is going to get away
from him he's getting so passive against
Hikaru and it's not I mean we see the
advantage on the um eval bar 1.7 that
could be a bit misleading because it's
not like there's any tremendous idea at
the moment King H7 looks normal Rook D2
as well but you don't this is not how
you defend against the car you don't
give him you know these long-term
chances because you know what's gonna
happen he's gonna make something out of
nothing eventually
whoa big move there G4
and I'm wondering about a queen trade at
some point like I there it goes Rook
takes D4 and rugby two of Rook A4
that I really like that was an excellent
defensive Choice by Neil but can he pull
it together in this shortcutting maybe a
three to stop Rook before great move
because Rook A4 was still gonna be met
by Rook before giving up the a pawn for
the G Pawn that's what your car really
wants he wants one extra Pawn but if for
it to be two extra pawns on one side and
then one extra Pawn for white on the
other well they all misses the easy
moves and he's finding the hard ones E4
every Pawn trade is in White's favor if
you can get a two on one on the king
side that should be drawable but he car
is going to inch his Kink toward the
center and with five seconds left I just
don't see any Halls holding this before
you swap you trade them before you
usually don't like doing five but you
take and then you Queen at the same time
Rook C5 and King F6 and Hikaru making
progress here Robert he really is
because at some point he's gonna try to
swing this Rook around to B4 where did
he come into D5 and then Rook C4 is
going to be a huge threat yikes it's
gonna be unstoppable it's just over it
now Rook C4
but again he holds going total passive
mode Rook A1 still holding but not for
long yeah I don't think this is gonna be
anything King can go to C5 instead yeah
Rook C3 is possible here or this
I'm wondering if at some point you just
give up the pawn to get active but no
chance he's not even allowing mihal to
win the F6 Pawn he's a car is doing this
while keeping his material advantage
attack this is It's Exquisite filigree
technique and there's a resignation man
he earned that one that was just
um you know he outplayed nihal who
couldn't find the Tactical shots when he
knew them and then a car was able to
secure that full point and I think
that's a bit of a smile
and nihal he's flustered he's
discombobulated he's not playing the
hall star in chess right now he's
playing right into hikaru's hands and
like I said he needs to flip a switch
and he's got to do it now because
this is the threshold that Hikaru
himself pointed out the three-point lead
Robert if it gets up to four you start
feeling like you're almost in blowout
territory if you get it back down to two
hey you're right back in the match but
can nehal pull it off with the black
pieces
well we'll see E3 one of those quiet
systems once again here nehal strikes
with C5 uh in previous games he was a
little bit uh delayed at hitting in the
center now plays B6 so it's sort of a
combination of his opening plans and it
looks like a Queen's Gambit accepted
position
it does and we had this yesterday where
suddenly mvl was playing the stuff that
Wesley was playing here Hikaru is
playing the type of position nehal was
playing with white and E4 forces a
better end game for white again
and hikar is so good at these types of
positions we've seen him beat all of the
best players in the world in this type
of structure A5 is a very important move
from nihal mingsha B4 isn't going to be
played and now probably H6 you're not
afraid of Bishop takes F6 G takes F6 you
get the bishop pair and Hikaru just kind
of feels like a runaway train right now
and he starts winning games he becomes
even more confident he starts playing
faster and at some point you know he
just goes Magnus Carlson mode
well that's scary for Neil sorry we saw
a Magnus did to five on a carwana
several days ago so G5 is the big
question right now for nihal there could
be even a sack on G5 in some positions
but not this one because the bishop 1 C5
can always Retreat to E7 to break the
pin I really like that decision for knee
hold this is the kind of Chess he's got
to play principled ambitious go for the
throat and H4 bikie Caro an idea that
we've talked about in a lot of different
types of positions nehal leaves the pawn
on G5 using tactics using the eventual
Rook H1 check as an indirect defense
good play so far by the Indian
Grandmaster great play from niho I mean
look at this right you see the pawn
structure the E4 Pawn is the one that
sticks out the most so that is going to
be a long-term liability that white
needs to deal with Black's Rooks are
connected Black's King is on E7 nicely
placed so white will need to either
Castle which not clear which side you
would go to or play King to E2 but after
King E2 there's also ideas like Knight
H5 going after the bishop on G3 and then
a well-timed G4 could send this Knight
back to Timbuktu White's position is
suddenly not as good as it looked just a
couple of moves ago I think nihal is out
playing Hikaru in the early stages of
this end game but out playing Hikaru in
the early stages of anything is just the
start of what you need to do and Knight
H5 Rook H1 would be annoying just going
for this pin so I like Knight H5 because
the bishop can't move because F2 is
loose he goes for F2 directly with
Knight G4 giving up G5 to take a better
Pawn
okay but what's the follow-up he plays
F6 kind of slow rolling and controlling
squares in the center may be preparing
an eventual Knight D to E5 although you
don't really want to play it immediately
because that ruins your own structure
hikaru's sinking his teeth into one of
the only strongholds that he has Bishop
B5 annoying move and again Robert it's
starting to seem Bishop C7 oh my God
blender
oh look at him God this never happens to
nihal he can't believe he's like an old
man yeah he he's beside himself and
Hikaru is like wait did he really just
blunder this ship takes V8 and it's
resign time after Knight T4 whatever
night anywhere for I'm not sure who is
more surprised by that blunder like
hikara looked at the camera and it's
kind of like uh am I really playing
nihal or am I playing one of my chatters
yeah I can't believe it I mean these
blunders don't happen when he's got .3
seconds in a tactical position this is a
pretty stable end game with obvious
tactics and Rook h8 to D and moving The
Rook away from the open file Robert that
move didn't make sense no matter how you
looked at it
black still has some chances to survive
this yeah which is absolutely crazy to
think about when you just hang a full
exchange but E5 next will kick The Rook
off the fourth rank to win the E4 Pawn
if you play F3 you blender Knight B3
check watch out for Forks so E5 is the
next move and actually you know still in
this game somehow he is and this is what
nihal does when he's on form he can pull
it out in any position I love the fact
that nihal didn't just resign I think a
lot of people in that situation would
have just said I blundered reside next
game not nehal he says I'm gonna keep
trying I'm gonna pull myself together
and he's got serious chances here but
Robert I'm so skeptical when you're
playing Hikaru doesn't usually give
these types of games away but now it's I
know a car is better I'm not gonna
dispute that that's obvious right but I
feel like if you could safely take E4
which I'm not sure you can because Rook
C7 check and King d a very important
move because King D6 love Rook C6 with
check and F3 would have been a fork of
knights but my point is if you can
somehow like take the F2 pawn and give
up B6 now you have a scramble where
black has extra Pawns in the center why
is it actually upon the queen side and I
know white has more material but will
give some chance of Bishop F5 Bishop D3
though oh another Blood sight by Neon
and it stops Knight takes F2 there's no
defended Square on this diagonal and at
this point Black's position collapses
and nihal resigns again yeah and he is
really upset and look at the car he's
like next let's get the next one going
he's the next one going he does not want
any time between the games uh he just
wants to you know steamroll Neo at this
point
and this is where he wants to end the
match he doesn't want this hanging in
the Nether world of a three or four
point lead if you're Hikaru you're
trying to push this up to a six or seven
point match because you know how amazing
New Hall is in bullet and you know that
the SEC this year just has had a habit
of things getting turned around in the
bullet so for hikar you're not playing
games you are stepping firmly on the gas
pedal in these next 39 minutes and
change for sure and look at the car's
face by the way he doesn't seem thrilled
about how this opening has gone and we
saw this similar opening I believe is in
the Levon aronian against Dimitri on
Drake and match uh where they kind of
had his iqp structure uh quite often but
Hikaru now with the black side against
the isolated Queen Pawn he just had the
white side a couple games ago and it's
interesting to see how the players they
sort of play in a similar Style
yeah and the position is very
symmetrical here Newhall decided to
recapture with the pawn on D4 keeping
the Knight for defensive purposes but is
this really the way Robert to play
ambitiously looks like Hikaru has zero
problems and he can even try for an
advantage with c65 does that work out
I'm guessing at the very least y'all
wants to induce that move it might be
better for black in the moment but it
just creates some long-term weaknesses
instead of Hikaru backtracks it brings
Knight back to D7 attacking the pawn on
E5 I think Bishop F4 seems quite nice
Queen H5 is another possibility I think
Neil has to as they sees the initiative
he does it with the move F4 I was a
little bit worried if black can take
control of the light squares but I don't
think it car is quick enough
I don't think he is either and I think
nihal has gotten the upper hand here
another opportunity that he has to try
to capitalize on the car deploying his
Bishop to B7 looks like a foolish
developing square but no no no if he
manages to play C5 and D4 that Bishop
turns into a three-headed Hydra yeah and
if you could get Knight A4 and your
Bishop to E3 in one move then black is
like strategically in huge trouble
because uh you just clamp down on the
dark squares that's the benefit of
having opposite colored Bishops but
black also has the F6 their white needs
to keep in mind if you play Bishop E3 I
think black immediately strikes with F6
and I think F6 right now and I think
Neil has underestimated and maybe he's
prepared E6 in response followed by a
five
so what's the way for Hikaru he slow
rolls it with A6 preparing C5 and then
B4 has become a very strong what's going
on B5 C5 Knight C5 95 I can't predict
anything Rook B1 here perhaps after a b
Rook takes B4 hits the bishop on B7 and
you would love to lift your Rook to the
king side rookie three to G3 or in this
case Rook B1 to B4 play F5 and Rook to
G4 I know it's a long story but a rook
lift is what white desperately needs for
an attack and you could deploy The Rook
to E3 right now I like birds with one
stone defend the Knight aim for G3 aim
for G4 with the queen this is where
nihal just has to change the way he's
been playing and can't fault him for
Bishop D2 Robert but again I Feel Like
It suffers from the same fault uh that a
lot of his moves this match have fallen
for which is just overly passive play
not going for the throat when he needs
to try and giving Hikaru the types of
positions he wants of course I'm saying
all of this I would do five times worse
no of course we're not trying to say
that uh he's doing a bad job but I do
think from you know a strategy
perspective he is not putting enough
pressure on a car he's making the safe
moves but that means they're also safe
for Hikaru and right now Queen D5 lined
up with the bishop on B7 C5 next all of
a sudden if C5 and C4 happen it's black
whose pawns are rolling so uh for nihal
will he play Queen G4 here A2 is also
loose you have to consider that I know
the 97 is hanging this particular
variation but after Queen G4 black does
have a few things to figure out
and queen G4 should be played within a
couple of seconds nehal falling behind
on the clock he goes Knight D6 instead
and I thought C5 okay now he plays Queen
G4 but what about rookie six Knight [ __ ]
lift of his own oh yeah the E7 Square
vulnerable
H6 and F5 come that could end up in
Checkmate real quickly either so either
side could get checkmated here but
Hikaru seems to have the shorter end of
the stick as he shoves his Pawn through
to H5 deflecting the queen deflecting
he allows hectic pronunciation there he
allows H4 he all rookie six is still met
by Knight F5 but then maybe there's that
G6 movie talked about
yep and by the way this is an idea
that's been uh played by both sides this
H5 followed by G6 defensive concept very
important to remember
and now both sides down to a minute a
bullet game here we go okay Knight F5
there's no f56 must play Knight F5 no he
takes the bishop oh he wants F5 now
because he's a G3 Rook G6 Intermezzo
there was Queen F3 oh here come the
pawns yeah actually H5 pushed the queen
to a even better Square to allow for F5
he goes H4 to strike the queen what a
queen F4 win F4 gotta play gotta keep
the E Pawn if you take on H4 you give up
the Crux of your attack Queen F4 and E6
I think you should try
yeah maybe even F6 why is he delaying on
Queen F4 what is the counter punch I
think he's conflicted because Queen
takes H4 might be tempting maybe he's
thinking about some F6 move but all of
that seems so wait wait it's four rookie
five F6 if Rook takes you won there's F
Takes Two with an Intermezzo Queen H
Checkmate is a thread that's what he's
thinking about but it wouldn't work it
actually would not have worked because
black could have thrown in a check of
his own to uh cause distractions of
Queen F4 is his choice he spent a lot of
time playing Queen F4 he lost his lead
on the clock in akaru he's seeing F6
he's seeing E6 he has to be nervous of
those pawns rolling love the way Newhall
is handling the attack here Knight f8 is
such a cold-blooded move just saying hey
I don't care about F6 my knight is a
hero of a Defender when it sits on G6
covering this all-important h8 Square 10
seconds for knee-hole he's gonna move he
really must and he takes an H4 Knight G6
with a queen G3 very quickly and watch
out for E6 as well because E6 will
distract the pawn F7 oh and Hikaru is
alert to E6 watch for hikaru's pawns the
Robert he's got connected passers in the
center and they Rumble up the board so
quickly watch out for H4 H5 as well so
black spawns pushing white pushing on
the flame Brooke A4 what a move
attacking the bishop attacking the
Knight now when he takes F4 gets
checkmated and rookie for hg6 how is it
surviving oh my God
what a move no no Rook H5 Queen D4 Queen
F2 oh my gosh
he goes he's winning it's over holy sh
oh my God cheese balls look at those
pawns on the sixth record six Space
Invaders up there and if going down
Queen E3 rookie three rookie six the win
is to take play F7 and then Rook B1
infiltrating to B8 wow and if this game
ends here we will show that variation
Hikaru he's bleeding the clock he plays
rookie six but we see there's the whack
variation F7 it is Rook B1 what a
cold-blooded way to end and what a
brilliant comeback win for knee-haul wow
that might have been the move of the
match E6 I mean he was throwing all his
pawns everything but the kitchen sink at
Hikaru and he was the one eating there
he gets a victory cuts the deficit to
three points and he needs to seize the
momentum as we're about to get to the
halfway point of this time segment
ladies and gentlemen this match is so
far from over it's far from being a
blowout and we see Whitney Hall Saran is
capable of when he believes in himself
he plays his style and he gets these
tactical positions Robert I just think
he needs to try to switch his style and
that's exactly what he's doing here
Hikaru though is the one who switches
his first move we've got a right Lopez
on our plates we do indeed that on your
plate give a shout out to one of the
featured Chatters I saw that uh
flickering across the screen saying that
Hikaru is just proud and actually I feel
like hikar often is like that when
somebody out calculates him yeah he's a
little disappointed but I feel like he
genuinely is proud of nehal and in some
ways Dania maybe this is out of left
field but is nehal kind of like not a
mini Hikaru but like in the sense that
Hikaru grew up being a speed demon then
eventually crossed 2700 became a top
player I feel like nihal has many of the
same attributes as a chess player
asikara did he absolutely does and just
to co-sign that point I would say that
they also have this incredible mixture
of attacking and tactical Acumen both of
them are ridiculous at seeing short
tactics they're great calculators but at
their core I think both Hikaru and niho
this is often underestimated about
Hikaru are actually positional players
they've got a great sense of where
pieces belong and yet in this match I
think nihal has to deviate his style and
try to go full tactical mode
I agree and right now he has a strong
center with the black position again and
I just want to give a shout out to the
40 plus thousand people watching across
twitch and YouTube we're really happy
for that you're joining us here it is an
epic match and a card knock more with a
three-point lead right now renewal sorry
but if you look at the evaluation bar
and the position in this game wise
pieces are in weird places The Rook nf2
now pinned uh this bishop on B3 stare
down with the bishop on E6 the queen on
E1 doing a defensive task so you have to
be very careful here if you're a car
Nakamura you just lost the previous game
Dania you cannot afford to let this one
go as well but Newhall he's putting
pressure I like the way he's playing
he's playing quickly as he improves the
placement of his Rook so does he car
there's a lot of hidden tension going on
in the D file the moment D take C4
happens you could get a bunch of Trades
I don't think it's a nehal's favorite to
trade I think he wants Hikaru to be the
one to concede the center with e takes
D5 that would be a bad idea leaving the
fun free to rule to roam forward wow and
look at me I'll go A5 was a good first
punch and it's a one-two combo with B4
and Bishop A4 a one move threat that
Rook can just move up to E7
yeah and I think it will he's perhaps
thinking about throwing in BC I don't
really think that's necessary I don't
think it necessarily hurts or helps
either player
yeah I don't know why you would need to
throw them away it's not like white
really wants to take on B4 anyway he
plays Rook E7 so again nehal very
deliberate in his actions he has a
slight lead on the clock but I actually
think it's his position that gives him
the most chances unlike some of the
previous games here with the black piece
is he is has Stout defense and he can
turn that into offense a rook can go to
C7 and try to create an open file and
what nihal has desperately needed in the
three minute portion is confidence and I
think he's gotten so much confidence
back on the heels of that amazing
victory in the previous game you can
just sense the energy the new confidence
the momentum in his play the match hangs
in the balance can Hikaru muster up yet
another comeback Knight appears on F5
and I think it's going to be captured
and after EF no knee Hall just leaves
the Knight there and moves his Rook away
attacking C3 yeah because the pawn E4 is
stuck in the mud can't take on D5 you
lose that 9 F5 so Bishop takes F5 can
happen soon C3 under attack if C before
you just take back the open seafo is
good for black and what about taking
I'm trying to look at de4 make that work
as well yeah I don't think it does it's
the position smells of tactics it's like
smelling Mama's cooking when you're
upstairs it wafts out but where exactly
is that punch I don't see it maybe an
improving move is necessary like Knight
G6 to F4 yes and the queen comes out to
G3 oh and then you have that five and a
fork I need two that's so easy to miss
yes this Fork on E2 is available it's
happened in many games once a knight
lands at F5 and F4 watch out for the E2
and E7 Square so uh right now Queen G3
does not work as you just pointed out
and a car has to watch overnight D3 as
well
yeah Forks Galore in this position the
Knight on F5 can't do all the heavy
lifting on its own and what a
cold-blooded response by Hikaru but this
is not a move played out of Desire it's
played out of necessity it's the only
way to avert all of the forks and again
can nihal keep his foot on the gas pedal
in this position can he take an A2 it's
a very brave move it might be a bad move
but I'm wondering if you can just snag
that pawn there and get away with it
somebody hasn't had breakfast nihal has
had his breakfast and he offers Hikaru
some breakfast sacrificing H6 how many
times have we seen the move G6 with a
knight on F5 or F4 it's a fantastic move
I give up that pawn to get one back and
with interest so Knight goes back to E3
Knight D3 the queen just slides up to E2
he takes on C3 here so White's Pawn
structure is bad right A2 C3 split black
has an extra Pawn in the center towards
the king side so where next that's the
big question maybe just a slow improving
move like King to G7 just pass the
turnover you're mentioned Queen C5 to A3
that looks good as well
but nihal taking the concrete approach
where is that night going I think it's
dropping back towards C5 no no it moves
back to F4
Carl tries to take the opportunity to
rep it's not that he's declining
repetition it's more that he thinks the
queen is better on F3 and I think it is
back to B3 if you take on B3 a takes B3
you fix white spawn structure so I don't
know if you want that he doesn't it goes
Rook D7 to the open file now Knight C4
is possible but not that dangerous the
queen can always slide back to C7 or
forward to C5 Knights are traded Oh I
thought you take with a knight on E6
takes the queen Knight B3 is a threat of
A5 and that fork that you're pointing
out you do not want to fall victim to a
fork out of nowhere
and how do you actually defend both at
the same time because if you play Queen
B6 the other Knight could slide into C4
and suddenly Hikaru not only up 25
seconds on the clock he's creating a lot
of concrete threats Queen C6 good move
attackie E4 Pawn take that right now now
black has two extra pawns on the f e
fuzz white as the split extra pawns
passers on the queen side wow they are
passers nonetheless Hikaru attacks C5
the C Pawn is rumbling forward this is
very losable H5 yes doesn't work because
HG and G3 check and you make the white
king amazing and Hikaru has to drop back
to F2 takes in Rook C3 get behind the
pawn 1993 readers Rook at three and then
E4 and F5 he goes to E6 avoiding the
trouble oh this is really bad for for
white Black's just winning a pawn and
now you've had two extra Pawn lead on
the king side Rook F3 a chance but C5
drops key car is going to give up C5 and
put the Rook behind the pawn try to push
it push it as far as it'll go and that's
not far at all can nehal convert this
position I like the move H4 keeping more
Pawns of the board because that black
King's gonna G5 and F4 eventually the
white king I think is too slow to get up
towards the a pawn
I think it might be a draw though you
could get into a situation where pushing
either Pawn opens up holes on in the
center that whites King can occupy this
could be something resembling a fortress
but maybe there's some kind of zukes
song at some point that if you're not
careful in a carburetor car's moves seem
easy okay
oh wow then F4 and the King B4 you just
have to be a little bit careful maybe it
works
he goes can you be full maybe it's time
for Rook F1 E4 E4 Rook F4 oh my gosh
she's just getting the pawns and they're
stuck in place the other ones it's I
don't know but you can try oh a car
trying to get his King up and win the
pawns but he might not make it in time
oh gosh kick somebody E2
and then you have to try the side checks
with rookie oh he sacks The Pawn King F5
E3 is it enough King G5 I think you're
in time
I think it's a draw yes just four
you just can't bring the king no you can
actually bring the king all the way up
to G7 and back by the hair on his chinny
chin chin Hikaru manages to pull out the
drug don't miss rookie three but it's
really actually a draw that's a big
question I think it is because you're
gonna promote to a knight at the end but
that could be zooksbon let's watch okay
here we go it's a drug it's not even
yeah yeah the king's not near it nearly
close enough it's just to draw another
another incredible save by Hikaru
and look at it Karo he's wasting a few
extra seconds look at this he didn't
promote right away he spent some time it
is a draw and that means we are ready
for our break a car gets out of his
chair nihal sarin I mean he was so close
to cutting this to a two-point deficit
with the end game was another brilliant
defensive hold from ikara Nakamura it
really was and the hall is going to be
frustrated but he should pull out the
Silver Lining from the last 15 minutes
or so he won a brilliant game with white
he drew from a position of strength with
black yes he would have preferred to win
the game but he's got the white pieces
again in the next game and I feel Robert
maybe I'm jumping to conclusions too
early but he has been playing with a lot
more confidence in the last couple of
games and he needs to try to get this
lead down to two or maybe even one point
he certainly is because against anybody
else in this competition Nielsen will
have the advantage in bullet chess but a
car Nakamura no slouch in that format
either the bullet chess champion
multiple time BCC Champion so Hikaru
keeps this lead we are going to head to
break just like the players in win
return it's more three plus one time
control in this matchup in semifinals of
the SEC between Hikaru Nakamura and the
al-sara
foreign
[Music]
is anybody in snoops Camp playing chess
is that happening or not I haven't seen
it there's some smart people in the camp
so I wouldn't be surprised if people
are versed at it very uh a lot of
college educated people you know I
unfortunately am not one of those
sophisticated people that play chess in
the camp what you talking about man I
don't play chess
I mean you know how to play I listen
there's a difference with knowing how to
start a car up and then driving Formula
One racing
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
and we return here in the semi-final
match between Hikaru Nakamura and nihal
sarin and thus far it's been all Mr
Pineapple Hikaru Nakamura you see the
pineapple flashing behind him there and
he says I can't be bothered let me
continue this match yeah he's had this
match under control from wire to wire
there's been up and downs ups and downs
for Hikaru there's gonna be moments
where he will be disappointed with his
lack of tactical awareness or missing uh
faster win here and there but at the end
of the day he has this match where he
wants it to be he's got a three-point
lead with only 20 minutes or so left in
the three minute portion Robert if you
told him that that would be the
situation he would accept it with uh
without a second thought although
sometimes it feels like he has done so
much winning that three-point lead may
not feel as much as he is capable of
because Hikaru Nakamura has defeated
David parabin and levada by Hefty
margins his lifetime record a whop
unbelievable 23 wins and two losses in
the speed test Championship he's only
lost to Magnus Carlson
you take hikaru's winning ways for
granted so often but what's amazing
about that record is just who his
opponents have been and he's defeated
nihal and shmihal and aronian and mvl
and literally you name it to lose only
to Magnus Carlson considering the SEC
Fields the last couple of years is like
I pointed out last time reminiscent of
Floyd Mayweather's boxing record it's
crazy crazy consistency
it really is just an insane figure there
are only two match losses 23 match wins
against the best of the Chess World and
here we go Niha will have to produce his
best to mount amount of comeback at this
stage he has playing you know this
Knight F3 Knight CD qgd and now getting
into Catalan territory if Hikaru takes
on C4 which he does not I call this the
kramnik Catalan usually in the Catalan
the Knight stays on B1 because it often
is deployed to D2 this is a viable
continuation popularized by kramnik uh a
decade or so back and the structure
changing with an early trade on D5
Hikaru recapturing with the Knight
Robert which could strike a lot of
players as less natural than taking with
a pawn But ultimately we get the same
structure and ooh what about E4 here
we're getting sloppy yeah because E4
Knight G5 take on e4 things like that he
plays Bishop G5 which I don't think is a
bad move but it wasn't as tactically
alert as he could have been and again I
will contend that against you know a
lesser Grand Master in the hall would
against me he'd play for in like three
seconds
although inducing F6 doesn't look so bad
either but you're right because missing
this tactic that you need to be as sharp
as a knife to beat Hikaru Nakamura right
because he is a defensive Maestro and if
you're not putting him away he'll find a
way back and right now Knight E1 I like
the maneuvering of these pieces for the
second time today he's got a knight on
D3 and I definitely approve and the
Knight on D3 spinning its way toward F4
although you don't necessarily want to
play Knight F4 too quickly that pawn on
D5 can be easily defended in a variety
of ways instead Yeehaw opting for
pressure on the queen side a typical
move before he might follow it up with
A4 and potentially E5 but you don't want
to overextend yourself you also want to
keep your eye open for tactics like
Knight C5 I was wondering that can White
Knight C5 right now no and let's pull up
an analysis for this is very instructive
if you play Knight C5 you know where I'm
going with this art don't you yes I do
Bishop back to E7 and apparently this is
still equal but after Queen B7 I thought
the queen is lost it might be timely
Bishop H3 you're absolutely right at the
end of this line there is amazingly the
move Bishop H3 and so black actually has
to repeat moves with Rook AB8 in order
to have the response F5 crazy lines here
they don't go for it let's get back to
the live chord okay we see a swap of
Bishops on D6 so not too much as as
change except for the exchange Bishop F4
Bishop takes D6 and now we're in a
position where Knight C5 all right
that's not gonna happen anymore let's
I'm not focus on the tactics but let's
look at the underlying structure the C6
Pawn potential Target A7 you don't want
to keep take your eye away from that for
too long because a queen A3 can really
keep Black's pieces stuck in place or
queen A4 can hit C6 and keep the pizza
stuck in place so it would be a double
whammy so I think right now you know it
needs to find that accurate move did you
like that led show with the A7 oh look
at that show with an exchange
five five B5 he's winning oh it just
wins it wins on the spot he can't miss
this and he doesn't any car with a big
blunder there and a car completely
overlooked you saw his reaction there
he's like what am I thinking to allow
this and now there's gonna be a Pawn on
C6 he hasn't taken it yet there he goes
he can play can't get E4 and D5 because
the D4 Pawn is loose but the game is so
far from over nihal's Pawn Phalanx in
the center is decisive it should yield
Victory but Hikaru for the time being is
going to stabilize and keep his pieces
in the center and try to keep White's
minor pieces at Bay most important for
Hikaru is to keep this Knight firmly
entrenched on C7 do not let this pawn
move forward Knight A6 runs into B5
exactly that's how I say be very very
careful here a nice X would be a blunt
he goes back to D3 good recognition by
nihal if hikar doesn't lose this game
I'm just gonna be a disbelief this looks
so incredibly lost I see 3.6 on the Eva
bar if I was just looking at this I'm
like okay white has to win this game of
course look at the B6 spawn look at the
passer on C6 look at the weak light
squares all across the board how in the
world can anyone survive this game let's
see if a car can show us well so far so
good for knee-haw he is making massive
progress he has tied black down to the
B6 spawn night before was an incredibly
astute positional move because it
provoked this weakness and here come the
other puns Robert I don't like the
phrase the position plays itself because
well no nihal is handling the white
pieces here as far as I know but this
should be pretty straightforward if he
avoids any tactical blunders yeah Queen
D4 are just a pilot pressure on B6 that
doesn't look so fun
um as you said E4 F4 E5 you can play
like that you can play Quiet Moves Like
H3 right just like a little move here
and there uh to improve your position if
you feel it helps but E4 is just
self-explanatory start with E4 it
doesn't you know it's not a committal
move in any way F4 is somewhat more
committal but your king is still
perfectly safe Hikaru desperately trying
to prevent F4 he's preparing on pistol
but I think H3 disrupts the pawn yeah H
oh because Knight F4 is so good also
good Queen E2 next to win the pawn on G4
directly
I would play H3 at some point though
just to free up your pawns Knight takes
D5 no there's Queen D2 or something like
that
close one
how many extra points does white have B5
and this is excellent defense by Hikaru
his only chance is to create a passer on
the queen side Robert I'm getting a very
bad feeling about this already I know
it's plus five but I've been in the
situation so many times against icaro
yeah right just giving him a chance as a
pawn is sprinting to the other side A4
A3 A2 happens before you know it and
look at the dark Square control by
hikaru's Queen C7 not available the
knight in Queen cover D6 is covered by
both those pieces as well so I feel like
nihil should still be winning but he's
down to 18 seconds and he's got to find
a move and queen H4 was the correct one
he allows the queen trade at A4 oh my
gosh
and Knight T4 apparently is the best
move here just going for the mass trade
of pieces and 92 check is a fork oh my
God that's a devastating Intermezzo but
he finds Knight C3 instead but what's
the difference
b19 he put her to screen no way
the car was gonna win this or maybe not
Robert that tells you how winning
White's position was he blundered a
queen and it's still not that clear yeah
you want E5 and D6 that's what you so it
goes C7 he wants D6 next
time King F7 they're still D6
exactly
wait a second folks this is not over yet
uh absolutely three result game forget
the darned eval bar oh
yeah and I wonder if your car missed yet
King E8
maybe not Perpetual he's got Perpetual
check and Hikaru has to take the mature
call and make it oh wait it's gonna take
the 96 of the coin oh my God and then
there's like E5 and Bishop kidding me
wait Bishop D five or Bishop B7 but
Bishop is pg6 Bishop
Queen G6 to B1 oh my gosh he blundered
oh
that is
a Backbreaker
oh my gosh
how does he do it
he doesn't know himself he's shaking his
head sometimes I think Hikaru can't even
believe himself and that guess what the
moment he played B5 Robert I could sense
it you called it you absolutely called
it and Neil just missed this 92 fork and
then he still had chances and then he
missed the queen G6 to B1 takes B7 Fork
it is absolutely ridiculous and now the
lead is ballooned to four whereas about
to be cut to two you called nihal a mini
Hikaru this is kind of what nihal was
doing in the cgc on a much lesser scale
of course but he was pulling some of
these positions out nobody could believe
it and hikara just does this on a daily
basis this is just what he does every
match you just cannot bring him down it
doesn't matter how many extra pawns you
have it doesn't matter how winning you
are it doesn't matter what the evil Bar
says he will always find a way to
complicate it and the moment you get
down below 30 seconds he is just gonna
find the right buttons to press the
right times and to win that position is
absolutely unbelievable I just feel like
Hikaru never takes a move off
right some players that get a little bit
lazy here and there even when a car
makes mistakes it still feels like he's
really digging deep at every turn I I he
expends all of his energy in every
single chess game and the way he just
won that game is mesmerizing it's
unbelievable I I just don't think
anybody else would have won that game no
way know-how and here he goes the four
point lead we have to somehow focus on
the game we have in front of us and we
see it's a symmetrical Pawn structure
slightly more space on the queen side
for white but black very solid and
defended in the center
and the last time things started to get
out of hand Hikaru did I believe have a
four point lead and then nihal won that
brilliant game with three pawns on the
sixth rank McDonald labordane Style uh
famous game from the early 1800s where
black had three pawns on the second rank
so nehal needs a little bit more where
that came from and he's off to a good
start watch out for Bishop takes H3
taxes does not work here because the
queen now protects the knight in F3 but
if you're not careful that could be an
easy thing to overlook
yeah most certainly is a difficult
defensive task awaitsikaru I would not
call this 0.00 this does look a lot more
comfortable for nehal but I feel like
I'm a broken record Robert here we go
with this again can he convert and he
just wants rookie seven rookie eight
he's playing good moves the D5 Pawn may
be hanging in some position oh Knight A5
is C4 perhaps I feel like nihal is just
traumatized by the move B5 whether it
comes with the white pieces or the black
pieces because we remember what happened
in the previous game when icaro played
B5 but here's a blunder because Queen B5
Bishop takes H3 oh you called it
you forgot about it yeah that's actually
a very important Pawn because it may
look ugly and doubled but it's not easy
to win and the C4 Square becomes blacks
for the taking
yeah no this is a big big oversight and
he car you can just tell you realize
it's now it's a little too late but
obviously you should not stop only take
on B5 I feel like H3 is upon you simply
cannot afford to lose no but now Hikaru
down quite a lot of time nihal he needs
this game you see it on his face right
he is laser focused he is trying to tune
everything in the world out he steals 11
and a half minutes in this time control
so if he can start rolling he will have
a chance heading into bullet right now
what moves does hicaro have
what moves does sicaro have I think
that's the question he's asking himself
and he has not been able to answer it in
over a minute I don't I don't know Rook
Knight C3 I was thinking that
but does it work tactically I guess it
does yeah maybe you should make it out
okay 95 that looks good for white
because Queen G6 there's Knight F4 stuff
oh our Knight takes E7 always hanging so
what about Knight takes D4 because that
Pawn's also hanging oh I forgot about
that one Knight D4 Knight D4 Queen D4
Queens in the center but you probably
get away with it F2 is hang out there so
you have to take on e4 and then go rook
cd1 and I'm gonna let uh the qualified
players calculate this my guess Robert
is that we're gonna get some sort of
Queen end game or Rook end game where he
carves down a pawn but has serious
strong chances I'm saying that really
without calculating anything concretely
and when you say drawing chances I guess
at this point we'd say also winning
winning chances exactly he wins anything
in front of him so Knight takes C3 uh if
Rook takes E7 there could be Knight
takes B1 that's at least worthy of
calculation uh so crazy pieces he
doesn't score it Knight B1 yeah what's
the follow-up does he just want to drop
his Rook back that would be
anti-climactic I think he wants Rook
takes no rookie795 oh oh my God that's
such an easy Fork to miss the side Fork
yeah so Knight takes B1 what is the move
Rook back to E1 as you indicated
but I feel like there's something there
he takes D4 this is where in in the
previous parts of that she would take on
E7 he has to step on the gas but I'll go
for it and take on B1 and do it quickly
ah he goes Queen to E7 still keeping a
bit of an advantage but it feels like
Knight takes people when it was muddying
the waters in a good way for him he
wants Bishop F5 to E4 I think exerting
tremendous pressure indirectly on the D4
Pawn Knight 64 94 Queen one check that
possible call eagle eyes
I've been so complicated that's actually
that good right it's clearly better for
black you steal a second Pawn but that
Knight is a firm blockader on the D4
Square so maybe it's worth just opting
for a bishop before your old idea to
keep the tension
yeah but considering he didn't take on
B1 which was just such a good try I feel
like he's gonna play Knight takes D4 and
steal the clock and again he's falling
behind on the clock he's hesitating he's
got two enticing options and he goes for
the concrete one good call
Queenie one Bishop takes B1 and it's
Queen E5 checks so you better be very
careful
Hikaru watching on hot calls and
stepping over mines left and right Rook
to E3 Queen takes F2 is another nasty
continuation give me all those pawns
gift me them I will gladly take them
Bishop
Knight F3 not a bad move at all Queen
effort we want to go a queen E4 Queen
four keep everything defended
the one with blender it's a one move
blunder oh my God Nicole's not moving
now he does hey look at the car he can't
believe it and neither could neither I
was like wait a second can I really get
it and a resignation from Hikaru and
niho shakes his head but he's right back
in this match it's a three-point deficit
once more and I do think in this case
Robert he followed your advice from the
previous side when resigning a little
bit earlier than he normally would the
position was completely lost right the
bishop was coming to E4 that I think was
beyond salvation even for Hikaru he was
down a thousand pawns but he wants two
more games he wants to bring this lead
back up and avoid something crazy
happening in the bullet he believes in
his chances big big two games I'm
laughing because nihal is white and he
became the B3 Cowboy first so he's just
saying come on come on a car I know you
love this opening but I'm gonna get to
it and somewhere adibon is smiling at
his compatriots play but I actually
think that black is perfectly fine in
this position just a little bit more
cramped and 95 there walked into Knight
takes E6 so don't put your 995 until
you've defended the square but Bishop F6
also runs into 94. so we've had a very
similar position before Robert but this
I think I agree is a slightly improved
version for black still I think the hall
is so comfortable in the structure
he is and he was able to beat Anish gear
in a rapid time control in the cgc he
has shown some good play against Hikaru
here in the this SEC match and what's
Black's plan right white put all of
these pieces in optimal squares if you
go Rook C8 you drop the A6 ball let's
not forget about the bishop and queen
inline attacking A6
and this is a move you see pretty often
in these types of positions it's got
multiple ideas right you are aiming at
H2 obviously you're not really thinking
about Checkmate just yet you could bring
the bishop back to D6 and build a
battery it's just sort of a general
solidifying move and here comes nihal
throwing himself at the king side and if
H6 Robert I'll let you drink your tea
but what's this follow-up is it 96
double take that's exactly what I was
wondering that 65 at the end tactics
Galore here and nihal sarin he is maybe
no longer afraid he's been playing a
little bit too
is it F7 or E6 oh my God Knight F7 might
be even better with Knight takes c65
that looks even more destructive because
you also have a queen H5 check in there
as well so I feel like Black's position
is falling where he takes on E6 it's
still good for white and look at akaro
he's shaking his head Hikaru is feeling
the pressure from niho right now it's
the first time all match where I feel
like Niha has been able to string
together consecutive performances and I
I think that Hikaru is starting to feel
a little bit nervous and I'm stating the
obvious but it's hard to believe Robert
I think you'll back me up on this if Neo
wins this game it's only a two-point
match like a queen it looks like he car
was pulled away Queen G4 where's the win
Queen G4 looks great what's the move for
black
there's no move Queen G4 Knight C5 I
think is forced and then you can sack
The Exchange oh and you should be
winning there
absolutely winning just controlling all
the uh diagonals Rook C7 looks great as
well as you're pointing out Queen G4
Knight C5 can you play B4 does he have
time for that that's what I'm wondering
yeah B4 is very natural apparently wait
Bishop A8 Queen 8 and then B4 do I have
that oh but don't play Queen Bishop a
queen a rook C5 because you might run
into an Intermezzo with Queen C8 at the
end of that actually it works for white
oh my gosh so is that The Prudent option
does black have any shenanigans that
we're not seeing let's show it let's
show that variation with Bishop support
please
Rook takes c56 is loose it is a
Desperado
sorry no that's funny that's actually
like a funny line probably best for
black but even that is the minimum upon
down with a weak
and you can't take back with the bishop
you have to accept further weakening of
your Pawn nihal has to convert this and
get him a broken record I've said that
phrase so many times today but this end
game I think is eminently convertible
let's see if Hikaru even finds Rick take
C3 that's not obvious either no because
after the Whiteboard Bishop A's been
played in Hikaru he resigned last game I
could see him resign just because he's
so fed up with the position but there's
still four minutes in change in this
time here it's Queen F3 connect your
queen and Bishop white is up two healthy
pawns with a safe King this game is over
and look at Hikaru right he's like
wiping the sweat off his forehead and
there's very few players in the world
who can make a card Nakamura sweat nihal
sarin is one of them I haven't used the
t word all day but H5 is the first tilt
move that I've seen from Hikaru it's a
frustration move it's not as serious a
defensive attempt as Queen takes A8 and
again I don't really see any all's
hesitation Queen F3 maybe he's is
worried about the Knight jumping into D3
and I think that actually is hikaru's
idea Queen f393 but I feel like White's
spoiled for Choice there even Bishop D5
Robert after Knight D3 with Queen F5 to
follow is again basic Brian Bishop D5 I
mean like you're saying wow completely
winning right now it just ends Bishop D5
is Elementary my dear Watson and the
queen F5
picks up the Rook with Checkmate to
follow and look at it he is really upset
right now and so if you're a knee-haul I
think you're gonna get another three
minute game and you're happy about that
even if you get the black pieces in that
one without a waiting white smooth yeah
I mean Bishop E6 Bishop F7 is game D
Hall is absolutely happy about getting a
chance to make this a one-point match
unreal I truly thought Hikaru was gonna
pull away after he just secured a four
point lead but I think Neil also has to
remain calm I'm not too worried about
him remaining calm I'm worried about
myself I'm amped right now after those
games but if nihal gets a little bit too
you know confident boarding a cocky then
your car with the white pieces of course
can beat him and then we're talking
about a three-point lead heading into
bullets so I think the players are
struggling to rematch at the moment but
either way this will be the final game
of this time segment yeah as long as
they manage to rematch in the next two
and a half minutes
they'll be okay you can see some
frustration there for Hikaru it's been
building up over the last couple of
games and for nihal sarin a golden
opportunity right now Robert you said
amped I am amped for this bullet segment
this is going to be absolutely Epic Man
it really will be I mean look at Hikaru
he has played some amazing defense has
found some great tactics and nihal just
what it looked like things were getting
out of hand he is fighting back Neil's
showing that he is resilient not just a
good precise player who will grind down
an end game he's displaying great
tactical awareness himself that E6 game
I mean that probably Remains the game of
the match with three Pawns in the sixth
rank but either actually Hikaru is then
defending that game where he was dead
lost with all those past pawns both of
those matches uh games excuse me compete
for game of the match but right now we
do have a match that's the most exciting
part and E4 by Hikaru it's showing that
he remains serious and he can no longer
just mess around with A3 and H3 and
another differing opening Choice the car
we're going solid I like that approach
he says listen I'm gonna go for night
Scotch I'm gonna go risk management and
this is not a line that you play just to
make a draw David paravian would have
something to say to that but it's a line
you play if you really want to avoid
losing I like this decision from Hikaru
and let's see how well prepared nehal is
in this super topical line where you
take twice on C3 and take on C6 and it's
funny because the preparation is only
starting right this is all really well
known the 14 moves deep and here
Blacklist Bishop G6 so the point is that
C6 is falling regardless let's offer a
trade of light Square Bishops a bishop
pair can be an advantage but if you're
just left with one dark Square Bishop
against Knight and F6 it's maybe not the
most worrisome thing yeah and in such
positions white claims that well the
bishop offers him a long-term Edge but
if black plays carefully if black uh
does not let this long diagonal pressure
get out of hand uh there should be
absolutely no problem let me just take
on D3 and go Rook fe8 Robert it just
doesn't seem like black has any problems
here whatsoever just don't play Rook D6
and fall for Bishop A3 oh here Rooks in
the same diagonal uh you lose one of
them for a bishop so Rook fe8 is a very
safe
nice move Bishop takes F6 is not scary
you have your queen defending it from C6
so just use the open files to your
advantage not only is it not scary in
the event of an end game Black's Pawn
structure is visually worse but Black's
Rooks will be more active and things
could actually get out of control for
white nehal does take on D3 now Robert
the drawback is of course that you're
opening up the C file there could be
some pressure on C7 but a well-timed
knight D5 could come to the rescue let's
see how nehal handles this queen E6
maybe the threatened back rank made in
the event of Rook C7 although Queen E6
there could be a timely Rook B7 you have
to worry about so he goes right after
the D3 Pawn protecting C7 and Willy take
with the queen on F6 that's the big
question because we might see a queen
Swap and after gf6 I feel like white is
the side for choice because Black's King
side pawns are a little bit worse I
guess nihal should have taken back with
the pawn I think he's underestimating
the potency of hikaru's pressure on his
Queen side and you can't afford to just
give up the CNA pawns you have to cling
to them and then black might start
paying the price for his damaged
kingside structure black Strokes do not
manage to reach their full potential in
terms of activity and Rook A3 going
right after the A7 Pawn if you push C
six or C5 that Rook on C1 takes that
pawn and Rook D4 comes to mind let's go
after the H4 Pawn but still I'm gonna
take on A7 C7 is loose and I'll get a
queen side passer
and you can consider Rook to C4 even
with one pair of Rooks white Superior
activity might shine through even more
although Rook C4 may be blacks in time
to swap play rookie one checking C1 to
get active points just in time and
that's very easy to miss you all
offering a draw Hikaru is like no way
Jose
why in the world would a car accept a
draw here right now that's a weird draw
for no losing chances but the position
if you take on C7 we get an end game
where white is essentially a pawn a head
even though its material is level right
Rook C7 swap swap take on D3 it's three
Pawns in a rook versus three pounds in a
rook black has these double I said
f-pawns which means you cannot create a
pass Pawn of your own so nikaru is
playing with zero risk he's just trying
to calculate the end game that gives him
the best winning chances
and maybe I'm reading too much into this
but maybe that was a statement draw for
that maybe that was nehal saying you
know what I know you're not going to
take this draw but I'm showing you that
I'm confident 100 confident in my
ability to hold this game there's an
interesting idea here Robert which was
to take on C7 and then swing The Rook
back to A1 try to get behind the pawn
but black would have blockaded the pawn
on its initial Square from A3 Hikaru
judges that there are no winning chances
there and he tries to keep all four
Rooks on the board yeah and the black
king maybe should join the party at some
point uh you can go King f8 King D7 or
King to d8 to keep C7 protected and free
up your Rook on E7 or you can bring your
king up the G file and try to activate
it that way instead a neopas rook B4
let's get active if you allow two Rooks
on the second rank your toast so Ricardo
plays Rook to C2 just to defend that
pawn on G2 and also the pawn NATO very
alert we saw Magnus win a ton of these
types of end games throughout the SEC
and in his other tournaments hikara was
also a magician in these slightly better
end games his main problem though Robert
is that his pawns are now a liability
every time you play a move like Rook AC3
and you go after black spawns black
anchors himself to White spawns and
you're running into the problem of
inability to make progress yeah you take
mine I take yours thanks for the trade
and you will have an essentially an
extra Pawn in the end game but it's not
enough in this rookie and we actually
saw Magnus hold a game like that against
Fabiano uh one of the games that didn't
go magnus's way so here Rook C7 we'll
see a swap swap Rook takes A2 that
should be sufficient Rook seat four is
there a rook G4 check done you that
needs to be taken care of you read my
mind and nihal read your mind and plays
H5 just to make sure that's not an
option
King G3 so maybe at some point that
white King's activity can be useful but
the black king could always step up to
G6
and Rook to D7 another cautious alert
moved by nehal hitting where it hurts
forcing the pawn up and I think Rook D1
essentially forces The Rook trade
and maybe Hikaru thinks that's a better
version of the single Rook end game
I don't know I thought Rook D1 kind of
forced things but he just goes King G6
and says I'm not afraid of this position
as it currently stands yeah Rook D1 if
Rook C to C4 it's just so awkward Rook
D2 and suddenly you get very careful
yeah rookie seven rookie two and before
long
might be the one playing for a win
what's going on here oh oh a car's
taking a bit of a risk and look at nihal
he's looking at this quizzically he's
like wait a second okay seven bail out
wait but rookie seven ah okay you're
saying rookie he said Rook takes and
Rook takes F7 good call Buddy listen
that's terrifying could land on the
fifth rank you have a check there on a
five but suddenly he cars don't want us
to be careful he kind of leans back in
disgust and can nehal make a push here
Rook E7 what is the plan from Hikaru I
guess we're about to find out he's got
23 minutes to figure out a plan we know
what niho's plan is it's to go rookie
too play for mate oh my gosh he's in
trouble now he's worse
rookie rookie two for sure you're
winning G2 and D4 and A2 you you win all
the pawns but hikari's gonna try to win
all of black spawns or at least the F7
Pawn just enough I think to make a draw
I think Hikaru is holding this oh barely
Rook D4 King E3 only move it's almost
Checkmate in fact maybe Rook G to E2
first can you get away with that I was
thinking about that Rook takes F7 you
take D4 the king hides back on H4 check
and the white guys four and nihal trying
to figure this out he does keep some
time on his clock
take Auntie Forge H4 check
but what now yeah that's the people Rook
F2 maybe Rook a three oh that Rook no no
one was The Rook oh Rook G7 check first
yep
and maybe Rook G4 here no Rook G4 Rook
F3 check what am I talking about nihal
dodging and Meandering his way around
but it's a forced repetition the king
can't step to F4 as you're saying so we
end this portion with a two-point lead
for Hikaru you would think hey a car
must be happy he's winning heading into
bullet but he looks just a bit upset is
that a USA is that nihaw wearing a USA
shirt I think it was
[Laughter]
oh my goodness what an end to this time
control Donya
incredible and again if you told Hikaru
without him knowing the Arc of the match
hey you're gonna be up nine and a half
seven and a half going to the bullet you
wouldn't be thrilled but he'd be okay
with that score but given where this
match was he had a four point lead he
had all of the momentum he was ready to
bring the hammer down and put the match
away suddenly nehal is within two wins
of tying this match ladies and gentlemen
do not go anywhere cancel your
engagements we are in for 30 minutes of
Unforgettable bullet action
everybody should stay right where they
are you know as we had to break but they
should also remember to tune in on
December 21st for many huge
announcements get ready for the Q4 2022
stateofchess.com coming to you live on
December 21st we have some huge news for
the chess community and the event will
be followed by a Community Q a with
Danny wrench plus some very special
guests will be joining the show to talk
about the exciting announcements we're
making and what these announcements mean
for the future of the chess Community
don't miss the show December 21st at 10
A.M Pacific Time right here on twitch.tv
chess Daniel daradetsky and I will be
right back for the coverage of the
bullet portion of this epic match
between Hikaru Nakamura and nihal Saran
foreign
[Music]
makes shows like this possible which is
why our twitch subscribers will never
see ads on chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done a
hundred percent ad free Bliss
forevermore whether you're following our
events on site or on stream type the
command connect in the chat and thank
you for helping bring these shows to
life
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
as we get back here to the semi-final
matchup between a car Nakamura and nihal
sarin here at the speed test
Championship so much is at stake in fact
there's a spot in the finals on the line
and the winner of this match will take
on the winner of Magnus Carlson versus
Maxime vashir legrov that Carlson versus
happening tomorrow but Dania no matter
who gets through it is going to be tough
sledding ahead
it most certainly is we have an epic
bullet segment ahead of us you see it on
the scoreboard it's nine and a half
seven and a half just about as close as
it could possibly be and Robert we could
have been singing a very very different
tune I dare say we were expecting to
sing a different tune and instead nihal
has put himself in Prime position to
score one of the greatest upsets in SEC
history if you can keep his momentum
going especially when he had a four
point deficit that was wild I mean he
won two games in a row he almost took a
third but for a car Nakamura he got that
break he can settled down now and just
play bullet now bullet is a toss-up
Hikaru Nakamura is as great of a bull
player as we've ever seen But nihal
sarin often is at the top of the bullet
leaderboard some of it due to hyper
bullet 10 seconds per side that's just
not even chest at that point but with
that one minute plus one second
increment I think that should favor
Hikaru do you agree that hikar was the
favorite in this bullet I do but as the
games kick off I've played New Hall in a
ton of games with a 10 second time
control plus one second increment and he
is incredible maximizing his last one
two seconds so I actually think both of
these players are going to be amazing at
this time Patrol I think we're going to
see some very high quality games and a
superpositional choice by Newhall in the
first bullet game what do you make of
this I think it's a very good choice
because he finds his comfort zones we've
seen him play the Black the white side
excuse me the Queen's game accepted and
other variations where he feels at home
like Rook C5 a big move from Hikaru and
the queen just drops back saying well
what's your Rook doing there it let the
queen go but the Rook on C5 just
awkwardly plays his card is playing some
fluency with the typical ideas but the
problems that White's got this massive
clamp on the D5 score marozzi bind style
and a night landing on D5 could not only
pressure E7 Robert but lead to the very
favorable trait of dark squared Bishops
for white that's true and Bishop A3 like
forces The Rook back you can't go to C7
because the Knight D5 he starts with
Knight D5 and the Knight on six is ultra
well defended that's important the 97
covers you don't get the shatter black
spawn structure and you certainly don't
want to cooperate with the trade once
the dark squared Bishops disappear
you've got long-term problems with your
king and your remaining Knight is going
to be passive knee-haw keeps tightening
the screws and tightening the Noose that
he's up on time as well yeah Knight
takes D5 is a big question because
Knight D5 Bishop takes G7 Knight takes
E3 it is pandemonium there but instead
he goes A6 B5 we saw that happens
yesterday but I think black is actually
getting the advantage here great stuff
by hikar it's easy to miss that moment
but he's creating Mega counter play on
The Queen side so maybe a calm move is
required a knee-haw playing anything but
calm Knight to D5 and we've got
pandemonium it's great bullet chest
Bishop H6 there is a pawn push to stop
the checkpoint on G7 so it's not like
your car isn't too grave of danger B
takes C4 if Bishop then there's Pawn to
C3 you get away with that as well oh
careful now if you're a knee-hole that's
so easy Miss BC probably has to meet up
with BC but Robert then you've got to
reckon with the threat of A3 which comes
all of a sudden and Hikari
H6 and just force F6
and maybe I'm thinking about like C5 C5
spells of tactics but I can't quite put
my finger on it maybe C5 start with C5
because after C5 DC there's also Bishop
E5 distracting The Rook from the Queen's
defense so you don't even go for
Checkmate on G7 you're going instead
after the night New Hall is investing
his time can he find C5 and he does not
he wants to take out of sack take a
decent Bishop what am I a good decision
yeah that's you the Knight also has
trapped on B4 A3 there's Knight C6 of
the queen of B2 is losing almost trapped
he moves the queen now A3 is a huge
threat I don't see a defense against it
if you lose the Knight you basically
lose the game he can't save his Knight
oh my land he defends C6 is Queen D5
check to win the knight at C6 right away
so five seconds one second he's got a
move and he doesn't figure out a defense
he's trying to take on E2 instead okay
but just Queen H6 Queen H6 was winning
oh he misses it but he's still in good
shape Rook A6 Rook D7 check to follow
you win the F6 pawn it feels like you
have a vicious attack but then black
would win B4 and C4 nehal trying to
cling to his pawns taken and go B5
that's the Practical choice
and look at the passive defense my Karu
Saves the Day
not yet though Rook b60 Hall still
keeping his foot on the gas pedal but
not to no avail
unbelievable another defensive save with
a mere two seconds on his clock more or
less Hikaru Nakamura is surviving and
how many chances like this are you gonna
get maybe another one in this game yeah
look at the passive defense by ikaru no
it's a draw it's a draw and queen H6
there Robert that was the turning point
he traded Queens too quickly but how can
you blame him Holy Smoke City we're
gonna milk off as much time as he can
Hikaru is a grizzled veteran of the SEC
format he knows that there's not going
to be a quick draw and niho great with
the mouse speed he's just gonna move
quickly oh
my gosh
oh he scared him
there are no words he just scared him
and he won the rook and won the game and
now he has a three-point lead
I'm trying to I'm opening my mouth but
well not even a sound is coming out oh
my goodness that was incredible
just oh terrible terrible mistake in
bullet and now nihal he's gonna have to
somehow right the ship emotionally and
then over the board just a total mental
collapse and you know what it was niho
was getting annoyed because you got the
worst type of position that Hikaru can
milk for another one or two minutes but
so what there's plenty if there's any
eternity left on the match clock two
minutes ain't gonna make a difference
you can't blunder your Rook like that
and not to mention the fact that it was
completely winning for any haul this is
looking bad again Robert he needs
something crazy to happen right now A
draw something except a loss because
it's going to be back to a four point
match if he loses this game yeah still
plenty of time in the match yeah oh yeah
cannot afford to lose this one I agree
with you there and why do you look at
the Box you have the bishop pair I
wasn't even oh no Bishop E3 and queen C4
I think looks pretty devastating
good defense
C3 just move your Bishop back four and
queen B3 oh gosh an A5
so he has A6 yeah you can't take him
before so it goes Bishop D6
oh no
the only good news for black in this
position is that they're like no more
targets
well he's about to make some targets so
he's gonna go King 96 and Knight C5
holding on to that B7 Pawn you cannot
lose that pawn bishop C5 again
he goes Knight C5 I didn't like that one
what about Bishop takes E5 you've got an
eternal pin on the E6 Knight I thought I
should have kept that pin and maneuvered
his own Knight around to D3 but anyways
better Knight D4 what's wrong with that
yeah Queen C4 drop your king back you're
okay
exactly something like that but the C A5
Pawn will also be loose in some
positions so
what a match we have here Knight D4
played this would be a big hole for
nehal
oh huge and that might give him the
confidence he needs to write the ship as
you said take some Bishop C it looks
like the best ikaro can try but if the
Queens get traded it's just a drawn
anything but a car will waste a ton of
clock
okay so Bishop C8 going right for the
pawn Knight F3 King F3 the king is very
safe even if it looks out in the open
Queen DEC Quincy well Quincy seven
there's Bishop takes B7 so I don't think
you're actually saving the pawn although
you're trying to take A5 yeah but
Black's King also in a scary position
get away with this queen E6 he drops his
King back but that's an admission Queen
before the worst is behind him I think
what's wrong before no it's an instant
draw
okay okay goes here Queen D5 Queen D6
holding on
and now Queen C8 and the Queen no don't
take it Bishop G8 oh
oh Hikaru is starting to make inroads
Robert I have a bad feeling about this
yeah King's Paramount in bullet and the
king is not safe on f8 good move
generally you're yeah
we need six coming to a theater near you
it's done
oh my gosh Queen G8 goodbye all of the
pawns are lost every single one of them
take Queen E6 taking off six oh oh you
resigned get out of here that's a four
point lead four point lead for card
Nakamura He is building that separation
after being gifted a rook in the first
bullet game nihal will have to find it
within himself to claw back in this
match I liked what he got in this
position the first time around
but it's unbelievable what Hikaru is
doing he's turned it around yet again
and nihal needs yet another push can it
he start with one Victory you gotta play
one point at a time but you've got
plenty of time Robert you don't need to
look at the match clock and start
panicking 21 minutes is an eternity in a
bullet match it is and what just
happened there quick move by
he's not filing B5 and take out C4 but
the Knight did go over to the queen side
that's good news and now we're gonna see
some trades I just feel like Niha has
lost that verb that gumption with which
he was playing the last segment of the
three-minute match that loss really did
him in Rook C3 is a great move though
he's maneuvering it to E3 and then watch
out for 1966 tactics okay but Hikaru
brings it out to F6 to defend that Rook
on eight on E excuse me Queen goes to A8
this time and queen B2 King can just
slide back to Jeep maybe there's a
knight takes D6 taxi to look out for
absolutely and it can be supplemented or
preceded by Rook F3 Hikaru pushing D5
very alert Knight B6 there's Queen C6
looks like Black's okay there it's gonna
be 95. yeah 95 is going to the center of
the board Knight D7 was a threat so the
king slides back
and once again a knight reaches D3 for
Neo the queen may be centralizes to D4
no he wants to pressure the puns yeah he
wants H5 as well
and then H6 threatens Knight T5 H5 looks
really good
gotta do it maybe G5 he's worried about
wow that's a huge move and there still
might be H6 like Rook takes E7 but I
guess for now it doesn't work but it's
something to be scared of what did you
eat for breakfast jeez I really needed
I'm really go for it right now yeah car
wants E5 I think
but that doesn't threaten anything no it
doesn't
but D4 is actually a thread
oh it is
bad news for nihal
oh yay
Rook F3 seems forced and now Knight G4
or what yeah Knight G4 Knight C5 to E4
maybe but uh whoa he goes that way he
wants into C3 or potentially G5 that's
actually a super super astute move and
it's hard to deal with wow what a move
going the center of the board and Rook
see when he was a second exchange on C3
so Queen D6 play Queen f8 coming next he
smells blood he smells blood Robert and
Knight G5 is now a threat F6 has been
deprived of the white Rook oh my
goodness and Neil can't find a move he's
got seven seconds it's over
there's Queen C2 taking over the C5 but
Knight G5 traps The Rook but what is
this Rook C7 then he's gonna B4 he has
to
D3 potentially D3 looks great
Queen D2 you're forced into passivity
your car disrupting chiseling knifing
his wings wait there's some chances here
for white because of that pawnage stick
he gave it oh what pawn on H6 oh I'm
shocked that he didn't play Queen D2
there he's banking on his past beep on
and he wants tactics on the queen side
no you're doing everything he can but
this is not the way Knight takes E4 F6
D3
no no no no no no what was FG
oh my goodness this is collapsed
collapsed by knee-hole
and look at it milking the clock yeah a
car like can win this game in many
different ways but he wants to spend
that time pretending like he's thinking
exactly
Queen DHS would win a rook but it would
lose the game I think Hikaru again maybe
I'm reading too much into this I think
he's doing he is doing this deliberately
he's not winning in the fastest way to
milk some more time I feel like he's so
confident he can win this in any way but
Queen G4 check keeps some chances alive
yeah you can keep the pawn
are you though no you're not maybe you
want 86. that's clever can you three
Rook C3 check
Rook G4 you blundered the juice
what's he doing King C40 car gave up a
draw B7 to be immediately the night the
Knight reaches F3 in time that is really
insane is this easy though
oh I lost it we moved his knife what was
Knight H2 just defend it with your king
knee-haul oh my gosh King G2 traps the
Knight literally and Hikaru now again
milking the clock the guy is has to
resign there he does he does but wow 17
and a half minutes remaining is still
technically possible mathematically
possible for a nihal to get back in this
match but things are going from bad to
worse for the youngster from India
and there was some crazy end game
tactics there that niho may have
overlooked it's a five point lead the
biggest lead of the entire match has
come at the worst possible moment Robert
nihal he still has a chance but he needs
to be perfect starting yesterday
he needs to win this game that's for
sure he puts A5 trying to open up the
queen side uh but I don't think there's
enough going on the position play F5
I'll try to create some Dynamic play but
look at this Dania I mean it's a closed
position black is the side for choice
but you can play this forever
and not to be the bearer of bad Tidings
for Newhall but I've played Hikaru so
many times I can sense when he smells
blood and right now he smells blood he
believes beyond a shadow of doubt that
he's gonna win this match and at some
point I think Nee Hall managed to sow
some doubt any car is mine but that
doubt has dissipated the lead has grown
and I'm being starting to get very
skeptical here about newhall's combat
chances you mean you didn't like the
Petrosian King Marshall we just saw
h8 to B7 good reference and it's also a
good idea but the problem for Neil he's
got to play G6 H6 G5 at some point but
White's also ready to open up the king
side like if you play G6 white might
play H5 so you have to be careful about
that
you might recall that gosh Robert I
forget which match it was but there was
a bullet match where they only played
like five bullet games total so with 16
minutes left on the match clock you're
in territory where you're starting to
get worried about literally not having
five games to play and this is gonna
take an hour yes oh my God this is the
worst thing possible because the car is
going to build up his clock and sit it
out for at least a minute
the worst part for nihal is if he
pre-moves and he keeps pre-moving a car
will play G4 I mean he won't do that
because he's winning in the match but
you know what I mean that's what I would
do in a bullet game that I needed to win
and at some point just throw in a move
but Hikaru is not pre-moving he's just
moving quickly so if you're Neil you
wait until the car pre-moves a couple
times and then throw in a G5 or an E5
but yeah this is just a dead draw yeah
that's the classic technique without
increment but with increment there's no
need to pre-move if you're either
opponent but especially if you're Hikaru
and look at fun Master Mike getting
involved this stall is going to be
longer than Dino's in chess boxing while
there is no hide and seek because
there's nothing to seek in this position
it's all locked up there's no Pawn
pushes that are good for either side
we're playing checkers look at all the
blacks pieces on light squares and white
species on dark swears whoa wait why is
it's so funny in closed positions when
the Evo bar shifts like this is I know a
dead draw what did it see like E4 and G4
Queen B3 no
and Hikaru well within his right to do
what he's doing I mean
you're milking valuable time and at some
point before she reaches the 50 move
we'll remind you that if 50 moves are
made without a pawn advance and without
a capture a draw is automatically
declared so at some point Hikaru should
literally sit for a minute and I think
he's chosen this moment to do it the
next move is the draw
not yet no it's only move 83. when was
the last move wasn't B4 play to move 34.
oh 34. yeah oh and what just math it's
like wagering in Final Jeopardy so that
you're one dollar ahead of the guy of
the guy in second place that's what
Hikaru is doing he's taking the last
possible move to sit it out and he's
taking every one of these seconds Robert
every single one of them yes indeed
because time is precious and now the
match clock down to 13 minutes 51 50 49
and that will not leave enough time for
nihal if he cannot win games in a row
and win them quickly
well with five games to play I'll let
somebody in the chat who's more
qualified do the math is there even
enough time to start five games there
probably is if you can get a quick win
but quick win and Hikaru they do not
belong in the same universe Robert
and I wonder like if you're a car if you
just do something funny no he plays
Queen B1 it is a draw 50 move rule
without a pawn push or a capture that's
how the rule Works in chess so now we
get April Lopez with Berlin Mia on the
white side right that was for second I
thought his car was white oh
oh that is a move though I guess I first
over a second I thought he blundered his
Bishop but C5 was hanging
and now he car is just playing with so
much speed and confidence it's brutal
yeah couldn't play D5 because the E5
Pawn is loose he's gonna play f46 or no
he's not gonna play F4
I think Queen B6 is practical but nihal
could play Queen F3 there to keep the
Queens on the board
but again one of those positions that's
going to take a while for anything to
even start happening
G4 maybe just throw the pieces forward
yeah gotta try something like that
F5 not available to Black is EF and then
G4 so Bishop E6 is the choice and D4
yeah white is slightly better here but
this game is going to take forever
no it is and Hikaru has been playing
really quickly partially because he
wanna he wants to give himself that time
if he's losing he's gonna sit it out for
at least a minute
and look at their bullet ratings Hikaru
3280 at 32-11 both these Superstars uh
amongst the best on the site uh maybe
Magnus can try to lay claim to the
number one rating but it's amongst those
three are really a nice hey hey I know a
commentator might have something to say
about that oh what's your what's your
bullet rating at right now it's like 33
15. oh but I dropped some yesterday I
was trying to get them at my place
before this match because I knew a car
was gonna he's gonna get up to 3 400. I
take it back indeed uh but okay take it
back you said Magnus is better than me
Robert you get out of here how dare you
well I didn't mean to leave you out from
uh the conversation this position Daniel
look at this slightly better for white
control of the open D file you can move
your knight and play Rook D1 go put a
rook on D7
this is just going to be the longest
game yeah take a nap put that in your
pipe and smoke it nihal looking at the
match Clock IT ticks down second by
deadly second it's down to 11 minutes
Robert and we're not even close to a
resolution in this game no and let's not
forget he has to actually win them too
yeah that's what's often left out of
these conversations white is ever so
slightly better and Rook C5 next does
feel annoying because there's gonna be
pressure on the pawn and if you
particularly The Rook there's a pin
going on so okay Rook C5 you can't go
Rook B6 to the Knight C8
yeah he should be winning here at least
close to winning
84.
Rook D6
get in there but there's also these B
takes C4
that's the problem like the B file opens
up and White's pawns fall
and knee-hole letting his clock run down
to six seconds
that increment is just killing him right
it's killing him yeah and he's you know
trying to make progress pieces look good
but unfortunately there's nowhere to go
and thanks to the about 50 000 of you
watching across all platforms twitch
YouTube wherever you're watching if you
appreciate you 97 Knight C5 and Knight
C5 was winning wow and it still is
pushes the pawn look at white going for
an attack and now all of a sudden niho
with the advantage FS Newhall has to
cash this in quickly they're an F6 it's
a moment
I there definitely is and if black
panthers Rook G2
oh he's going up with the King
oh no two absolutely car holding
King's going F6 oh my goodness
what are you gonna do about that
King H5 Kia four kf4 H4 King H oh
another retreating Crusher by nihal Sir
and he finally wins a bullet game and
with nine and a half left Hikaru well
hey you got to be a little bit careful
anything can happen it's the SCC for
goodness sakes it certainly is nicaro
he's not gonna take his lead for granted
and we just saw a couple of ladder mates
like that yesterday and wait what's
going on with the car five minute game
has been has been initiated yeah wise is
a five minute game akar was just like
come on let's restart where's our team
start let's get this we started please
nihal has to lobby for the match clock
to be brought up to around 9 30. just
like in basketball if it's an illegal
play in the shot clock and the game
clock came down you got to bring it back
up
yeah let's uh get this restarted let's
get the match clock back yeah okay so
it is being rectified yep as we speak as
we speak and here we go I'm sure the
time will be added back on the clock
that was neither of the players faults I
would imagine
um so here we go we see the same exact
opening E4 under attack protected by
Knight to D2 white has more space a
strong Center but black is just playing
for an offbeat opening and good job
there by the producers pausing the match
clock for the appropriate amount of time
and rectifying that situation for anyhal
every single second is absolutely golden
and I like what he's gotten out of the
opening here yeah this reminds me of his
uh match Again Sam said to it right
there Sam said from the global
Championship where he actually was out
playing Sam in some of these positions
with the black piece in must win
territory so Bishop goes to H3
threatening nothing Queen C5 check as
you mentioned is available and now it's
becoming more dangerous for white wait
and Hikaru wait Queen oh he missed it
yeah Queen C5
and then what
and then you forced you'd Force the king
to H1 you could take on D1 the bishop
would have to take back
white species now Knight F5 Knight F5
was a huge threat winning the queen and
I feel like at this point his initiative
has fizzled away
certainly has yeah the 9h5 kind of
awkward can't jump forward
it doesn't work because the Rook takes
you one check check
we both have the same blunder in mind
exactly we complete each other's
sandwiches and blunders we are really a
dedicated pair so Rook A1 a kind of sad
defensive move but does the trick and
yeah Hikaru is no real problem he's no
Bishop F1 at some point
yeah and if you have even one of those
super long games that takes four minutes
the match is instantly over eight
minutes the match clock is in eight
minutes and you all still has four more
victories to score this ain't looking
good yeah good luck winning this game I
mean this is limited material
and Good Luck winning it in under an
hour
he's trying Knight A4 is a nasty little
one okay Queen E2 how does the black
queen get in that's the big question
five
Queen E6 may be trying to get into B3
all of this all of these are one move
threats I mean Hikaru could just play
Queen C2 or Knight D1 whatever he's got
enough to defend with
I feel like there's like some Ivanka
game against Leonard Dominguez that was
sort of like this where black end up
winning the game just because white was
so passive maybe there's a car against
Dominguez actually and I think about it
but either way it's not pleasant for
white but you just sit on the position
and icaro is sitting on the position
he's sitting on the clock it's hit seven
minutes now
and G4 I mean a car trying to whip up
some chances against black skin now wait
a second he could still win this game
yeah HG Knight takes G4 Knight H1 and
Knight G3 wow and of course he's
instantly instantly oh and this is a
Crusher Robert because where's the 99 A4
it's in stuck in Siberia yeah and you
know Conti monsters hosts many chess
tournaments but it's not really where
you want to be if you can avoid it so
Knight G3 to F5 is what's on the docket
H5 is also loose and that Knight on B2
goes to C4 to the queen trade with
Knight to five check yeah but you can
also play Queen A7 I think you're
winning when that F5 Queen H6 there must
be a move here oh Queen chicks is Queen
E2 oh King H3 escapes the checks and no
stopping the mating attack
or just Queen D7 wow he's just gonna mop
up the Pawns and another minute goes off
the match clock
and it's basically official wait Queen
bb6 Jack
this can't be good no come on D6 and
whatever Knight G3 Knight E4 Knight C5
looks pretty sound
oh wait why is this King around King E6
and an F5 check
and somehow this game is not over but
the age which is actually bad for knee
Hall even if he wins it at this point
which he's not going to yeah and now
it's also winning for icaro H6 H6 ends
it or this taking B5 and promoting the
connected passers on the queen side yeah
car Nakamura deserves a round of
applause he wins this game he locks up
the match I mean it looked like he was
cruzing right he was up by four points
of some moment then Neil strikes back
with two in a row and in that first
bullet game that's where this match was
settled right nihal could have won it
and said he lost it by blundering his
Rook that a lot of the leads to grow to
three and hikar Nakamura has not looked
back I love how in chess as in a lot of
sports things you can pinpoint the exact
moment when things turned around right I
think that's one of the beautiful things
about these matches is that you can go
back you can look at certain games here
this is exactly the moment the instant
where the match could have turned around
and that instant was when nihal grabbed
hikaru's Queen going into that end game
where Hikaru had good drawing chances as
we have a night sack on f70 Hall still
playing inspired chess but once that
happened
it was basically all over the car was
still not happy Robert what does he want
I mean you're up by five he wants to you
know reach 357 bullet
this looks really terrible for black
your king is white is over E6 is hanging
The Rook on C8 is loose
simple and strong
also black only has uh a piece for two
you know two pawns not even a big
material Edge and your king is being
just ripped apart
wow
it should be six
even Bishop F6 here
mm-hmm
you could probably grab the Rook at some
point yeah Bishop F6 queen queen G4
check actually looks even best and then
Bishop F6 and Rook C that's the proper
order
it could also be Queen G4 Queen G6 and
just go for checkmate
yeah absolutely and and nehal has now
had two games that he's gonna win with
this Knight F7 sacrifice I guess the
other one was the double sack on E6 but
one takeaway is that he's a natural
Robert in these types of positions any
nimso Larsen structures he is just a
wizard he is indeed Bishop takes F6
still completely winning position but
it's going to take most of the remaining
time off the clock and watch out for 92.
now he car Never Dies it's like no
matter how many pieces he's got left
he's gonna find a way to create threats
I mean he ain't trade Queen a keeps the
queen on for now the queen G8 will force
them off it looks like Rook D6
yeah take on H6 take on A6 eat all the
pawns but it's gonna eat up much the
remaining match clock and for nehal I
mean there's a lot to be proud of right
last year he made the semis he lost a
Wesley so in a really close match this
year he made to the semis he knew he was
gonna be an uphill battle against Hikaru
Nakamura but he made Hikaru work for it
this was a really difficult match uh I
think he's given hikar one of the
biggest challenges we've seen from a
player not named Magnus Carlson or
dingley Ren from a year ago without
questioning car's record is 23-2 uh
forget the two matches he lost in Magnus
Carlson Magnus is in a separate bucket
but of those players uh who are going to
constitute the 24 matches that Hikaru
has won I would single out dingly Ren
who perhaps came the closest nihal star
and Robert might be in the top three he
really gave Hikaru a run for his money
and not a lot of people can say that my
match with hikaranakamura really came
down to one game it would have been a
one point match now ikara may very well
have won that match as well as we see
him stalling out the remaining 30
seconds the guy is totally brutal but
nihal really did come that close yeah
that first bullet game that was the
Difference Maker in this match so really
a round of applause to nihal sarin I
know he's going to be a bit disappointed
because that closing the Gap was Within
Reach but still he played so well
throughout this sec I mean he was shaky
in the bullet against Geary he also
against dingley Wren was in a close
match before the bullet and against
Hikaru gave Nakamura the four-time speed
chess champion all he could handle so we
see one last game here we'll see a bomb
Cloud I'm guessing oh no not a bomb
Cloud maybe uh a delayed oh King's
Gambit a throwback opening from ikaru
Vienna and homage to the romantics and
Bishop B5 here is the move
Knight C3 followed by Queen H4 Queen E4
is one of the recommended lines for
black which nehal might be opting for
here mm-hmm
seven
um I guess he wants a quick F7 F6
yes the vulnerable Queen
yeah the king is not castled yet so this
is bad news for Hikaru
could can end The Magic In Style and
with the victory G5 Queen G3
it's close you know it's one of those
moments that you're very fortunate to
have that Queen G3 move and said he's
gonna take on C2 and claim an extra Pawn
I guess
he raps it snags it from pikaru's grasp
and you're absolutely right Robert
U-Haul is going to be disappointed
everybody at this level expects
Perfection everybody expects monster
results he ain't gonna be happy but he
can definitely hold his head up high
this was an edge of your seat match from
start to the very finish several hundred
dollars on the line in this game right
here because uh part of the prize fun is
by win percentage so if nihal can win
this game he'll give himself a little
bit more money I don't think he'll
complain about that but he also probably
enjoys beating Hikaru they oh you're
gonna play much bullet so taking them
down even a few times will feel good for
sure and he's taken him down plenty of
times in this match Bishop E4 94 oh my
gosh there's some crazy five Knight F6
gf6 yeah Queen G3 almost Works in that
position
but not quite black takes it and then
attacks The Rook after Rook takes the a
king F7 so I think U-Haul actually might
take this one
all right Queen D4 good move giant trade
Queens black is up a pawn but look at
that extra Pawn C6 C7 double isolated
and wait a second
it might be doubled and isolated but
it's rearing to go hikar goes after
those doubled pawns I think that was the
right choice because now the e-pawn the
passer is closer to the white king
easier to stop you would kill for that
pawn to be transferred to the a file or
the B file here the king just gets into
the vicinity of the pawn and it looks
like black can't make progress H4 mm-hmm
and it should be a pretty
straightforward draw and another thing I
loved about this match Robert is just
the variety of positions that we got we
got so many different openings we got
tactical battles and positional slug
fests just the variety has been awesome
everyone else still trying yeah he wants
to win this game
uh but as he should he could bring his
real quick don't put him on C3 that's
how you lose this game but like Rook D3
check but used to point out Rook C8
getting behind the pass Bond here comes
the black king
here's Johnny the king infiltrating T4
and then it can move into D3 this is
getting scary
and he car's gonna do what he tried to
do earlier he's gonna give up The Rook
for the e-pawn and promote the H Pawn I
think that it was a win very briefly for
nihal we saw the engine go all the way
up in his favor but rookie two yeah
rookie two even H6 draws
oh King Chief no okay draw yeah it's a
draw well that's
concludes the match in Hikaru nakamura's
favor he wins by four points the final
count is 14.5 10 and a half and even
though a four point match is close and
we only had 25 games that is not a lot
when you think of some of these other
matches because the games went down to
the wire Dania they really did I mean so
many of these games they got down to
time scrambles they could have gone
either way and maybe the Difference
Maker was hikaru's comebacks I mean he
had I would say at the very least three
or four games where he was either
completely lost or just lost it was a
technical win for Hikaru and of course
the game that will stick in our minds
Robert for probably many years is the
game where nehal had a thousand Pawns in
the center and then he blundered his
Queen and then allowed the geometric
Fork on B1 that was a backbreaker as of
course was their second bullet game yeah
just some missed opportunities for nihal
sarin so he could probably you know
regret some of those moments but overall
I think the entire country of India they
love chess these days they can be proud
of Neil sarn he made it to the finals of
the global Championship here he made the
semi-finals and only lost a close match
to Kar Nakamura and well what's up next
for Hikaru we see the bracket we've seen
him take down parabian aronian nihal
Sauron and next up is either Magnus
Carlson
ladies and gentlemen could we possibly
ask for a more satisfying end to I was
gonna say the cgc the cgc had a pretty
satisfying end the SEC is gonna have an
epic ending before makamura siren we
have another very small match Robert I
wish we had stronger players to
commentate on but we're gonna have to
settle for the world champion and the
guy who's beaten him in the SEC
previously that's right the way the
reigning world Blitz Champion Maxine
virtually rough takes on world champion
Magnus Carlson but before all that we
have an interview with the one and only
Hikaru Nakamura please leave your
questions in chat that you have for a
car make them good questions please but
we'll be excited to feature those and
ask Hikaru we're looking forward to
hearing his thoughts as he's the winner
moving on the championship match it's a
card Nakamura after this short break
use gifts not GIFs from the biggest
chest stars on all of your favorite
platforms just search chess.com and your
favorite chess star on Discord Twitter
WhatsApp and more to find hundreds of
gifts from chess.com's biggest broadcast
and events pokemane Ludwig moist
critical xqc and even me Danny try it
today
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
it is an honor to be joined by Hikaru
Nakamura a finalist in this year's speed
Chess Championship Hikaru another
dazzling display I gotta ask how do you
do it when your back is against the wall
in some of these positions how do you
survive and even win positions that look
incredibly lost
yeah I mean obviously it was a very
tough match I think saying that I played
dazzling or saying it was dazzling is uh
a little bit too generous I mean for
large stretches the match Niha was much
better
um I think really the difference in this
match is simply when nihal had some
winning positions whenever I think there
were like one or two moments when he was
down by two games specifically um and he
had a good chance to win when he wasn't
able to get it back from two to one
um and it went back up to three or four
a couple of times I think it's just in
the critical moments he wasn't wasn't as
good but for me you just try to play
Play Moves that's kind of what I was
doing was just just playing moves um
even when it was losing him I mean there
was this one game I think three plus one
where I was completely lost he had all
these Pawns in the center then it's like
somehow he blundered this Fork on E2 and
it still wasn't winning but then he lost
on time I mean the whole thing was was
kind of wild but it was it was an
exciting match so I I enjoyed it
well we'll ask you about that game in a
bit Hikaru but I got to ask you about
your opening choices in the five plus
one what stands behind those choices and
you were actually getting better
positions both with A3 and with H3 was
part of it to create that psychological
tilt effect because you know someone who
doesn't punish that and feel really
frustrated is that part of your decision
making or were you just trying to have
fun
um well I mean I I guess let's just say
I'm a streamer first so I can say this
but frankly I feel very burned out I
mean I I felt burned out probably for
the last like month or so I mean I've
been playing so much chess
um and so going into this match I just
figured I would just play anything and
have some fun
um that's that was sort of the attitude
um and just try to save what little
little I have left in the tank for the
world wrapping and Blitz so that's
that's the short answer
um I seem to get good positions I mean I
think it's because nehal was probably
not expecting me to do this
um and so I think when your opponent
doesn't you don't really get any kind of
Advantage actually the fact that he was
like worse like this this ridiculous
game where I played H3 I think it was
and he just hung this Pawn on e4 I mean
I think when you when you start off
poorly and like you're not even getting
an advantage like I don't think the
result matters that much like even if
it's a draw well you can't improve an
advantage certainly it affects your
opponent a little bit I think
um so that was kind of the rationale
behind it but I wasn't um I was not uh I
didn't do any preparation I just wanted
to play and just like just go from there
so there's nothing really super deep to
it
yeah that makes perfect sense and I
guess I have a question about your
opponent I mean he's been very
impressive uh throughout this year
whether it's the cgc and now here in the
SEC and of course the Olympiad earning a
gold medal on his board like what can
you say about nihal and and what do you
see as his future do you see him as a
future speechless champion
well first things first I was at the
time I thought it was a mistake uh
because I lost a couple of hours of my
life but I'm going to tell you guys a
little story so back during the Fisher
random 960 I think it was maybe the day
of the finals um maybe the first day of
the finals against netball or it was the
day before um but I played near Hall I
think
sorry what's that
oh sorry someone else is talking
whatever anyway okay so as I was saying
sorry one of The Producers just said
something okay um so so I played nehal I
think I played him 960 I also played
regular Blitz but the one thing about
that match was really important is that
there were a couple times that I got a
elite of like two I think it was like
two points uh similar to today and then
nehal kept fighting back he kept like
winning games and so because of that
experience and also in the cgc where I
think he was down against uh savian and
anisha's while the way he was able to
fight back and battle back uh that
really helped me in terms of like sort
of staying folks and trying not to lose
complete control because I knew that
even when it seemed like it was over he
would still fight and so I think the
future was very very bright
um for nihal in general I think that um
that the you know the sky is kind of in
Blitz split specifically and bullet as
well I mean he has he has great
defensive skills he's very good at
finding tactical resources that we saw a
couple times when I have 109 takes off
seven today and uh those names of Larson
setups so uh I think the future is very
bright for him I think the only thing
that probably needs to work on is when
he gets that advantage and those
critical moments just like finding the
killer blow because today there were a
couple moments when he um he had those
chances and he missed them that that was
the difference
so it's a bright future for nehal at the
very least
well that was great insight and now we
want your Insight on that game you
mentioned Hikaru where you seem to be
dead in the water you started showing
signs of life and before you know it you
turned it around and won oh this is a
three plus one game so I guess I'll
start with a true false statement and
you can correct me if I'm wrong was the
moment where you first realized that
maybe this is going off the rails for
Newhall when you managed to muster up a
pass Pawn on the queen side or was it
before
I mean I'm just I'm just praying for a
miracle here even after I get B5 it's
still losing but the problem for nehal
is like once he allows me of the past
spawn he has to shift like before the
passport there's no counter play I'm the
one who's to defend but once I get to go
B5 I know that I'm just gonna push the a
pawn down the board like that's the only
only chance I have so I think once I got
a B5 I mean it's still obviously winning
somehow but the whole sort of the trench
just completely because now nehal is to
be precise and find a couple of moves of
course before that he's just on cruise
control he's just completely winning and
you don't expect to be even remotely
close to me having chances so probably
when he allowed B5 is a little bit
careless
um again it was still probably winning
but that I think when this game went the
wrong way that was sort of the the that
was the first one when it should have
been over uh but then then I made this
uh but then in this the next game I I
was a complete idiot and um at a
critical moment I didn't play B5 with my
Rook on B1 and that led him back in the
match I think if I had played this move
B5 when The Rook was on B1 in the next
game uh the game where I blundered a
bishop pigs Hicks I played B5 explain
before which is losing
um in in that game if I had actually
played B5 and not lost I think that
would have been the match
um so there were a couple of these
moments that were um yeah so go back a
few moves when the Rooks on B1 I saw it
as soon as I as soon as I um yeah as
soon as I played like Queen B3 I think
it was go back like another move go back
go back over there yeah B5 right here if
I play this move I I think takes Rook B5
queen d8 queen B3 and I mean it's very
easy to play for white I'm not saying
it's like winning or anything but I'm
not gonna lose the game I think here I
was up four right
or was that three was it three or four I
don't know what it was but
um but I saw it as soon as I played
Queen B3 and then then of course nehal
found some good moves later and then I
blundered B5 and and that gave him a
chance to come back
um these two games I think were very
very very critical moments um in the
match and uh
yeah it's you know it was a little bit
wild but that's that
yeah no that makes perfect sense and uh
you know her car we have some feature
chat questions for you and the first one
I'm gonna ask is from subliminal who
asks Hikaru what do you think are nihal
strengths as a speechless player and are
they similar to yours
yeah so I mean I think nihals actually
does a couple things that are very
similar first of all he likes to play
all these silly openings his Knight F3
E3 Knight F3 B3 garbage um we both like
to do it I mean there are others too
like our tammyev um who also does it
quite a bit uh so nihal has a very
similar style in terms of his his
opening approach
um I think that you know the openings
are similar I think the time usage is
actually one thing that's kind of
different I think it's a little bit too
slow perhaps it relies too much on being
able to find the best moves in the split
seconds now mind you against most
players it does work
um but I think you know like against
players like myself players like Magnus
or Fabiano who are very very good
Defenders uh I think you need those
extra few seconds to sort of put the
game away so I think that's maybe his
his one weakness I would say um but I
think just the resilience he has
fighting back like we saw in the cgc
um he's just a great fighter and he's
generally I feel like does not tilt I
mean obviously in the bullet he tilted a
little bit here but like once again even
when he was down by four down by three
or four whatever it wasn't three plus
one he didn't just like fall apart and
just lose the match right there so his
resiliency I think is very similar to me
um the way that he's able to just keep
fighting
um so again like I said very very
talented Junior and uh I think you know
in the future people might think of him
the way that they they used to think
about think about me
uh I think it's uh it's gonna it's gonna
be exciting to see what happens uh to
Nee Hall and rapid and Blitz um but he
is the future
well that was great Insight next feature
track question from run Gilbert run
would Hikaru be disappointed not facing
Magnus in the final
I mean I haven't I haven't even really
thought about it honestly
um
I I think uh I I think you know Magnus
is very motivated uh the fact that he
lost mvl I guess it was two years ago I
think it was um when he played in the
the secular he's gonna be very motivated
um so for me I it doesn't really matter
that much you know if this is maybe like
four or five years ago I would secretly
be hoping that mvl wins because I think
that gives me a better chance of winning
the whole match but at this point it
doesn't matter I'm just uh just excited
to play uh play either mvl play Magnus
and go from there but I expect it to be
back
yeah I think uh the predictions of the
community also expect magnets in that
final but we have another really good
question from Juicy Fruit and that
question is do you shift from playing
more positionally to tactically as the
time controls narrow
um you know I thought actually that was
kind of a one of the things that was
that I really struggled with today is
that somehow I felt like I was playing
way too positional and way too slowly in
the five one and even the three one for
that matter there are a lot of games
even in the three one where I was down
like a minute on the clock for for
absolutely no reason I think once we got
to the bullet I started trying to shift
it a little bit but the problem is also
I my tactile Vision was not very good as
as we saw in those like two games where
I hung a knight takes off seven or a
knight takes E6
um so I I tried to just play actually
what I try to do is I just tried to play
more free-flowing but I mean I also I
have to give myself some credit because
I was very good at sort of understanding
the situation like this game um this
bullet game uh it was maybe three games
before the end where I was able to just
like trade all the pieces off and lock
the board up I mean from a strategy
standpoint I was able to like on the Fly
realize that I could play this whole f4h
or G3 stuff
um so I thought I thought that also was
was that was maybe the one thing that I
thought I did very well was the
awareness
um when it was time to kind of like shut
everything down
um
yeah it's just uh it was it was a crazy
match but I did some things well I did a
lot of things badly and if I do play
Magnus or even mdl for that matter I do
think I'll have to be a lot better than
I was today in order
I got one more question for you
paraphrasing Tomo Bedlam one
um I'll phrase it this way when
comparing the various time controls five
one three one one do you feel like your
style consciously changes from
positional to Tactical as the time
control Narrows or is it just about
trying to find the best move regardless
of the time control are you trying to
steer the game in certain Waters based
on the time control
actually you know I I don't think I I
don't think like I'm actually thinking
about I think the the simple way of
putting it is it's there's sort of our
levels of like how much do I care about
playing good chess and how much do I not
care kind of I think in the five plus
one I'm trying very very hard to play
quote-unquote precise chess play like
the perfect moves and so I'm down like a
minute or more on the clock and a lot of
the five plus one games I feel like the
three plus one there's some moment when
like I'm doing the same thing I'm
getting down the clock and finally I
just like enough of this nonsense just
play quickly hopefully the moves are
good enough and go from there so I don't
think it's actually about style I think
it's more about sort of figuring out
like at what point you stop caring about
trying to play Perfect chess and just be
be more of a practical player
yeah that makes perfect sense a car and
well speaking of caring I have a
question for you because you mentioned
that you'll be playing in the world
rapping in Blitz earlier this year you
won the Fisher random World Championship
so adding new titles to the trophy case
how important or how meaningful would it
be to you to win the World Rapid or
slash and the world Blitz
um I mean it would be very nice as with
any tournament I play it's just it's a
joy that I have the opportunity to play
in these tournaments still obviously I'm
a streamer first so I'm just having the
opportunity to still be able to compete
against the best players in the world is
what matters but certainly if I were if
I were able to win one of those it would
be um it would sort of be a cherry kind
of it'd be the cherry on top of the cake
at this point I mean I think already
I've sort of outperformed All my
expectations the way that I played in
the Grand Prix and then the candidates
um I'm actually very very proud of that
probably more proud of my performance in
those those events than I am of winning
the 960 but it would just be it would
really just be the cherry on top of the
cake at this point um but it would be it
would be meaningful it would be really
nice if I could but it won't change much
well I got you we'll be watching your
games carefully hikara even if it's 3
A.M or 4 a.m or whatever ungodly hours
uh the blitz starts in the U.S but have
a safe trip to Kazakhstan good luck and
of course before that good luck in your
final SEC match well there's that
there's also title Tuesday let's not
forget the the world oh yeah
I'll I'll see you there again I'll see
I'll see you in the evening all right
before title Tuesday quick question for
you if you uh you know if are you gonna
watch or who are you rooting for in the
World Cup final I guess that's my uh big
question
um I mean I I have to be rooting for uh
for Argentina I mean that's the that's
the one thing he hasn't won and um and
obviously I've always been a big fan
he's since he's been playing with
Barcelona so I gotta root for Argentina
I think without a doubt um you got to
see the goat win he's got he's got to
win it's just that simple
okay well you heard it from me Carl
rooting for Argentina and Messi will let
you go it Carl we look forward to seeing
you here in the finals of the speeches
championship
thanks you guys have a good one
thank you
well always a great interviewee is
Hikaru Nakamura and always a menace in
the speechless Championship he moves on
to the final where he awaits the winner
of Magnus Carlson and Maxine Russia
legrov and Donya I know a lot of people
think the inevitable is Magnus for
sakaru but Magnus has a very tough task
ahead of him tomorrow facing off against
Maxine vashilograph who beat him two
years ago and I'm gonna say what I said
after magnus's previous match if he
plays the way he did against Bobby I
think even mvl will admit he did admit
uh in the interview that Magnus is
incredibly hard to stop when he plays
like that but nbl's beating him before
and Maxime has been on the ball this SCC
he's made very few blunders he's
demonstrated great opening preparation
and I think he's got the right seven set
of ingredients and the level of
sharpness to give Magnus a serious run
for his money this is not a walkover and
this is more than a worthy match to
watch
no I'll be super exciting to see that
tomorrow that's Friday you know what
you're going to be doing under Friday
it's not going to be working no no no
your chest braids watching this match
and then on Saturday there's also a very
special event that you will not want to
miss either it is the second annual
chess kit All-Star finals it's coming
your way this Saturday December 17th the
world's top Juniors who won the chess
kid monthly championships in 2022
they'll be competing for the title of
Chess kid of the year they can also win
fun prize like lessons with GMS and
merch from our store chess kids own fun
Master mic will hold down the six rounds
of the mesh on chess TV and the chess
kid foot Channel tune in on Saturday
December 17th at 9am Pacific time that's
12 p.m Eastern you will not want to miss
the chess kid All-Star finals but this
is the speed test Champion Dania before
we go I do want to give you some kind of
final words about the match we just saw
so take it away well it's just been an
honor to cover the SEC thus far as I
always say I try to keep the praise
sparing but no nobody I'd rather do this
with the clock just flies by I can't
believe it's already 1 p.m the sun is
out the rain has stopped but ikaro is
going to try to make it rain in the
finals and I think this match really
shows that the match format is so
amazing not just the SEC format in terms
of the time control but just watching
two amazing players going after it again
and again and again it doesn't get
repetitive especially when you get the
different openings and the different
styles of play and when two players who
are in great form butt heads that's what
we saw today but ultimately King Hikaru
emerges Victorious and he will face his
ultimate trial in the next match
well as James Kennedy might say Naka
gonna clock you and he did get through
nihal sarin today and that sets up a
championship match against either Magnus
Carlson or Maxine vashilagrove that
remains to be seen we'll tune in
tomorrow for that Don and I will have
the call so we're excited to bring you
that action tomorrow but for now we say
goodbye we thank you on behalf of
chess.com to the over 50 000 of you that
were here earlier and still remain thank
you so much your viewership is so
appreciative we love helping you learn
and watch and get excited by chess so
until tomorrow this has been Grandmaster
Robert Hess and Grandmaster Daniel
nitzki your name is
yeah I got I got the blooper reel going
for everybody but for real we appreciate
you we'll see you tomorrow
right here on hsn.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there we go
[Music]
[Music]